this eight hour course will teach you
the fundamentals of node.js
and express so you can start creating
backend
and full stack web apps using javascript
this course was created by john smilga
john has created a bunch of courses
including many of the more popular
courses on the freecodecamp youtube
channel
john's teaching is very hands-on so you
will create a bunch of projects while
you're learning
what's up everybody this is john from
coding addict
and welcome to node and express
tutorial video where we'll cover
fundamental building blocks of node
and express js framework now since i
want everyone to be on the same page
we'll start the series with node and
express fundamentals
and gradually move to more complex
topics
we will build complex rest api with
express.js
as well as full-blown mern application
in this comprehensive node.js course
you'll not only learn
fundamentals of node but also many
related technologies
like express.js framework mongodb
as well as mongoose the main goal of the
course is to show you how to build
modern fast and scalable server-side web
applications
with node like in all my other courses
to solidify our knowledge we'll build a
bunch of cool apps
and go through the steps of deployment
as well
lastly let me just say this if you're
like me
and you enjoy learning new tech by
building projects
instead of going through the slides you
will enjoy this course
all right and let's start by answering
the most obvious question first
what is node.js and even though there
are plenty of good answers out there the
one that i like the most is this one
node.js is an environment to run
javascript
outside of the browser node.js was
created in 2009
and it's built on top of chrome's v8
javascript engine as you probably are
aware of
every browser has an engine a tool
that compiles our code down to machine
code
and chrome uses one by the name of v8 in
extremely simple terms
the creator of node ryan dahl
ripped out the v8 engine and build node
on top of it
since the moment it was created node has
evolved
tremendously and while there are many
things to like about node
i particularly enjoy large community
around node
since that tremendously saves time on
feature development
as well as the fact that with the help
of node it's never been
easier to build full stack apps since
both front end
and backend are essentially built in the
same language
and you guessed it that language is our
beloved
javascript as far as course requirements
go
there are not that many my expectation
is that you are familiar with basic
html elements simple css rules
and have general understanding of
javascript
especially es6 callbacks promises
and a sync await since this is a node
course
and i already have tremendous amount of
node content to cover
i'm not going to spend too much time on
javascript language fundamentals
while you can still follow along with
the course without knowing basics
it's crucial if you want to understand
how stuff
works behind the scenes as a side note
if you need to brush up
on the javascript fundamentals i have a
youtube channel called
coding addict where i post a bunch of
cool javascript related content
specifically you might be interested in
js
nuggets playlist where i cover a bunch
of useful
es6 features as well as asynchronous
javascript topics so if you need to jog
your memory
on javascript fundamentals i suggest
going to youtube look for the channel by
the name of coding addict
and then more specifically the playlist
by the name of
javascript nuggets when it comes to
course structure
it goes something like this in first
section we'll get familiar
with node.js as well as my dev setup
in the second section we're going to
install node.js
and quickly cover some general
differences between browser.js
and node.js then we'll spend some time
on
node.js fundamentals in section 3
and after that we'll learn what is
express.js
in section number four and once we're
done
with node and express fundamentals so
once we're done with pleasantries
then we're after the races where
effectively in every section after that
we will build a bunch of cool node.js
apps all right and before we install
node
let's quickly cover some major
differences between browser javascript
and node.js so essentially how node.js
apps
are different from the browser
javascript apps
and let's start with the biggest one
when working on node.js app
you have no access let me repeat no
access to
browser apis since well
they don't simply exist in node there is
no browser
so there's no dom there's no geo
location no fetch
and all the other cool browser goodies
you see unlike browser apps that are
interactive for
example user clicks the button or
toggles the nav and that sort of thing
with node we build server side apps
and i know it's hard to picture that
right now but our
node apps will only consist of pure
logic
without the graphical interface on that
note
you know how in browser apps we use a
bunch of cool things available
on the window object yeah sorry to break
it to you but
that's also not available in node so
at no point in the course we'll write
document.queryselector
all right and once we have covered
things that
node.js does not have let's switch gears
and see some of the goodies that node
has to offer
for example unlike browser we can access
file system
info about our operating system respond
to
network quests just to name a few also
another major benefit of node is the
fact that it's based on
versions so unlike browser apps
which depend on the user's browser
our node app depends only on node.js
version it was built in so in other
words
if we build a browser app and if our
user's browser does not support a
specific feature
it is our responsibility to fix it
otherwise our app
might have bugs correct but when we're
done building our node app
there's no rule that we have to upgrade
to a newer
node.js version and possibly break our
app
we simply can keep running our node app
in the version
it was built in and without any worries
go on about our day
lastly unlike browsers where modules are
optional
in node.js you have access to modules by
default
and it's hard to imagine a node app
where you're not
going to use them as a quick side note
under the hood
nodejs uses common js library for the
modules
and while the general idea is exactly
the same as for the es6 modules
that we use in the browser syntax is a
bit different
as far as the install it's as
straightforward as it gets
just navigate to nodejs.org pick a
lts version answer yes to all the
questions
and if you don't get some weird bugs
congrats you have installed node
in order to check if everything went
correct just type node
version in your terminal and you should
see the version number
if you don't you'll have to troubleshoot
the error
now as much as i would like to help when
it comes to install
it's impossible for me to troubleshoot
your local setup
so when it comes to troubleshooting
install errors
i strongly suggest using your favorite
search engine
instead typically within a matter of
minutes
you'll see a bunch of useful solutions
to your exact
problem lastly let's also talk about
versions
as you can see at the time of the
recording i have two options
14 lts or 15 current one
if you read the note docs you'll see
that for production apps
they always suggest using lts which
stands for
long term support and therefore i will
also suggest the same but
as far as tutorial i don't think you'll
have any issues
if you use the current version instead
now also
since you're watching this in the future
your version number
most likely is going to be greater than
14
basically greater than mine i definitely
suggest
installing the lts option that's offered
to you instead of downgrading to my
version
and if you're stressing about content
being out of date
let me assure you that everything we
cover in the course
will work perfectly fine with your
current
note version and eventually if
some bugs do creep in i will definitely
update the course content
so long story short just install your
current
lts version whatever it is and you'll be
in good shape
so in my case it is 14 i have two big
buttons
and of course since i would want to go
with lts i'll click
on left one then notice we are getting
the download package and now i just need
to go to my downloads
and then crack it open and then like i
said we just need to answer
yes to all the questions so we go with
continue
continue and yep i would agree
and again we just install and then we'll
be prompted
for our passport and once we add that
one
we should be in good shape and then like
i said
once the install is complete and yep
we'll move this sucker to the trash then
if we go to our terminal
and if i massively zoom in and if i type
node version there it is
i should have my version number which in
my case of course
is 14. if you also can see the node
version
in your terminal you are in good shape
and you can continue
with the videos if not please
troubleshoot it because otherwise
everything we're about to do
next is not going to work since you
haven't
installed node on your computer
install is complete hopefully we all
have node
on our machines now what what do we do
for contrast with vanilla.js it was
somewhat easy right
we create index.html jam our javascript
code
whichever way we prefer and browser does
the rest
it evaluates our javascript code but
what about node how do we get node to
evaluate
our code and effectively we have two
options
a repl which stands for read
eval print loop and cli executable
which just means running our app code in
node
if i have to be perfectly honest reply
is for playing around
and cli is essentially for everything
else
in fact this is going to be the first
and most likely the only time
we'll use a rebel in this course and
after that
cli is going to be our best friend
how do we spin up the rebel well we go
to terminal
and in terminal we simply type node
and then no arguments nothing we just
press
return or enter however you would like
to call the button
and that's it now notice we have this
little angle bracket that just means
that
we are in the rebel and once we are in a
rebel
we can do reply things what would be a
first ripley thing we can do well we can
simply type our name so cons
and the name is equal to john
and there it is of course now i can
access name
and my name is john as you can see
you're not going to write anything
serious in here and if you have written
any vanilla javascript apps you know
that of course we can also do the same
thing
in a browser console so we can also
evaluate some code there but of course
we're not going to write
anything serious in a browser's console
so the same thing
is for reple yes we can come here we can
play around
but when it comes to serious
applications of course you'll pick
a cli executable instead
and in order to close the repo we simply
go with control
and c and as you can see we have
suggestion that we need to press it
again
and now of course we're out of the rebel
not bad that bad we now know how the
ripple works
but what about a more serious
node application how do we get node
to evaluate our code well we would need
to start
by creating a project right so
back on my desktop i'm going to create a
new folder
and surprise surprise i will call this
tutorial why
well because we'll do tutorial things
and
i'm going to say tutorial now of course
if you want you can add
node but i'm just going to leave it as a
tutorial
and then of course we'll have to use our
text error
in my case like i already previously
mentioned i'm using visual studio code
and my preferred method is just drag and
drop
and then instead of the folder what i
would want is to create a new file
and this is the case where you can
literally name it whatever you would
want
and in my case i'm going to go with app
and js and in this app.js
okay now we want to write some more
serious node program
and the program is going to be following
where there is a
const so there's a variable by the name
of amount
and as a side note i'll make this bigger
and i'll probably bump
up the font size just so we can see a
bit clearer
so we're gonna go with const and not
also close the sidebar
hopefully you see that i have the file
by the name of app.js
and like i previously mentioned we're
going to have a variable by the name of
amount
and it's going to be equal to 12 and now
let's set up
a if condition where if amount is less
than 10
then we simply cancel log small number
and otherwise we'll just say that the
number e is large
so we go with if and we're looking for
amount
is less than 10 and if that is the case
we go with console log
and we'll just say small number
and otherwise if it is of course equal
or bigger than 10
then we go with console log and we say
large number and at the end of the day
we just write console log hey
it's my first note up as you can see an
extremely complicated functionality
and in this case i'm just going to set
up the template strings
so you understand that of course we can
use them here
as well i'll say hey it's my first
node app and if you want of course you
can jam the hello world there somewhere
as well
since that is the traditional approach
with the first program
and then in order to execute this code
we effectively have two options
i can navigate back to my terminal and
i can zoom in like so and of course now
i'm in a root so i would need to
navigate
to the desktop and probably the fastest
way
is just typing cd and drag and drop
my folder here okay so now as you can
see
i'm in the tutorial and in order to
execute my code i just need to type
node and then app.js now keep in mind
that technically i could have done that
from the root we just need to provide
the full path
where i go to users blah blah blah and
then tutorial and of course the file
name
is app.js and let me bump up the font
size even more
and the moment we run it check it out
we have large number and hey it's my
first
note app now if you don't believe me we
can go back
and we for example can say that the
number
is nine and of course again we would
need to run the code
and we're gonna go with node and then
app
js beautiful we have small number
and we still have our hey it's my first
node up
again the whole point of this line here
is just to showcase that not only we can
use quotation marks
but also we can use the template string
as well
so that's one option but if you're
familiar
with vs code you know that it has this
cool feature of
integrated terminal where effectively we
have our terminal
but it is right away pointing to
our folder so we don't need to do this
whole dance where we navigate to the
folder
and then run the app we simply can open
this up and the shortcut is
control and tilde and also keep in mind
that of course
you can navigate through the tabs the
problem
is that i always forget where it is and
effectively we need to go to view and
then you're looking for this terminal
command here
as you can see this would be a shortcut
and tilde and in here we have nice
suggestion that we already located
in tutorial folder and what do we need
to do
well again we just go with node app.js
why well because that is my file name so
for the remainder of the course
i'll use the integrated terminal that
comes with this code just understand
that
both of them effectively do the same
thing and there it is now i run
node app.js because that of course is
the file name
and i have small number and hey it's my
first
node app and that's how we can evaluate
a
more serious code using node
as i note if at any point during the
course you need to compare
your code to mine just navigate to
website
johnsmilk.com and the website
is johnsmega.com and then either in the
project
page or in the homepage you'll find node
express tutorial project so in the
homepage you'll find it in the latest
project so
just keep on scrolling but if it's not
here it's definitely going to be in the
projects page
and you can even filter it in order to
save some time so look for node
in here like i said the project name is
node express tutorial
and not any of these links will
get you to the repo and at this point
you can either clone it 4k
or just simply download and you're
looking for this
node tutorial and in here you'll find
all the folders as well as the files
now keep in mind that eventually when we
start working
on express we'll have to get
this repo anyway because i'll use it for
starters since i have prepared
some assets for you some assets that
we're going to use
in our examples so this is really up to
you if you want you can get it right now
just keep in mind that you'll have to
get it later anyway
and once we have executed our first code
in node
let's quickly cover the concept of
globals
or global variables in node and the
emphasis
is on the word quickly yes
there are more global variables
available but the idea
is not to spend half an hour in slide
bill
instead i would want to give you a
general idea and as we progress with the
course
don't worry we will implement them and
that way
you can right away see them in action
not just some random
general description and before we
continue let me just
mention that throughout the tutorial
the code from the previous video i'm
going to save in a file
so for example remember our first
complex app
with a mount and all that so what i did
i created a file name by the one
hyphen intro js and then i just copy and
paste it
this is what i'm gonna do throughout the
no tutorial
part of the course so that way you can
always have access to the code
and if you ever need to you can jog your
memory now if you don't want to use my
one if you're
adding your own comments and all that i
would also suggest doing that
where essentially just create a file
just dump it
and then that way you are slowly
progressing on the course
and if you ever need to go back and
refresh your memory
you always have that option and keep in
mind that
if you would want to run this file you
simply go with
node and then whatever the file name
right so in my case that would be
one dash intro js
again i'm going to keep on numbering
them because
i'm just annoying that way but you don't
have to that is
really up to you so back to the globals
when we work in vanilla.js applications
we know a very cool thing is the fact
that we have
access to the window object and the
reason why it's so cool because in the
window object
we can get a bunch of useful things
right so for example we can get a query
selector so i can select a node
i can get built-in fetch and hopefully
you get the gist
now i don't want to rain on your parade
but
you know there's no window why well
because there's no browser
so there's no window object so if you'll
try to access window
node will spit back the error and most
likely
your app will crash now there are some
globals of course there is this concept
of global variables
and essentially what global variables
means that
anywhere in your application you can
access them so no matter how complex my
application gets
how nested it gets or whatever i'll
always have access to those variables
and again let me repeat these are just
some of the variables of course there's
more
and i'm not going to spend hours and
hours talking about them
i simply want to give you a general idea
and then like i said
we'll start using them and you'll see
them in action and in my opinion
that's just going to make it way clearer
about what in fact they're doing
and some of the useful ones we have
their name so that would be
underscore underscore their name just
going to give us path to current
directory
then we have also underscore underscore
filename which
as you can see is going to give us a
file name then we have require
which is a function to use modules as
well as the module that would be info
about the current module
now these two will literally cover them
in the upcoming videos because our next
big topic
is going to be modules so for time being
just remember that we have require and
module and you'll see them
in action in no time and then we have a
very very very useful one and that one
is a process and why it's so useful
because it gives us
a info about the environment
where the program is executed because we
need to keep in mind
when it comes to a node app at the
moment yeah
we're executing that on our machines
but when you deploy for example your api
so for example your server right where
is it sitting
it is sitting on digital ocean or herald
core or whatever
so that of course is already a different
environment
and of course based on that environment
you
can make a bunch of decisions in your
application
again if you'll take a look at the
process right now it's just going to be
a
giant object of gibberish data
but trust me as we're progressing we the
course
will find a bunch of useful properties
that we'll implement
in our application now any of them
you can simply console log and you'll
get that useful data
so you can just run console log and then
for example their name again i'm not
going to cancel log all of them
probably the biggest one is going to be
the process like i said you'll get a
bunch of properties that at the moment
will look like a gibberish and i simply
need to save
and of course then we go with node and
app.js we run that and there it is now
of course
this gives me the path so if you're
interested of course
you can console log rest of them as well
but in my case i'm going to stop
with their name now also very quickly
yes you have access to the console so
as you can see in order to cancel log we
have to use the console so that is also
something that is available globally
then just like in the event ljs we have
set interval as well as set timeout
so you can run these ones and i'm not
going to run both of them but i'll show
you set interval
very quickly just so you don't think
that i'm cheating
and the way it's going to look like of
course we have our callback function and
then i'll say
that my interval is going to run every
second and
i must type hello world otherwise
well what kind of tutorial is this and
again we simply go back to
node and then app js
and as you can see now after every
second
i have hello world in console and in
order to stop it remember the command
was ctrl and c and before we move on and
start talking about
the modules let me also mention
something else
where essentially we don't need to type
node and then app.js you can simply
write
node and then app however throughout the
course
i'll probably keep on typing js just
because i'm annoying
that would be the first thing now the
second thing and this is not a node
thing this is actually a terminal
if you don't want to type it you can
simply go back to the previous command
and in order to do that you need to
press on
arrow key up and check it out the moment
you press
notice that was my previous command and
then i have one before that
so in my case that is node and then
app.js again you don't need to add that
just extension
but probably i will and then
you just go back to the previous command
and then press and again
you just execute that command and of
course if you want to clear the console
again this is not
a node thing this is a terminal i just
type clear
and lastly to answer the question that's
probably bugging you the most
we always have to just type node and
then the file name
because as we're going to be testing a
special in tutorial it will probably get
annoying
and the answer is yes but only for now
once we learn about npm the external
packages which at the moment
i fully understand doesn't make any
sense at all
then there's command that effectively
will restart our application so we'll
have to install
some third-party module some external
library
and that will do the job of restarting
the application
for now yes all throughout tutorial
up until the point where we cover that
external library
and external libraries in general yes
we'll have to type node
and then whatever is the file i know
it's a little bit annoying
but i just don't want to skip ahead i
want to get us there
with a full information of what is
happening
so with this in place with clear
understanding
of the global variables
in node now let's move on to our next
topic which is going to be
modules in node beautiful
and once we understand the globals in
node now let's talk about the
modules and first let's return to this
command
notice we have here node and then
app.js
probably the question that you have
is well does that mean that all my
application
needs to be in this one file and the
answer again
is yes and no yes you'll execute one
file
but you'll split your code in modules
otherwise that would be literally insane
to
jam all your code in one file
and effectively i'll just show you with
an extremely complex app
and of course extremely complex is in
the air quotes right now
and you'll see why we'd want to use the
modules
in the first place so in the next video
i'll give you official intro
with a bunch of gibberish and all that
but for time being let's just build
super complex app and then see
why i would want to use those modules in
the first place
and if you have any familiarity with es6
modules if you have worked with them
in vanilla.js or in react.js
you're already in good shape the syntax
is going to be tiny bit different
because you know it uses
common js but the general idea is
exactly the
same and we start with a simple function
by the name of
say hi you guessed it and then this
function is going to be looking for the
name parameter
and then inside of the function what do
we do we simply cancel log and we say
hello there and then whatever is the
name
of the dude or the gal that is being
passed in as a parameter
and of course we can invoke it and i can
say say hi and then pass in susan for
example
and in order to make this interesting
i'll set up some variables as well
so i'm going to say const john is equal
to john
and you guessed it since there's a john
there also has to be a peter
and hopefully you get the gist so
imagine we would have a bunch of names
and then we have probably more functions
than this one but
for time being this is just going to be
say hi we copy and paste we invoke this
function
i guess three times one for johnny boy
one poor peter and then the first one we
already have for susan
and what do we do we run node app or
app.js we run that and there it is now
of course in our concert we can clearly
see hello there susan blah blah blah
now wouldn't it make sense if the names
would be separate
as well as this function or the future
functions
that we're going to create would be in
separate files
and then we can access them all
throughout the
application and that way of course
we would have smaller files and more
structure
to our application and that is exactly
what the modules
allow us to do and that's why we'll move
on and start talking about the modules
in the next video
beautiful and once we understand the
main problem with this code
where again the moment code is
technically still tiny
but as you can see it is getting bigger
and more annoying
with every line now let's talk about the
modules and i guess let me just give you
the
main idea first and then we'll talk
about the
implementations and all that good stuff
so first of all what are the modules
again if you're familiar with es6
modules you already have the idea but
essentially that is
encapsulated code and the key here
is that we're only sharing what we want
so we're only sharing minimum how would
that look like in real life well
i can go here with secret and then i can
type here super
secret and then since this variable is
in this file
as we can see you can access anywhere
okay so by mistake i can just access it
i can override it now of course you can
make an argument that
i mean it is made with cons but
hopefully you get the gist
this is available to me everywhere in
this file
so once we set up the module you'll see
what are the differences now node
uses common js library under the hood
that's what makes it happen and then
every file in node is a module again let
me repeat every file
in node is a module so those super
powers
that we will cover in just a few seconds
we have them by default we don't need to
do anything we don't need to go to the
store
and buy some javascript code no we just
get them
by default and the way the modules work
well we simply need to create a new file
right and
i'll right away set up the names here
because of course eventually this code
will be sitting
in the file name by the three hyphen and
then
the module basics or whatever but the
names
as well as the function well it's going
to be in a separate file
so what i'm trying to say is that in a
root
of course there's no folders or nothing
so everything is rude
i'm going to go with four again i'm
doing that because eventually this is
going to be
three hyphen modules something i'm gonna
go with
maybe names or you can type first module
whatever you would want
and i'm just gonna go with names.js
okay awesome and then i'll take
these three variables from my
app.js and i'll copy and paste in the
names
and then also what i would want is to
set up one more file
and of course this one will be five
and i don't know we can say second
module
or so i'll say here utils
something generic so we set that up and
now of course what i would want
is to grab this function from the mgs
and copy and paste in the utils
and now sixty four thousand dollar
question
is this app gonna work or is it gonna
break
and of course the answer is it's gonna
break because we have no access right
now
to say hi or to john or peter
so why don't we go to the names
and console log something and as i said
yes you can console log this
in the app.js it is a file so by default
it is a module
but since we'll do most of our work in
the names and new tools first
why don't we go to names and that way we
can also see how we can
run the file just by using
node and what i would want to console
log is
the global by the name of module so in
the names
go below or above the variables doesn't
really matter
and go with console.log and then module
and remember to run node and then
whatever is the file name
so in my case it is four dash and then
names
js you run this and
you'll notice something pretty pretty
cool
where we have the object and in that
object we have
quite a few properties now the one that
i'm interested in the most
is this exports one and it tells me that
this export is an object
and the way the common js syntax works
whatever i'm going to dump in that
export
i'm going to be able to access anywhere
in the application
so that's the key remember we're
only sharing the minimum so it's up to
us
to set those values in that
export object we decide what goes in
there
previously remember secret was
accessible
everywhere in my app.js now in the names
i can be
hey you know what john and peter yeah
i'm sharing them anywhere in application
we can access that
but the secret variable no this is just
going to be local
so i'm going to add here i guess the
comment by the name of local and that
way at least we understand so this is
going to be
i mean i'm not going to use global but
i'm just going to say that
share so we're sharing this with rest of
our application and then if i know that
this is
a object and it is sitting in the module
how does that work well we go with
module
then it is an object so we go with
export
and we have multiple ways how we can set
this up
but the most basic one will simply say
that yep
it is an object and inside of that
object there's going to be two
properties
john and peter now i can probably
already guess that
we're using a es6 syntax since the key
name is exactly the same
as the value well we can simply pass it
right so we have
john and peter so now what happens in
the app.js
we can access them so i can go back and
this is the case where we'll need to run
that require
remember in the globals we talked about
this function
so in order to share them we need to
use module.exports and essentially i'm
setting up
the object like so where i go with
whatever values
i would like to share now in order to
access them
i need to go with require and
i can assign it to a variable or i can
simply require
now in our case we will assign it to the
variable and i'll use the same
type of syntax where i'm going to go
with names just so we can console.log
that
and this is going to be equal to require
so that's my function and as a parameter
we need to pass
in where the module is located
so where is this data coming from
and always always always always you will
be setting up
your module you have to start with dot
now sometimes your modules will
be two levels up i don't know three
levels up whatever
then of course you'll start with dot dot
but you'll always start with this one
dot
because there's also going to be a third
party modules and there's going to be
built-in modules in node
and then we'll use just these quotation
marks
again super super important every time
you create your own module
you'll have to start with dot and then
forward slash so essentially you're
giving a path now in our case what is
the path well
i'm looking for the names right so i set
up here the path
and then if i cancel out the names
i should see something pretty pretty
cool where i go with
names and there it is now i'm going to
run
node and then app js now keep in mind
we're not
running names anymore we go with node
and app.js now of course still complains
that we have no access to hi
let me comment this one out so let's say
node and
app.js and check it out now of course we
have the
object with john john and peter and
peter
and we explicitly said what we would
want to export
so we go with exports and that way
no one has access to the secret one so
this secret one is
only for this file and of course we can
do the same thing
in the utils as well right so we have
the
say hi and we go with module and export
and i can just simply set it equal to
now the reason why i was setting this up
as a
object because i had multiple things at
john and peter and don't worry in the
next video
i'll show you alternative syntax how you
can also set this up
but in this case i have object and then
of course i'm setting these properties
and i said note
this is just my preferred way of
actually using the exports again there's
multiple
ways how we can do that and i will cover
the other ways
in next video but this is just my
preferred method that's why i right away
set
my exports equal to an object and then
pass these two properties
and in utils since i only have one thing
i'm just gonna go with say hi that's it
i'm saying
that i'm gonna be exporting my function
so say
say hi like so and once i have exported
my function now of course i need to go
back to the app.js
import my function the same name
and i'm going to go with say say hi
and that one is going to be coming from
the different file of course so we go
with
five and then utils and notice here how
we don't need to pass
in the js if it is ajs file we just
simply omit the extension as long as the
file name of course matches
and then i can remove now if you want
you can cancel log but i already know
that i'm gonna have the function over
there i'll uncomment
my say hi so now of course there's going
to be no error
and let's make a clear console and again
we run
the node and then app js and there it is
now of course we have a different error
where it says well
john is not defined all right but
i know that john is sitting in the names
right
so here we have multiple flavors either
you can destructure it so instead of
going with names
i can go john and peter that is
definitely one option
or i can go with property names right so
i can say
names and then john and then the second
one
is names and peter
names and peter and now hopefully
everything works
otherwise you're probably thinking that
i'm just messing with you
there it is now we have hello there
susan john
and peter and effectively what we did
we separated our concerns again the main
idea
is that every file by default is a
module
and then when it comes to a modules we
are in charge
what we are sharing and in order to
export or make it something available
from this module
we go with module exports and then
we just set up the functionality whether
this is going to be
a object that we're exporting or we're
simply exporting
as a function so we set this equal to
to the exports and if you're familiar
with es6 modules
as you can see this is very familiar to
the
export default and then
whatever you're exporting as default
whether that is a function whether that
is a react component
or whatever notice i'm exporting as
default
so of course when i'm importing this
in this case app.js well i already know
that this is a function
so i can name this whatever i would want
and the same goes here
since i'm exporting this as object i can
call this shaken bait
as long as i access it later of course
i'll be able to access
the property as long as the name matches
to
whatever i set up over here so
let me save this and now of course we
can talk about
our next topic all right so far we know
two flavors
one if we want to export one value
we just set module export equal to that
value
and then of course wherever we want to
use it
we just import it set it equal to some
kind of variable
and of course once we use that variable
we have access to that value
and the second flavor is if we have
multiple values
then we simply set module exports equal
to an object
and then in that object we set up the
properties however
there's also another way how we can do
that
and essentially it is called export as
you go
and the way it looks like first i'm
gonna
set up a new file and i'll call this six
and i'll call this alternative
flavor now again naming is really up to
you
since that is the hardest thing in
programming
and then i'm going to come up with one
array and i'm going to call this items
and that will be equal to item one
and item number two and then i'll set up
a object and i'll say const person
is equal to a object and there surprise
surprise we'll go with name property
and set it equal to bob and i'm
purposely adding multiple data types
just so you don't think that we can only
export variables
or functions and in here we have two
options
either where we are setting up the
value in this case items i simply go
with
module exports and then whatever is the
name
and of course in this case i'm going to
keep the items but notice the syntax
where instead of going with const items
i
right away go with module.exports
or if you are a true rebel you can do
something like this
module exports set up the property
for example single person
and set it equal to your person
object why we are able to do that
because if you remember in the previous
video when we console logged
module exports it was an object right
so what are we doing here we're setting
up a property
on that object and set it equal to an
array
and here i set up another property and
just set it equal to a person keep in
mind of course i can still
write simply module exports and then the
person
but since you might sometimes see this
type of syntax as well
i wanted to cover that and now of course
we save
alternative flavor.js and you're
probably not going to be surprised that
if we navigate
to app.js and in this case i will call
this data because i'm getting
a object and on that object i have two
properties and i need to come up with
some kind of name
now as always this name is really
up to you you can call it shake and bake
you can call it uncle bobby whatever you
want in my case i'm gonna go with
generic data we go with require again
we're looking for the file by the name
of
alternative flavor and
in this case i'm not gonna do anything
with it apart from console logging
and if i navigate back to my integrated
terminal
and run the node app.js
there it is of course now i have the
items as well as the single person
now please keep in mind one thing where
this syntax whether the first line
or line number six at the end of the day
is exactly the same like we're doing
over here
yes the syntax is a bit different but at
the end of the day
you just make these values available
somewhere else in your code now just
because i prefer
this type of syntax most likely
throughout the course
you'll see this approach but
if you prefer this one instead be my
guest
at the end of the day it is your
application and
you are the one who is going to be
maintaining it and before we move on to
built in modules as well as third-party
modules
let me throw you a mind grenade and i'm
going to start
by removing this console log in the app
js like so and i'm going to create a new
file
with the same exact name a mine grenade
as always if you would like to call this
differently
that's totally your option and i'm going
to go with
mine grenade like so and
js and in this file i'll create some
basic functionality
and by the way let me save app.js so
let's go with const
num1 is equal to 5 and then
const num 2 is equal to 10.
of course there has to be a function
that adds these values
as always with every tutorial so go with
add values
just for the sake of it i'm just going
to go with good old function
keyword and the old setup meaning
not the arrow function syntax and
simply here we'll go with template
string the
sum is colon and then of course let's go
for
template literal and we'll say num1 plus
num2 and instead of
setting up the exports i'll simply
invoke
add values and now i'll throw you that
migrate
that i was talking about where in the
app.js
i'm not going to assign it to anything
i'll simply write require
and then we'll go with my grenade
and now let me comment out these three
since at the moment they will just over
populate the console
and again let's run node and app.js
and once we're on our code we can
clearly see in the console something
pretty interesting where
we have a log of the sum is 15.
so what's happening over here well when
we are setting up
everything if we have a function inside
of the module
that we invoke yes that code will run
even though we didn't assign it to a
variable as you can see clearly here
and we didn't invoke that variable
and before we go any further let me
mention three things
first it's not unique you can also do
that in es6 modules
and if you took my vanilla javascript
course you know that we use that
functionality
number two yes throughout the course
here and there we will use
this particular setup now it's going to
be with third party modules
and of course once we get there i will
remind you
about this setup so that's how it works
and third
i wouldn't suggest losing your sleep
over it
just please remember that when you
import a module you actually
invoke it and this is really going into
weeds but
the reason why that happens is because
this code is not just exported
on its own when the node exports this
it actually wraps it in the function so
that's why when you're required
yeah you do invoke the code if you have
some kind of function that actually is
executed here
keep that in mind not talking about
exporting something
i'm talking about executing function
here and there and of course
in this case you need to use the
imagination that we'll do something way
more useful than this at this point
you're looking at it okay
i could have just set up that function
in app.js and you're 100
correct this is the place where you
definitely need to use your imagination
where
of course the functionality we'll use it
for is going to be way
more complex but the idea is going to be
similar where
we'll just require some kind of module
and behind the scenes that module will
do
a bunch of cool stuff okay that was fun
we created our first module and in the
process covered the general module
syntax
and use cases as well now what
well as helpful as our say hi function
is some very smart people created
way more useful modules than that
and the good news is that we can start
using them right away
so what i'm trying to say here is that
node has
bunch of built-in modules that we can
use freely
in our apps in the following videos
we're going to cover
following modules os module so operating
system module
path module file system module as well
as http module
to set up our http server and before we
continue let me just say this
i purposely cover only a few major
modules
and more specifically only a few
properties and methods provided
by those modules you see the list of
built-in modules in node
is quite big and the amount of
properties and methods
each module has combined is of course
even bigger and as a result we could
easily spend the remainder of the course
on just that but is that really
beneficial
and of course the answer is no instead
let's cover the general setup first
and later as we progress with the course
implement
some modules as we go now
if you're interested in more properties
and
methods built and modules have just
navigate to the docs
and go nuts so if at any point
you would want to find out more about
specific property
or method or the built-in module
in general just navigate to nodejs.org
and then look for the docs and
again in my case the version
the long term support version is 14
so i'm gonna click here but as you can
see we also have an option
of going to the older versions as well
so as you can see i can get the docs for
the older versions
as well but i'm just going to stick with
my version
and then be prepared to go nuts if you
enjoy docs
then you have yourself a big old party
where of course you can look for modules
and then each module
has the properties as well as the
methods
so of course you can get a extremely
detailed
information on the properties as well as
the methods here
in the docs all right and once we have
covered
the general existence of built-in
modules
now let's take a look at few of them and
i'm going to start by creating that file
that i promised a few videos ago
remember when i was setting up the
modules i said that eventually
there is going to be a file by the name
of 3n modules and this one
i would want to do it together just so
you don't think
that i'm not fulfilling my promises so
we're going to go with
module and then i guess modules.js
i'll grab that i currently have in the
address
it's pretty much everything and we copy
and paste
and in this case i also uncommented
these say hi
again this all stays for your reference
and you'll have
access to it if you navigate to the
github repo
so grab everything in app.js i'll
actually cut it out since we'll start
from scratch
and copy and paste now of course all
this code is sitting in the modules and
just keep in mind that of course
we're still referencing the names utils
alternative flavor
as well as my favorite the mind grenade
and back in app.js
now let's start by taking a look at the
os module
and os module we built in module
provides
many useful properties and methods for
interacting
with operating system as well as the
server
and the general setup for the built-in
modules
or even the external ones that we're
going to cover a bit later
is going to be similar where we're going
to go with some kind of variable
and in this case i'm going to call this
os for operating system
then we're going to go with require and
then in the require
we'll have to pass in the name so since
this is a built-in module of course we
don't need to install anything
just remember it later when we work with
external ones
yes we'll have to install that module
first in this case
it is a built-in so we just go with os
but again
let me stress something we're not doing
dot and then forward slash no we just go
with os
so that way node knows all right so
you're looking for the built-in module
and once we set this up
then we have multiple options either you
can access
those methods by just running this
variable
so it would look something like this
where i go with os and notice
the moment i press dot i have all these
options
so these are the methods and properties
that i can use
or if we know that we want a specific
one
you can simply destructure it here and
of course throughout the course
i'll use multiple setups just so you
understand that both of them effectively
do the same thing
so here i have access to all the methods
and properties
that this module provides and of course
now we can go crazy
for example i could get a useful info
about the
current user which of course is me so
say
info about current
and user and you know what as a side
note
i'll save here and i'll close all the
files it's just a bit annoying that i
have all those tabs open
back in the app.js once i have a comment
of course
now i would want to assign it to a user
and we'll simply go with os
since that is the name of my variable
and then
method that i'm looking for is userinfo
i don't need to pass anything
i simply invoke it and of course since i
would want to see the result i simply go
to console log
and then i'm looking for the user and
you can probably already guess that
we'll just run node app.js
and there it is now of course i have a
info
about the user which is me so this would
be a home directory
this is going to be the default shell
and all kinds of useful stuff
then i want to show you how we can get
the uptime
of the system so effectively how long
the computer has been running
in seconds and i'll just add a comment
method returns the system
system up time up time
in seconds and
the way i'm going to run that i'll right
away set up the console log
just so you understand that of course we
have multiple options
how we can invoke those methods you
don't always have to assign
to some kind of variable now i'll leave
this one in here
so i'll leave the console log and then
user
and let's say right above or you know
what let's do it this way
so leave the console log where the user
is and then
let's go with another one we'll go with
console.log in this case i'm going to go
with template string
and we'll say the system system uptime
yes and then let's use a interpolation
of course
and the method that i'm looking for is
uptime
so again i go with my variable name and
i know i've said this before but
i just want to stress this point just so
we all are on the same page
and in this case i'm going to go with os
and then the method name
is uptime and then let's just add
seconds and again same deal back
in the integrated terminal run node
and then app.js and there it is now of
course not only i have the info
i also have the system uptime
and what's interesting this actually is
100 seconds
meaning if i'll run this notice that
you'd expect that this would probably
stop at 60 right
since we have 60 seconds in a minute but
no actually this one goes
to a hundred and then i'm just gonna set
up a object where i'll show you
a few more methods and then we'll move
on to a next module because again the
point
is not to cover each and every method
the point
is just to give you a general idea how
the modules
the built-in modules would work in node
so clear my terminal and then i'll
create
a object i'll call this current and then
os
and then in this object i'll set up
properties and i'll set them equal
to the method that actually returns that
value from my
os module so go with name and os and
this is going to be equal to a type
method then i can get the release and
this one will be equal to os
and then release again we invoke it
then we'll look for total memory and
free memory
total and mem and of course i'll go with
os
and then total mam as you can see
somewhat predictable and then we're
gonna go with free memory
and it's not going to be surprised if
we're just going to go with
free memory here let's save that one and
lastly let's just cancel log it
and we should get a bunch of info
about our current operating system again
we're going to go with
node and then app.js and not only have
the user information not only i know
how long the system has been up in
seconds
i can also get some useful data about my
operating system and again
we're just scratching the surface of
course there's more
methods and properties but hopefully you
have a clear understanding
how powerful these built-in modules
are in node.js since the node we can
interact with the file system
something we couldn't do when we used
our javascript in a browser another
useful module
is a path module which allows us to
interact with file paths
easily and i'm going to remove
all my code in the app.js because behind
the scenes i created
a file by the name of 8 os
and module and of course copy and pasted
the contents from the previous video
that's why in app.js
i'll remove everything and the setup is
going to be exactly the same we come up
with some kind of name
now most likely it's going to be path
and then we pass
in the module we would want to get and
in this case of course it is
a path module and then let's just start
with
a very useful property a separator
property
that returns a platform specific
separator
so if i go straight up with console.log
and then
path sep this is going to return
my platform specific separator so if i
write
node mjs there it is and of course i
have forward slash now if you're using
different platform
for you the value might be different
after that let's take a look at the
path dot join so the join method
which joins a sequence of path segments
using that platform specific separator
as the limiter
and second thing it does it returns a
normalized
resulting path and in order to show you
an example i'll create
a new folder so not a new file but a new
folder
i'll zoom in and i'll say content
and inside of this content folder i'll
create another one
and i'll simply call this generic
subfolder
and in this subfolder i'll say a
test and text file and instead of the
text file
i mean you can place something you can
omit it
doesn't really matter i'll just say text
and then
txt and once we save it back in the app
js now i
want to use that path dot join method
so i'll say const and then file path is
equal
to path dot join and then we need to
pass
in those values as strings so for
example
since i'm looking for the content folder
i'll simply say forward slash
and then content then i know that inside
of the content folder
i have the subfolder that's another
folder
and then eventually there's going to be
a
test txt so we go with test and then dot
txt we save the sucker and then if we'll
cancel log the file path
we should see the whole path and there
it is now of course
it is normalized and we get it as a
value
so we have content subfolder test and
txt
so if i start adding some type of
forward slashes meaning trailing slashes
then of course they will be removed we
still get
the normalized path and we can also get
the base name
so for example i create this file path
but i only would want the last portion
of it how can i access it well the
method name
is base name so we're gonna go with
const and
base and path dot base name
and we just pass in that file path and
now if we cancel log the base
we should see the text again these are
just summaries if you want just a
directory
of course you can imagine that there is
a method
that returns that as well but since i
don't want to cover each and every
method
that's why i will skip that one and
there it is now of course
not only i see my normalized path but i
also
see the test txt which is my base
and the last method that i would want to
showcase is path.resolve
and why it's so cool because it returns
an absolute path
and once in a while in our applications
we need to provide that absolute path
that's why of course we'll have to use
that method
and when it comes to path.resolve it
accepts
a sequence of paths or path segments
and resolves it into an absolute path
so below the base i'm going to go with
cons and then
absolute and that one is equal to path
and we're looking for dot resolve
and here remember when we talked about
the globals
one of the first globals i covered was
underscore underscored their name
so this is going to point to this
directory
where the app.js is located and
once we're here then of course we just
need to provide
rest of the values in my case that is
content
then i'm looking for sub folder
and then eventually i would want to get
to the
test dxd i would want to get this
absolute path
and then once i set up the value of
course if i go
with my console.log and if i provide
absolute once i run node
and objects you can probably guess that
in the console i'll have my absolute
path
to the test txt and if you're wondering
why we would ever want that
well remember our application is going
to run
in different environments right so
of course the path to some kind of
resource is going to be different
in my computer in my local machine
than for example in heroku
hopefully it is clear and now of course
we can take a look at the next
useful built-in module nice
now we know how we can work with path
module
and like i mentioned in the previous
video we also have an option of
interacting with a file system
so what i would want right now is first
create a new file i'll call this nine
and we'll say path
and module like so js
i'll grab everything that i have in the
address
copy and paste and once we have this one
out of the way
i'll just remove and keep the app.js
clean for now
as well as clear the console and
yes we have an option of interacting
with the file system
and the module the name of the module is
fs now essentially there are two flavors
when it comes to file module we can do
it asynchronously
non-blocking or we can do it
synchronously which is going to be
blocking
but for time being we'll just cover
both of the setups and then later in the
course
we'll cover what are the differences and
why you should prefer one over the other
one for now
just think of them as different methods
but eventually yes we'll talk about it
the whole structure of the node
and why would you want to use the
non-blocking code
instead as well as different approaches
when it comes to callback functions
different solutions and for now i just
want to show you both methods
essentially four methods and then we'll
just move on to the next topic
and in order to set this up in this case
i'm just going to
structure right away the methods that
i'm looking for and in the first video
we'll take a look at the synchronous
ones
so that's why i'll destructure read file
and sync and that is coming from require
and then the module name is fs
again please keep in mind it would be
the same thing
if i were to go like this fs
and then fs and whatever the name
i was going with read file sync and of
course i have access to it
i'm just showing you a different way how
we can access those methods
we just destructure them out of the fs
module
and then the second one will be write
file sync
write file sync and then once i have the
structured both of them
then i'm going to set up two variables
so
first we'll read two files we haven't
created those files yet but
in a second we will and then eventually
we'll create
a new file with write file sync so i
would want you to go to the content
folder if you haven't created then i
suggest
creating one and i mean i'll keep the
subfolder
just because i believe the path module
is still using it
but in a content i'll create a new file
so not in the subfolder
but actually in the content i'll say
first first and then txt
so this by the way sets it up in the
content so let me move it up
or i'm sorry this sets it up in a
subfolder i believe
and it tells me do i want to move yes i
would like to move
and now i have the content that has the
first txt
and then i have the subfolder with
test.dxt of course if you want you can
place it in a subfolder that's really up
to you
but in my case i would want them simply
in a content
so i'll go the second one txt
and as far as the values i'll say hello
this is first first
text file and then of course we can
copy and paste the value and just change
it around to the second file
so in the second txt we'll say second
text file and once we have both of the
text files now let's take a look at how
we can read from the file system
and since we have read file sync we know
it is a method and in that method we
need to provide
two parameters we need to provide a path
to that specific file as well as well
what is the encoding so the node knows
how to decode the file
and generally you'll go with utf-8
and we'll first go with first that's my
variable
we'll go with read file sync
my method name and like i said we
provide a path we go
to the content and then inside of the
content there's going to be
a first txt and then as far as the
encoding
the default one will be utf-8 but
if you want to be a bit specific just
set up the
second parameter and notice these are
all your options
and just go with ut effect okay
and then once we have everything in
place of course we can copy and paste
this is going to be the value for the
second one and we just need to
change the file name of course so we
have the second one
and now in a console log we should see
both of the text so if i go with
console.log
first and then second
i should have one long text and let's go
with node and app.js and there it is i
have
hello this is a first text file and i
also have hello
this is the second text file and once i
have both of them why don't we create
a new file and the method for that
is write file sync and the way it works
again we provide
two values two arguments one is gonna be
the file name
and if the file is not there then
of course node will create that file and
you'll see that in a second
and the second one is the value that we
would want to pass
and i'm going to go with write file sync
write file sync and like i said first is
going to be a path
so you can call this third you can call
this result whatever you would want
in my case i'm going to go with forward
slash content
and then we're looking for result
and then sync and this is going to be
txt
and then as far as the value if you want
you can simply pass hello world
and test it in my case i'm going to make
it a bit more interesting
where we'll set up a template string
we'll say here is the result
and why don't we use the interpolation
we'll say
first and second so we'll have first
value and then the second value
and you know what when we add here colon
as well
so let's say first and then let's place
a comma
and then we're gonna go with second
again
if the file is not there then of course
node will create one and if the file is
already there
node by default will overwrite all the
values
that are in the file and i'll show you
that in a second
so i'm going to go here with node and
app.js
and check it out now i have result
sync txt and then inside there i have
here is the result
hello this is first text file and
also have hello this is second text file
and just to showcase that if there are
some values
they will be overwritten by node well
if i go with simple hello world and then
i run
node.js again i have my
new result now if you just want to upend
to the file
well we need to pass in one more
argument notice i have the first one
i have the value that i would like to
set up in a file
and the third one is an object basically
an options object
and here the property name is flag
and if you'll set this flag equal to a
then node will append this and the
easiest way for me to show you that
is run node.js and now we should have
two results so we have here is the
result and notice how we're starting
a new line why well because by default
we are overriding everything
and then when we add that flag then of
course we create a new value
so these are two very useful methods
that we can use
with node to read files as well as
create ones from the scratch
beautiful and once we have looked at the
synchronous approach
like promised i also would want to show
you the asynchronous
and as always let's start by creating a
new file
again in my case that is going to be 10
hyphen and then
i'm going to go with fa sync and js
and of course i'll grab everything in
the app.js
and then just copy and paste and then
back in the app.js i would want to
change
these names so i'm not looking anymore
for the
read file sync i'm actually looking for
a method by the name of read file
so this is going to be the asynchronous
one and the same
goes with writefile now of course we can
remove
all this code as well and the way the
synchronous method works we need to
provide a callback
and if you're familiar with callback
essentially what it means
is that we run that callback
when we're done so when
whatever functionality we're doing is
complete
then we run that callback just like we
normally
would do with add event listener on a
button
remember we go with add event listener
we add whatever the event
of course with the button that would be
a click event and then pass in the
callback function
and that callback function will run
every time we click on a button
so this is the same thing where we have
the
read file function and we can simply use
it
since of course we have the structured
then we need to provide a path
so again we go with forward slash
content
and then the file name is first txt
and this is where we provide that second
argument and that is going to be a
callback mission
now in that callback function we pass
into more arguments first one is going
to be error
if there is one as well as the result
and then inside of the body first i
would want to check
if there is an error and then i can just
return
null as well as maybe console.log so
we go with if error and then we'll say
return
null or simply return whatever you'd
want and if you want you of course can
cancel log the error
as well like so and then if everything
is correct
well then of course i'll have access to
my data which of course
has the name the parameter name of
result
and since i would simply want to console
log the result
i'm going to go with console.log and the
result
but of course keep in mind that this is
where you would
set up the functionality so let's go
back and we're going to go with
node app.js and in this case something
really interesting where we don't get
the
text right so we're getting this buffer
so this is what's going to happen
where if we don't provide that utf
coding
then of course we'll get the buffer now
where do we add this
encoding value well right here in
between in between the content
as well as the path so let's just go
with
string and we're looking for the utf
so let's say utf-8 and we'll save that
one
and let's run it one more time and of
course i have node app.js
and then hello this is the first text
file
and now the million dollar question well
how we can set up the same functionality
check it out we have read file read file
and then we simply create a new file
with both of these values so if you're
familiar with
callbacks you know that of course we
would need to set up that functionality
inside of this callback where i'm
getting this result
otherwise there's going to be an error
because the only way for me to access
this result
if i'm setting this as a callback is of
course
inside of this function and this is what
i was saying before
where yes eventually i'll show you a
different approach because
inevitably we'll set up a callback help
and you'll see that in a second so what
i would want to do
right now when i get back my first text
file
well now of course i would want to
assign it to some kind of variable
and then i would want to read that
second file right and then eventually
once i read the second file
then of course i would want to create
that new file
and the way it's going to look like i'm
going to go with const and
i'll say first and you can name it first
text
i'm just going to know it first and this
will be equal to my result okay awesome
and then right after that result again
i'm going to go with
read file and then the same thing
we provide a path so we go with content
and then in this case of course we're
looking for second
and then txt then we need to provide the
encoding
so node knows how to decode that and we
go with utf-8
and then of course we need to provide
our callback again
same deal we go with error and result
and in order to speed this up i will
copy and paste so just grab everything
starting with if
and ending with the result copy and
paste
again this is the case where we're
checking for the error first if there is
an error we cancel log it
and if everything is successful we
assign this one to the second one
and then eventually now i would want to
set up my
right file so again it is a function we
need to provide that value
and we already have result sync txt
that's why i'll create a new one and
i'll call this result
and async so again we're looking for the
content
then we go with the filename which is
going to be result
and a sync and
txt of course since there is no file
node will create that for us
i'll right away set up my data now if
you want of course you can copy and
paste
this functionality this is totally up to
you where basically we use two of them
and in my case this is exactly what i'm
going to do in order to speed this up
if you want to create something from
scratch of course that is also an option
and i'm just going to copy and paste
that's my template string
and again if you want to add this flag
you can definitely do so in my case i'm
just going to omit that
so here's the result i have first and
second
and the reason why i have access to them
because of course
i'm looking in the outside scope
of this callback function and then again
we have a callback function in the right
file
i know there's tons of callback
functions that's why we'll have to set
up
a better setup when we're handling these
callbacks
but we'll do that a little bit later so
for now let's just add
a comment here where we have first
parameter second parameter
and then third parameter and of course
this is going to be again our callback
where we have error
and result and then inside of this
callback
finally we can take a look at the value
and of course the value
will be in this result now of course
we're creating the file and all that
but hopefully you get the gist that if
you'd be doing something
where you're looking for this result of
course it would be over here
so again let's check for error quickly
if there is an error
then of course i would want to return as
well as console log the error
just in case and if everything is
correct let me just console log
the result so save it here and
two things we need to watch out for
maybe there's an error
and second one we should create a new
file by the name
result and then async txt
let me clear the console and we're going
to run
node app.js and i do get an error
and error simply tells me that i did not
add the dot
in front of the content so i would need
to go back
to write file and just add that
and once we add the dot we are going to
be in good place
where i'll clear the console and i'll
run one more time
node app.js and then the result will be
undefined
okay that's fine like i said in this
case we're not
expecting anything back but what's
really cool
that in the result async we should
have our text here is the result hello
this is first text
and then the second text so hopefully it
is clear
this is how we would use the async
pattern
so let me zoom out right now here and
you'll see this
famous callback hell and in the next
video
i would want to give you a brief
description
of what are the differences between the
asynchronous approach
or non-blocking approach and the
blocking one the synchronous one
as well as what are the alternatives to
this callback l all right and just to
give you an early taste
of the differences between the
asynchronous or
non-blocking and synchronous which is a
blocking code
why don't we set up few console logs now
before we do that
i will create a new file and i'll say 11
here and by the way i definitely need to
zoom in
just so you don't think that i'm
cheating fs and
async js and let's go to
the address we'll select everything and
copy
and paste and of course in next video
we'll set up different module in this
appdress so
for time being i can just remove it and
then like i promised we'll set up
some console logs so why don't we go
back to fs
and by the way during this video i'll
zoom out
because i definitely wanna go back to
this
evil evil callback hell that we're
getting
from nesting callback within the
callback
and as far as fa sync let me zoom in
and why don't we set up a console log in
few places
let's say before we're accessing the
file
so i'm gonna go with log and we'll say
start
then we're gonna go with write file sync
and then right after that we're gonna
say i'm done with the task
and then inside there let's write done
with this
task copy and paste and we're gonna go
with starting the next one starting
the next one meaning the next task
so that should do it and of course i
need to go with
clear so clear my console and i'm gonna
go to node
and then the file name is 10 iphone
and then fs and we're looking for sync
i run it and notice something
interesting
where i have the start so that is going
to be before
i read the files and only then once i'm
done
writing that file i have done with this
task
and starting a next one and what we need
to imagine
that of course this task of getting
those files
as well as the second one of setting up
that file
well it might be very time consuming
right and
imagine that if we have even 10
users and they're all the time using our
application and
if for example this one user does this
one task
or both of them and they take really
long time what
means that node is not going to be able
to serve
other users and trust me it is at the
end of the
really really big deal and notice how
javascript is
reading this code synchronously it just
goes line by line
so we start with this task then we read
these files
and then we write the result and again
if this is something that takes
really long time then pretty much your
application is down
so no other user can do anything with
that application because one of the
users
is for example reading these two files
and then
writing one again this is a very simple
example but you need to picture
that of course there's going to be tasks
that take
longer time and as an alternative let's
take a look at the
async approach so here again we'll set
up some simple console logs and again
we'll cover this in a bigger detail a
bit later
for time being let's just set up console
logs and you'll see the biggest
difference
where i'm gonna go with log and let's
say start so i'm gonna do that
before i read this file and
then i would want to go inside of the
right file
the last one and instead of console
logging result which of course
is undefined since in this case we are
not getting anything back
now i want to go with done with
this task and then right after
my first read file i'm going to go with
log and starting next
task hopefully you're able to follow
along again
before the read file inside of the right
file
and then right after the first read file
because of course the other ones are
nested inside of this callback
and then if we go to node and if we just
change it around
to 11 and then fa
and i believe it was async and if we run
it
notice something cool where i have my
start
and then i right away have this starting
next task
and eventually i have this done with
this task
so what this means is that since we have
this asynchronous approach
the moment we start this task we just
offload
we just offload this task and we
continue
with our code so that way when user
number one for example
comes here and wants to get this
functionality
yeah sure here node just offload this
task
and then your application can keep on
serving
other users again it seems a bit trivial
at the moment because we have a basic
approach but hopefully you get an idea
where in one case we have everything
happening line by line
so only when we're done with the task
we're starting a next one
and with this approach we start a task
and we just offload that task and then
we start
a next task right away and eventually
yes
we have done with this task in the
console
as well now as far as the implementation
as far as the callbacks
yes this is a bit messy right notice how
we only
want to accomplish few tasks and it's
already somewhat off a pain
now alternatives are using promises
as well as async await now again
hopefully you understand that when we
talk about reading the file
as well as the writing or file i use
this
as an example of some kind of task
that would take a long time now for the
remainder of the course mostly it's
going to be
reading from the database writing to the
database
and that sort of thing but this is a
very good illustration of how some tasks
would take some time so of course we
would need to use a callback
and as far as the callbacks yes you can
use them but the code
is going to get messy somewhat quickly
that's why
a bit later in the course we'll take a
look at the alternatives which
are promises and a sync await
and i have to tell you honestly for the
remainder of the course
we'll use async await because in my
opinion
it is just easier to work with excellent
and up next we have http module but
before we continue let me just
mention that i purposely won't spend too
much time
on explaining every single http method
we're going to use in great detail and
here's why
you see starting from next section all
of our work
meaning code in some shape or form
will revolve around server setup
aka http module so that point of course
i will cover every last bit of syntax in
great detail
at this point though i think it's just a
waste of our time
so if you're confused about something
http related
don't sweat it we will return to that
subject shortly
and cover it in far greater detail
now if you're wondering why we bother
with http
module at this point at all since we're
going
to use it later anyway you see with the
help of
http module i believe i can show you
some core features of node in action
and give you somewhat of a visual
representation of them
otherwise i would have to base
everything on slides and
i don't think it's the best approach so
long story short
if you're iffy about something http
related
just please be patient and i'll answer
all your questions
in the next course section nice
i think we've got a good initial
understanding of how the
file system module works in node and
hopefully i did not lose
too many of you so hopefully there are
still some students left in the course
because i fully understand that seeing
this for the first time
is probably a bit overwhelming
and what i would want to do next is
cover the
last initial module the built-in module
and that is going to be the
http module which is going to allow us
to set up a web server
now please keep in mind one thing we'll
just cover the basics
because the large part of this course is
going to be
creating your own server and setting up
the api
now granted we will use an abstraction
on top of the http module and that is
going to be the package by the name of
express but the whole point is going to
be exactly the same that's why again
we're not going to cover everything in
greatest detail
at the moment because i don't see the
point of repeating myself
and now i want to go back to objects
i'll zoom back
in just so you can see better what is
happening
by the way let me check my zoom level so
i'm going with settings
and i think that should do it my zoom
level is two at the moment
and then back in the app.js let's grab
the http module
and we'll assign it to some kind of
variable as always let's go with
require and we're looking for http
that's the module name and the method we
would want to use
is create server again we'll assign this
to some kind of variable
and in this case the variable name will
be server then we go with http
create server and this create server
method
is looking for the callback and in that
callback function
we have two parameters and both of those
parameters
are objects and since they're parameters
you can call it whatever you would want
but
a common practice is calling them rec
and res now this first parameter
represents the
incoming request so imagine a client is
requesting from the web browser
your webpage so you'll have information
about the method and all kinds of useful
stuff
in that request object and the response
is what we're sending back now we're not
done of course we'll set up more code
here
but before we do anything we also would
need to
specifically say what port our server is
going to be listening to
and that's why we'll go with server and
listen so that's another method and
again this is
arbitrary but i'm gonna go with 5000.
again if this looks like a lot of
gibberish where we have the request
response
as well as the ports don't worry later
in the course i'll cover
that in more detail as well as show you
some
useful slides and all that good stuff
and as far as the response well we have
few methods
we have write so we go with arrest and
again this
is the object and notice here how i'm
not using the rack yet
so i'm not checking for anything i'm
just concerned about my response
and the method name is right and inside
the right
we just come up with some kind of text
and i'll say
welcome to
our homepage homepage
and once we have sent back the response
i also would wanna end
my request so i'm gonna go with res.end
and once we're done setting up the code
inside of the callback function
now of course i would want to open up my
terminal
clear everything and we would need to
spin the sucker up
and of course the way we do that is node
and then objects
since that is the file name make sure
that you save it though so before i run
i'll save it and then notice something
interesting
notice how we're not exiting so
previously every time
we ran the file every time we ran
node and then whatever the file name we
exited from the file right
so node was done executing the code and
we just moved on
now in this case since we have a web
server
what do web servers do they keep on
listening for requests
and actually you want your server to
always be up
and of course if i go to my web browser
and then i'll make this bigger and if we
go with localhost
and of course in this case we have 5000
there it is we have welcome to our
homepage
so now of course we have effectively
created
our first website now granted
it's very basic but at least we have
something
on screen and before we discuss the
external modules
and actually set up a module that nicely
watches
our code and does the restarts for us
i also want to showcase what we have in
the
request object now this is going to be a
giant object
so i'm not going to cover each and every
property however
i would want to showcase a property that
gets
us the url and what would be the url
well that would be an address
and if you're worked with reactor or dom
you know that
for example for the homepage we used
forward slash and then
if the client wants to go to for example
about page
he or she would enter forward slash and
then the about
now in our case notice how we're still
serving the same content
so just to give you a quick introduction
of the request object as well as set up
a bit more realistic application we're
going to go with the request now again
if you want you can log it so we're
going to go
here with request and you'll see that it
is a giant object
now since we made some changes we do
need to stop it and then we'll go with
node object but notice how we're not
right away console logging the request
object why
well because server is waiting
for those requests so we need to go back
to our browser
and then refresh and then of course once
we navigate back
like i said this is going to be a giant
object
which bunch of useful info now what
we're looking for
is the url property because that url
property is going to tell us
well what address client is requesting
so what endpoint the client is
requesting
and like i said for the home page the
common practice is using
simple forward slash so in here we can
set up the
if statement where i say if request url
is equal to the home page then of course
this is what i would like to send back
and just to speed this up i can tell you
that we can cheat a little bit
where we can just place everything in
the end
and in my case i'll just cut out my
string
so we have res dot end so now we simply
send the text
and now of course i also would want to
check for the about
or contact or whatever so in here let's
go with if
and then request and url and if that one
is equal
to about about then of course i can send
different text
and as far as the text i'm just going to
say here is
our short history and then lastly well
what happens if the user
is trying to access a resource that
doesn't exist
on our server so we'll have the about
page we'll have the home page
what about if the user is asking for a
contact page that we don't have well
here we'll simply set up a default
response
we'll say res that end and just to make
it interesting i'll set up
the template string and i'll show you
that if we really want to
we can also pass indirectly html
and i'll say oops an explanation point
i'll close
my html again please understand this is
just a basic scenario of course
that's not how we'll be setting up our
apis or nothing like that
but just to give you a quick intro we'll
do it quick
and dirty where there's going to be a
paragraph and we'll say we can't
seem to find the page that you're
looking for
page you are looking for
looking for and at the very end i would
want to set up a
link that allows the user to
navigate back so go with href and i'll
say forward slash which just means
home page and we're gonna go back home
let's close
our link let's save that one so
at the moment of course we have the
about and by the way
almost forgot yes we do need to stop the
server and we need to go with
node and then app.js refresh
one more time there it is notice how we
don't have the about we can't seem to
have the page you're looking for
and that is actually a bit interesting
because it should be available right
and of course the reason is because i
messed up on the url property my bad
let me do this one more time and we'll
stop the server here
again let's run node app.js and now we
should have
here's our short history that's our
about page
then we have the homepage and of course
you already familiar
with our error page so if i'll go with
error
or any kind of resource that doesn't
exist then of course we'll get
the error page and of course we can
bravely navigate back home
and we go back to our home page that
should do it for the quick
intro of base modules and now of course
we are ready to move on to our next
topic all right at this point we're
familiar with two types of modules
our own as well as the nodes built-in
ones
but just like in any good infomercial
i'll say but wait there's more
we also have access to the world's
biggest code store
and before you seriously start
questioning my mental state
imagine this scenario you're building an
app
and of course as any good app it needs
to have a slider
just for funsies now at this point you
generally have two options
build it from the scratch yourself or
search on google and copy paste someone
else's solution
well have no issues with either of these
options
keep in mind that someone somewhere has
struggled
with the same issue the need for the
slider
and there's a good chance that that
person was kind enough
to build it and share the whole project
with us
so our only job is to go through the
docs
and with the help of one command just
add it to our project
we can do that because when we install
node
we automatically also install npm
or node package manager
and npm enables us to do three things
reuse our own code in other projects
use code written by other developers
and lastly share our own solutions with
other developers as well the npm project
is hosted at npmjs.com again the site is
npm.js and here you can find
everything starting with useful utility
functions
to full-blown frameworks and libraries
and as an example if you're familiar
with react you know that
react has the create react app package
and of course it is hosted on the npm
a typical node project will have
more than few npm packages installed as
dependencies
and before we install some cool packages
let's talk about naming
npm calls the reusable code a package
and a package essentially is a folder
that contains
a javascript code now another names
you'll hear
are modules and dependencies
and honestly at this point all three are
used
interchangeably when talking about
shareable javascript
code so don't be surprised if during the
course i call them
any of these names package dependency or
module
at the end of the day they all mean the
same thing lastly
let me just mention two things first
there is no quality
control in npm registry anyone
can publish anything so it's up to you
to sniff out the empty
and useless packages and yes there are
quite a few
of those ones out there as well a good
indication
of the security and usefulness of
package is the amount of
weekly download if the number is high
meaning
if it's popular it's a good chance that
it's a battle tested and ready to go
and that brings me to my second point
remember the slider example we discussed
in the beginning of the video
when it comes to npm packages there's a
good chance
that if there is a bug someone else has
already fixed it
and as a result it's already fixed in
the package
or there's a working solution all right
so that you did for intro let's start
using node
package manager in our own project
and as a side note if you want to search
for some packages
just visit npmjs.com
and then for example if you're looking
for the bootstrap you'll find the
package
and of course you can click on any of
them this will bring you to the docs
as well as weekly downloads and rest of
the stuff
once we're familiar with node package
manager let's see how we can start using
it
in our own project and the good news is
that it's much simpler
than you would expect you see when we
install node
we also install npm and because of that
we have access to
npm global command and you can check the
npm version by running
npm version in your terminal
just keep in mind that the version most
likely won't be the same as your
node version and that is totally okay
so you can either do that in the
terminal
or of course in the integrated terminal
and you can simply type npm
and then hyphen hyphen version i believe
you can also check by hyphen hyphen v
and there it is of course now we have
the
version for our node package
manager and then we have two flavors we
can install package
as a local dependency and that just
means that
we'll only use that package in this
particular project
that we're working on and the command
for that one would be
npm install or i for short
and then whatever is the package name so
whether that is bootstrap low dash
express
or whatever or we can install dependency
as a global dependency and that just
means that we can use it in
any project and the command for that one
would be again npm
i or install whichever method you prefer
and then hyphen g so this is going to be
the flag
and then again the package name now when
you install something globally most
likely
on a mac they will ask you for the sudo
so you'll have to provide the
credentials
that's why you'll run sudo npm
install and then hyphen g and again
package name
as far as which one you'll use more
often that definitely will be
a local dependency flavor because
even though yes you can install packages
globally
with arrival of npx there's
actually less and less need for setting
up
something globally that's why we'll
focus on local dependencies first
how to set it up in our project and then
in a few videos when we talk about
npx i'll cover why
there's less need for setting up
something globally
now there's one more thing that we would
need to set up in our project
as far as dependencies so i know i know
you're eager to start
installing the packages but
let's just wait a little bit and next
video we'll add that
extra thing that we're missing right now
and then we'll be in good shape and then
we'll start installing
every package under the sun excellent
we now know that we have access to the
npm global command
we now know that in order to install the
local package
we will need to run npm i and the
package
name so what are we missing well we're
missing
file by the name of package.json
and essentially you can think of it as a
manifest file
that stores important information about
our project and there are three ways how
you can
create package.json first is the manual
approach
where you just create a package.json in
the root
and please do that in the root if that's
something
that eventually you decide doing and
then of course you would need to create
each property or there are two
ways how we can automate this and the
first one is running
npm init and in there they'll just
step by step ask you the questions and
if you want to skip it
you can just press enter and the another
way the third way
is running npm init with a y flag
and then everything is set up as default
so i'm not going to show you the manual
approach
it's just too time consuming and we'll
right away go with npm in it first i'll
show you the step
by step approach and then of course i'll
show you how everything
is set up by default using the y flag
so go to your terminal and just type npm
in it
and there it is of course now they tell
you that
there's going to be a walkthrough of
creating a package.json file
and the first one is the package name
and by default of course
it is going to use the folder name now
keep in mind that
if you eventually want to publish this
package
then the name has to be unique so you
need to make sure that
nowhere in the npm you can
see the package with the same name and
i'm just gonna go with tutorial as far
as version
we'll talk about versions shortly
so i'll just skip this one as far as
description whatever again
is just the default now as far as the
entry point eventually will change it
but for now
it's good enough we're going to go with
one intro js
and then the test command as well as git
repository
and keywords and author and license and
we simply say
yes and we are in good shape so now of
course we have the package
json file with name version description
as well as the main property
and of course the scripts author and the
license
now i'll remove it i'll say delete
and i'll show you that of course you can
skip all those questions
by simply typing npm in it
and why and as you can guess
yes of course you can come here later
and then just change these values
that's why it's definitely faster to
just type
npm in it and then the y flag
so why do we need this package.json
well because if i would want to install
the package
the local package now of course this
package
is going to be stored as a dependency
and to show you that let's just go with
npm and you know what
let me clear the console first so we're
going to go with npm
i and then we're going to go with the
package name
lowdash and if you're not familiar with
lodash it's just a utility library and
i'm just specifically using
for installation purposes there's no
real
reason to have low dash for our own
project but
it's just something pretty interesting
that i would want to showcase that's why
we're using
lodash and we run it and notice how we
installed the package
and check it out now in the package.json
we have dependencies property and it's
an object and
inside of that object we have a package
by the name of lowdash
now i'll show you in this video or maybe
in the next one
why it's so important to have this
package.json
but another thing that i would want to
showcase once we can see that
we have dependencies property if you go
in your visual studio code
and if you click on refresh explorer
what you'll also notice is this node
modules folder and in that node modules
folder
this is where all the dependencies are
stored
so if you don't have that folder already
and pm creates it so in our case of
course we didn't have any dependencies
so when we install that first dependency
npm
creates that folder and this is where
you'll find the dependencies
now notice something interesting where
for the low dash
we only have one folder right so we have
only one dependency but when we need to
keep in mind
that of course there's going to be some
packages
that have other dependencies and that's
why i first
installed lodash just to showcase that
yes once you install dependency
of course it is going to be in node
modules but
if you'll try to install a package that
is bigger
that uses other dependencies you'll
notice
something pretty cool where if i clear
my terminal and if i'm gonna run
npm i and then bootstrap again
you can use any other package you'd want
this is just to showcase
how the packages work we won't use the
bootstrap
in this project so once i install and
once i refresh check it out not only i
have
low dash not only i have bootstrap which
i installed
but since bootstrap is using jquery
as well as the proper js now these are
installed
as dependencies and if you take a look
at the dependencies property
now of course we have the bootstrap as
well and
again the whole point of this video is
to showcase why we need package.json
so we need it because we need to provide
information
about our project and inside there
a very important property is the
dependencies one
because in there we'll just store the
dependencies
which our project is using and then some
packages
are actually going to use more
dependencies and they will be
automatically installed as well in our
case
that was bootstrap and just to
give you a taste of the package
why don't we just navigate to app and
i'm going to do that below the comments
of course you probably would need to
clean the file and as a side note
the last module the http i saved
in file by the name of 12 http
and back in the app.js in order to start
using
the module in our case i guess i'm gonna
go with low dash
first i would need to set up the
variable and common convention
is calling the variable like so and
we'll set it equal to
require and now of course we have access
to the low dash
now this is the difference between node
packages
like for example the http
or the file module or whatever and the
ones that you
install the external ones the external
ones you always have to install first
if you won't install the dependency well
node won't be able to find it
so in our case we did install the
dependency the lowdash
so now of course i can just assign it to
the variable and since lowdash is
utility library
why don't we test out one of their
methods
and i'm just going to go with items and
i'll create an array of arrays
so items is going to be an array however
the items are going to be
arrays itself so two and three
and then we're gonna go with four and
low dash has this method
the flat and deep method that
effectively
will just spit this back as a flat
array and the way we set it up we just
go
with const and i'll call this new items
and then since we have access to
everything
in this variable now i can simply go
with
underscore here dot and then
flat and deep so flatten deep
and then we'll pass in the items and now
if we console log
new items and if i go to my terminal and
just type node app.js and by the way i
need to save it
so let me go back i'll say node app.js
and once we run check it out in a
console i can see of course the
one two three four so lowdash has the
method by the name of flattendeep
we have access to it because we install
it as dependency
and now of course i can start using it
now
we're not gonna use bootstrap in this
project
because that would be too time-consuming
bootstrap was just used
so you can see that some dependencies
will have more packages so once we
install one dependency there's actually
going to be more dependencies
and hopefully you have a clear
understanding of how you would set up
package.json how we would install the
package and next video i would want to
showcase
why having package.json is so crucial
and so beneficial when we are starting
to share our project with other
developers awesome we have package.json
we installed few dependencies and now i
want to cover
why having package.json is so crucial
when we start sharing our project with
other developers and for this example
i'm going to use
github as well as few basic git commands
and my assumption is that since this is
somewhat of
a advanced course you're already
familiar with git
and github and you have the account if
you don't please stop the video create
the account
and just use your favorite search engine
to learn about the basics
of setting up the github repository as
well as
basic git commands so
our task is to push this up to the
up and now million dollar question are
we just pushing
everything up including the mode modules
which for the most projects is going to
be somewhat big
i believe i just checked in our case it
was like
nine megabytes but trust me it always
gets
way bigger than that or
we would just want to send the code and
you can probably already guess
that since i'm implying that the size is
too big
that we'll have to push this up to the
github
without the node modules and we'll start
by creating a dummy repo
on a github so let me open up a new
window
i'm going to go with github and i'll
just create
a temp repo and then i'm just going to
create a repo
and i'm looking for these three commands
essentially i would want to get that url
the remote url so i know where to push
it
and then inside of the repo before we
set it up as github repo
first i would want to go with new file
and we'll create
a git ignored because of course what i
would want is to place
the node modules in a git ignore file
because that way they will be ignored by
my source control
and i won't be pushing up this giant
folder
to the github because you'll see in a
second
that there is no need for it so we're
going to go with forward slash and then
node modules and if you're not familiar
with git ignored
it's just a file that specifies which
files are going to be ignored by the
source control and in our case as you
can see
i'm placing node modules inside there
then i'll clear my console and i'll just
initialize this
as an empty git repo and then we'll
add everything so git add git commit
we'll just say first commit
first commit and then i'll copy and
paste those three commands
in order to set up that url the
remote url and once i have this
in place should be able to go back to my
github
and there it is this is my repo
now probably your next question is okay
so
we pushed it up to the github but i can
clearly see that in my app.js
well technically i'm using the load as
dependency right
but we didn't push up the node modules
folder
so how the person who is going to get
this repo
will be able to run the code in the
app.js
since there's no node modules and you
told us previously that we can only run
it
if the dependency is there well let's
check it out
i'm going to go with clone option so
i'll just get the
url i'll navigate back here
and i'll do that in messed up again it
doesn't really matter
we're just going to go with desktop and
then git clone
now i copy and paste the url i'll open
up
a new instance of my text error
copy and paste and this is where the
magic happens
if we have package json we simply need
to run
npm install and what is going to happen
the npm will check for dependencies that
we have in the package.json
and automatically set up that
node modules folder so if i go here
first of all i can see that there has
been some changes that is already good
news
that just means that i have my node
modules and if i refresh
check it out so now of course i have my
node modules folder and if you have been
using react applications you're probably
already familiar with this one
where again when you are setting up
the code you're not sharing the node
modules folder
and i can showcase that by taking a look
at my react projects
and that's not what i wanted i didn't
want to look at my awesome picture
what i wanted is react and then let's go
with
project and you'll see that in that repo
we have bunch and bunch of folders
and each folder has two more folders
final and setup
and now check it out none of them have
the node models because imagine the size
of this sucker if i would push for
every project for every folder
the node modules instead i have package
json
so when you get the repo when you clone
the repo or download or whatever
then of course you get the package json
and in here these are the dependencies
and you just run
npm install and they are being installed
okay hopefully it is clear that why it
is so crucial to have the package.json
because
we can just share the code without
dragging the massive
node modules folder with us we can
simply just provide
what packages our project is using
and then once we get the repo then we
just run
npm install that is the command and then
npm will install
all the packages that are in the
dependencies
awesome we're familiar with npm we're
familiar with package.json
now let's finally install the dependency
that we'll use for the remainder of the
course and that is no other
than the node one and of course if you
want to get more info
you can visit the npm and you can search
for the package
but as far as the general setup is just
to watch our files and then restart our
app for us
so that way we don't have to each and
every time
type node and then whatever the file
name
and we can install it as a simple
dependency
that is definitely an option but since i
also would want to cover
depth dependencies we'll install that as
a depth dependency
and the command for dev dependencies is
following
where we go with npm and then i or
install
whatever and then we go with nodemon so
that is the package name
and then you can either do hyphen d
so that just signals that that is a that
dependency or
you'll see this save and dev
so again whichever method you choose
that is really up to you
but just remember that both of them will
save it as
a dev dependency so let's install it and
then i'll talk about it
why we would want to set up as a div
dependency
and the reason for that is because if we
think about it do we really need
nodemon in production and the answer is
no when we push it up
to digitalocean or heroku or whatever
we'll of course use something more
serious than nodemon to restart
our application pm2 comes to mind
but while we're developing yeah that is
an option
so in this case we'll add right away
nodemon
to the dev dependencies now what else
what kind of packages we would add to
dev dependencies for example testing
packages
for example linting for example
formatting
and that sort of thing again nothing
stops you from jamming this
in dependencies but if you think about
it
it makes way more sense if we add this
as
dev dependency so we use it while we are
creating the app
but then once it's in production then we
just share
the dependencies that actually the app
is using
not the ones that we used while we
developed the app
hopefully that is clear and once we have
the package
we're almost there now we just need to
understand how the
scripts work in a package.json
and at the moment as you can see we have
the test one we won't use that one
and inside of the script object we just
set up the commands
and as a side note we can set up the
command right now even without the node
mod
for example i could go with start
and that command will be equal to npm
and or i'm sorry node and then for
example app.js
so that is my command and once i save my
package.json
instead of running this node app.js
i can simply run npm and start
and there it is as you can see same
functionality
i run app.js and i get back the array
as well as the hello world again we
still exit the application
so it's not like we're out of the woods
but i'm just showcasing that yes
we can set up the commands and then in
the command we just provide a value
and in this case of course it is node
and
app.js now for some commands you can
simply type npm
start as you can see but for some of
them
you'll have to provide the full value
and that is going to be npm
run and nor to showcase that i'm going
to go with dev
and that one will be equal and here
we're gonna go with
a node mod and then
app.js so instead of running node
like we're doing in the start now i'm
setting up a dev command
and in order to run this one i'll have
to go with
run and then whatever here's the command
name again some of them you'll be able
to use the shortcut
where you go with start and some of them
you'll have to go the full route with
npm run and then whatever is the command
and as a side note
yes you can still run npm run start
and this is also going to invoke the
command but
in our case we have dev and in here i
have
nodemon and then app js
so let's try it out let's say first the
package
json and you should notice something
pretty cool
where if i go with npm run
and dev now i'm spinning up the node one
and it tells me that nodemon is watching
my application and since i know that of
course we can test it out
where i'm gonna go with console.log
and then instead of the hello world
which i have
after new items i'm gonna go with hello
people
and you should see something interesting
where once i change the text yep nodemon
restarts
my app and now of course my value is
hello people
awesome so now i don't have to
type every time the node and then
whatever file name
nodemon automatically just restarts my
app
and i simply set it up as a script
now if you want to change this around if
you don't want to run
npm around dev you can simply say
nodemon
and then app.js and just remove the dev1
completely
and a side note again if you have worked
with
react project you are familiar with the
setup because for react again we run npm
start
and then there's a value that spins up
the whole
react dev server where we can see our
application
not bad not bad well we're still on a
roll let's cover
how we can uninstall the package as well
and as a side note if you want to stop
the nodemon
just press again ctrl and c and notice
how we're of course
stopping the nodemon and again if we
want to spin up
we'll just go with npm start
and as far as uninstalling the package
we have the command for that and the
name is uninstall
so i'll stop the nodemon and in the
terminal i'll type
npm uninstall and then of course the
package name
which in my case is going to be a
bootstrap
now this is one of the approaches how we
can do that and there's also
a nuclear approach now why i'm calling
this a nuclear approach because that way
we remove the whole node modules folder
and don't worry
once you run the npm install then of
course you set everything back
up from the scratch as well as you would
remove this package like json and don't
worry
i will cover the package.json file
a bit later and the way that is going to
look like
well we can first clear the terminal
i'll install the bootstrap
from the scratch again so say bootstrap
here
and by the way probably need to add npm
i and now again as you can see i have it
as my dependency
and then like i said the nuclear
approach is
removing the node modules yep and then
removing the package log
and then just running npm
install now of course in the
package.json if i want to remove
the bootstrap for example in this case i
can simply remove it from my
dependencies
so i just remove it in the package.json
then clear everything
and then we go with npm and then install
and now we'll get from the scratch the
node modules
since we're the ones who removed it and
also we'll get that package hyphen
lock json now i'm showing you that
nuclear approach
because if you have used gatsby you know
that cats be somewhat notorious for
sometimes just being a little bit
annoying
where you do need to remove the cache
folder you do need to remove the node
modules as well as package lock
and then once you start up everything
from scratch
then as a magic the gatsby app starts
working
and check it out if we take a look at
the node modules
now yes there's a bunch of modules that
nodemon is using
right but there's no bootstrap and i can
clearly see that
because there's nothing under the letter
of b
so we can clearly see that we removed
bootstrap from
our dependencies all right and now let's
take a look at how we can
install package globally and what would
be some of the use cases
and first let's start with command let's
jog our memory
command was npm install and then dash
g and the package name and in mac
they might ask you for permissions so
you'll have to start with sudo
and then again same spiel npm install
blah blah blah
and first i want to showcase that i
haven't installed
nodemon globally and
the easiest way for me to showcase that
is by running
nodemon and app js
so we'll try to install nodeman package
globally why
well because then i can use nodemon in
any of my projects at the moment
i have it as a local package and of
course i can spin it up by running
npm start but let's imagine scenario
where i have
i don't know 20 nodal applications and
i'm constantly working on node
applications
so to make my life easier i will install
node 1 globally and then i won't get
this error
because at the moment you can see
command not found normal
all right so how do we do that well we
can install it
in our terminal or we can do it in the
integrated thermal
it doesn't really matter when it comes
to global packages you can
install it from anywhere so in my case
i'm just going to navigate back to my
terminal
just so you don't think that i'm
cheating and i'll zoom in and we'll
simply run
and by the way i need to start with sudo
and then npm
install and hyphen g and of course we're
looking for nodemon so now of course
i'm prompted to enter my password
and once i enter my password of course
i'm going to install nodemon globally
and now
in any of my projects i can simply go
with command of nodemon and then
whatever
is the file name now to show you some of
the use cases
if you work with gatsby you know that
they have the
global gatsby cli tool and that was one
of the reasons why you installed
something globally is because
well you used one of the frameworks for
example react
or gatsby in this case and then of
course in order to set up the gatsby
project
or react project you needed to install
this globally
now things have changed though with
arrival of
npx and i'll talk about the npx at the
end of the video
but notice if you navigate to your react
docs and if you look for
create react app which again was
something that you needed to install
globally now they suggest this npx route
where essentially you go with npx
and then again whatever is the command
name for example
for create react app that would be
create react app
for strappy the headless cms that would
be
create strappy app and hopefully you get
the gist where
for every resource that of course would
be different and
with that command you don't have to
install that tool
globally for example again in our case
we're installing nodemon but
normally prior to npx you would install
this
create react app globally and then you
can spin up
those react projects now i'm going to go
back to my terminal as you can see i was
successful
so what's going to happen if i go back
to my project
and if i run nodemon and app.js
since i have installed that package
globally
there it is i spin up my app.js and if
you don't believe me
i can change it back to hello world and
i have no issues hello world
and there it is now of course i have
hello world
e in the console so hopefully it is
clear that yes
we can install packages globally and yes
one of the biggest use cases was working
with some type of front-end library but
with an arrival of npx things have
shifted
where now those libraries suggest using
the
npx route instead as far as my personal
preference
since i'm recording a lot of courses and
since some of the global packages
usually introduce some kind of bugs to
the students now
not for all the students but there's
always this one student who just has
a lot of issues with the global package
personally
i avoid them as much as possible so i
always either use the mpx
or i just set it up as a local
dependency again
it's not a rule you can do whatever you
would want but
i'm just telling you what is my
preferred option
as far as what is npx it stands for
execute
and official name is the package runner
it is a feature that was introduced in
npm
5.2 and again the main
idea is following where you can run that
cli tool
for example in this case create react
app without
installing these globally so as long as
you have npm with a version of 5.2
or greater instead of doing this whole
spiel of setting up
the cli tool globally you just go with
npx
and then whatever here is the tool name
and of course the last one
is the folder name as far as the package
log json
why do we need it well if we take a look
at our dependencies we can see
that they have versions and
if you remember some of the dependencies
have dependencies on their own and of
course we need to keep in mind that
those dependencies have versions as well
and for example the person who gets your
project
you probably want them to have the same
exact setup because keep in mind
as these versions change well
so does some of the functionality
correct
so for example you set up to your whole
project you use some kind of dependency
that uses some other package and that
version changes
not for example for the bootstrap but
for the jquery
and then pretty much your project is
obsolete
meaning it might get some bugs because
the version of the jquery changed so
that's why you have this package.json
and in there you have those specific
versions
for all the packages not only for
dependencies
but also for the packages that the
dependency
is using now as far as this version
we have three values and you can think
of it as a
contract between us the people who are
using the package
and the person who is creating and
first number is a major change so when
this changes
that means that there are some breaking
changes now the second one
is a minor one so that means that it is
backward compatible so for example if
this changes to 18
i shouldn't expect any breaking changes
and the last one is just a patch
for the bug fix so that's also something
to keep in mind
when you decide to publish your own
package
that of course that's why we have here
this
version now lastly i would just want to
mention that if you're interested in
more info about the package.json i would
suggest
this resource so i simply went with
package.json then keep on scrolling keep
on scrolling and you're looking
for i guess this blog post right so the
name is
the basics of package.json and in here
you literally find everything explained
to the smallest
detail whether that is a name version
and rest of the fields that you can find
in a package.json
beautiful we now know how to utilize npm
and for starters
as a result for the remainder of the
course instead of frantically typing
node.js in a terminal we'll simply spin
up nodemon
and it will watch for the changes and
restart the app for us
now what before we move on to creating
servers with express.js
there are a few important node topics i
would like to cover first
and those topics are following event
loop async patterns in node.js
events emitter and streams in node.js
while these topics are extremely
important please keep in mind that our
goal
is to only understand the general ideas
behind these concepts
and i only introduce them so you have an
overall understanding of how things
work in node.js before we build our
first
node.js app if you're not satisfied with
my explanations or simply want to do
more research by yourself
just type any of these terms in your
favorite search engine
and i can guarantee you'll find plenty
of useful resources
within a matter of seconds like blog
posts youtube videos
and conference talks with that said it's
my strong
opinion that it might be easier to
understand those concepts
more deeply so not just a general
understanding but
understanding them more deeply once you
have one or few working
node apps under your developer's belt
let me also mention that in order not to
waste your time with time consuming
setup
in few upcoming videos i will run some
pre-built code
let me be very clear though i'm only
going to do that in a few videos
and for the remainder of the course we
will type out everything together
all right and let's kick things off by
discussing
the event loop now event loop in node.js
is one of those topics where i could
spend the entire course
discussing it and it still wouldn't be
enough
so let's try to avoid that and instead
just understand the journal concepts
while there are tons of useful event
loop explanations out there the one that
i probably like the most
is this one the event loop is what
allows node.js to perform non-blocking
i o so input and output operations
despite the fact that javascript is
single threaded
by offloading operations to the system
kernel
whenever possible and as you can see
i'm reading straight from the node docs
now don't beat yourself up if this
sounds like a lot of gibberish
there's a reason why one can dedicate
the entire
course just for event loop it is
a pretty complex topic but
one word i do want you to remember is
this offloading
and you'll see why in a second also
don't worry i have prepared
more examples as well as some slides to
get
my point across but just in case you're
not happy with my examples
or you just want to explore the note
event loop
in greater detail here are a few
external resources
i find particularly useful when it comes
to blog posts
just go to your favorite search engine
and type node.js
event loop and the one that i find
really useful
is this one and the resource is nodejs
and not.org but it is dot
dev and then follow the link and here
they cover event loop in great detail
with a lot of cool examples and pictures
and slides
and all that good stuff and when it
comes to videos
i would suggest going to youtube and
then just type
event loop and the first video that's
going to pop up
is going to be the event loop bot in
browser javascript
and i'll talk about it in a second and
the
nodejs specific event loop video
is this one i believe it's 15 minutes
long and
you can see the name over here so this
is
a very very useful video where the
speaker covers a lot of useful details
about node.js loop in great detail
and the reason why i'm suggesting the
first one as well
well what is the language that we use
in node that of course is javascript
right
and even though there's some differences
between the event loop
the one that we use in the browser and
the one that is in the node.js
if you understand the concepts behind
the event loop that we use in a browser
trust me you're already halfway there
to understanding how the no js
event loop works since it's such an
important topic
like promised i have prepared some of my
own resources
as well we'll start with the slides and
move on to the closed examples
in next video as a side note i made all
the course slides available
on course api.com again their website
name
is coors api.com and once you click on
the slides link
you'll see all the slides and i would
want to start our discussion by taking a
look at
what it means that javascript is
synchronous
and single threaded and effectively it's
just a fancy way of saying that
just repeat everything line by line
so for example if i have console log
with first task
then i have a for loop that takes some
time
in this case two seconds but that could
be 10 seconds that could be 20 or
whatever
and then i have another console log of
next task
javascript will just start reading
everything
and it will read it line by line and
if this takes a long time it will only
run
the next test once it's done performing
this time consuming one so hopefully
that is clear
that javascript just reads everything
line by line
and now let's take a look at our second
slide
and in here we can see the solution
if we would want to offload something
to the browser so when we're building
browser javascript apps
we have this option of offloading to the
browser now of course it doesn't mean
that we can offload the for loop
that's not going to work this
effectively is still going to be the
blocking code
but browser nicely provides the api
where we can offload those tasks to the
browser
and only when the task is done then we
execute
the callback and probably the example we
have done the most
is the fetch essentially when we make
the
network request but we can also do that
for example
with a set timeout so i still have
console.log with first task
but then even though my set timeout
function
has the second argument of zero so
essentially i have set timeout function
i provide the callback function that's
going to be executed
in certain amount of time even if this
is
zero meaning you would expect this one
to run
right away it only runs after
the next task so once javascript
is done executing the immediate code
only then it executes the callback
so in this case we have the set timeout
the api that is provided
from the browser and we just said that
we would want to execute that
e in zero seconds so effectively there
is no wait time however
javascript will first execute this code
and only then will execute
the callback so that way we can offload
those time consuming operations
to the browser again it doesn't mean
that we can offload for loops
it means that browser does provide some
apis
where we don't have to write the
blocking code
now let me be very clear though when i
say we cannot offload
for loops what i mean is that we can
still
write blocking code in javascript
but the browser does provide some nice
apis
where we can offload those time
consuming
tasks and that brings us to
our main friend the nodejs event loop
again before i go over the example let
me stress something
event loop is somewhat complex and this
is just to give you
a general understanding so let's imagine
this scenario
i have an app and just like any cool app
i have subscribers or users or however
you would want to call them
and in this case since my app is so so
popular
i have eight of them and
what do the users do well they're
probably being annoying and they're
requesting
something from the application and as
the requests are coming in
the event loop is responsible for
avoiding this type of scenario
so let's imagine this i have all these
users the requests are coming in
but larry the little decides that
in his request there's going to be some
kind of
time consuming i don't know database
crawl or something like that
so effectively he's requesting something
and behind the scenes in my code that
means that i need to perform
something that takes a long time
so in this case the event loop
just registers the callback so it
registers what needs to be done
when the task is complete because if the
event
loop wouldn't do that then we would have
this scenario
where the requests are coming in and
because
larry is requesting something that takes
a long time
the rest of the users would have to wait
and essentially it's not that the
actual operation takes a long time it's
just the fact that we're wasting our
time
on waiting for that operation
to be done and only then we can serve
the
other users but what the event loop does
it registers the callback and only when
the operation
is complete it executes it now keep in
mind that again we're not executing this
right away when we can effectively it's
the same scenario where
we run our immediate code first
and only then when we have the time we
execute the callback so for example in
this scenario
if i would have hundred console logs
after the next task
i would run them first and only then the
second task would appear here
regardless of what is the time set
in here because again we're running our
immediate tasks first and only then
we run the callbacks so the same thing
happens here
where the requests are coming in let's
say
that the operation is complete we first
registered the callback
operation is complete and instead of
executing that
callback right away it effectively gets
put
at the end of the line and then when
there is no
immediate code to run then we execute
the
callback hopefully that is clear event
loop is our best friend because
with the help of event loop we can
offload some
time consuming operations and
effectively just keep
all our users happy all right and once
we have looked at
the event loop in theory to hammer this
home
let's also take a look at some code
examples
where we can see event loop in action
as a side note all code examples are
located
in the event loop example directory so
if you need to take a look
just grab the repo and you can find it
there
and you should be familiar with our
first example
since it's a async version
of read file method so we import read
file
from the fs module and then we have
console.log
started our task first then we have
read file method where we pass the path
we pass the encoding
and then of course we have the callback
and then in the callback
i cancel logged first result and then of
course i have completed the first task
and then right after the read file
i have starting next task and something
really interesting
in a console i can see that we first
cancel logged
started the first task then i right away
have
starting the next task and then of
course once i'm done
once i get back my result then of course
i have hello this is first text file
and of course completed first task
and again the reason why is this
happening because read file
is a synchronous and we already know
that
event loop will offload this in this
case to a file system
so we start reading the file notice like
okay
run this line of code then offload this
one
and only when i get back to the result
then
run the callback so when the file system
responds
with error or the data then
we invoke this one all right so we
offload this task
and we just keep on reading the code
that's why we have
started the first task starting the next
one so right away go to the next test
and this one this asynchronous one well
we're just
offloading and then once the response
comes back
whether it's an error whether it's a
success only then
we invoke the callback hopefully that is
clear
now as far as this comment i only added
this one
because we need to keep in mind that of
course i'm just grabbing this code
from the file but the file is sitting
in the folder so if you were to run
nodemon and then directly the filename
which is of course going to be in the
event loop
the path won't match so this path only
matches because
of course i have app.js but if you'll
try to run this code directly
in this file that's why it's not going
to match and you need to go
one level up now my assumption is that
you're running it
the same as me and you're running that
with npm start that's why i kept the
path
matching to the one in the app.js now
our next example so let me clear my
app.js
i can close the read file as well as
package.json
and then the next one is set timeout so
select here everything
and copy and paste in my fgs i'll
restart
and then i have two console logs and the
third one
is e in a set timeout and this is pretty
typical example
for javascript loop as well if you have
taken javascript courses
which again i assume you have since
you're watching the note one
you probably remember this example where
i got you here is following yeah i have
the
console log first and i have the second
and third and you think that since set
timeout is set to zero
so since we're saying yeah call this
callback function
but actually wait only zero seconds
you'd think
that the order would be first second
and third right well wrong because we
have first
third and second why well because set
timeout
is asynchronous correct and what happens
with asynchronous
well they get offloaded so in this case
we run first
third and then the second because
this one gets offloaded again this one
goes to the back of the line
and only when we're done with our
immediate code pretty much with our
synchronous code only then we
invoke that callback all right now i
also
added these comments here where i have
started operating system process
and then completed and exited the
operating system process
and the reason why i'm showing you that
because in next two examples
we'll do something a little bit
different so now i would want to go
to set interval and by the way it's
going to be a bit clearer
if we run here node and then app.js
so let me stop this and i'll go with
node
and objects and you'll notice that we
started
the operating system process and then
the moment we're done with the code
that's it we exit now if we'll take a
look at the
set interval you'll notice something
really interesting where if i go with
node and app.js notice something
interesting and by the way
of course i didn't copy and paste so go
to the third example
and then just remove all this code and
copy and paste so that's my third
example
and in here i have the set interval now
again
yes we'll have to run few times node
app.js
and now check it out so what i see here
is
i will run first so that's my console
log
and then i have the set interval and
notice how we're not
exiting the process here so we start the
process
similarly to the second example but
if in the second example we actually
exited
because we completed all our tasks in
this case we're not doing that
why well because set interval is
asynchronous
now the difference between the set
timeout and set interval is the fact
that
set interval runs in those increments
in this case of course it is those two
seconds
so every two seconds the
event loop is just gonna invoke
that callback now that's why we're not
exiting
that's why we're still in the process
and
we can only exit the process if we kill
it so that would be control
and c or there's some unexpected error
otherwise it will always
stay alive now again keep in mind one
thing
where notice i will run first
was first why well because again this
is asynchronous and i know i've said
this before 20 000 times but
again this is probably the core building
block of no the fact that
every time we have some asynchronous
action it's just going to be offloaded
and then when it's time we invoke the
callback and our last example is a
server and again
i just wanted to showcase how the
process
stays alive so i'll take all the code
and copy and paste in app.js
now i'll stop this one so stop the
process
and then we'll clear the console and
again just to showcase how the process
stays live
i'm going to go with node and app.js and
i'm doing that so you're not confused
with nodemon and then check it out so we
have
server listening on port 5000
and then every time the request comes in
well we invoke this callback and in our
callback we're simply cancel logging
request event and then we send back the
hello world
so now if i were to go to a localhost
5000 there it is i have the response of
hello world
and in a console i'll see this request
event
and check it out how again this process
stays alive why well because listen
is asynchronous and the moment we set it
up
now event loop is just waiting for those
requests to come in
and then once they come in then of
course we run
our callback now please don't confuse
this callback with what we're responding
our
request i went so this callback is just
when we're setting up the server because
in here we can have the success over
there
so in our case as you can see everything
went great we have
server listening on port 5000 but of
course
there also might be an error
and this one of course just responds to
that
request event but the whole point is
with
server.listen we just say hey event loop
just keep listening for those incoming
requests
and the moments show up then respond to
them
appropriately hopefully it is clear and
of course we can move on to our next
topic all right and up next i want to
talk about
asynchronous patterns in node.js
so if we remember when we were setting
up
the file system module we covered how we
have two flavors
we have the synchronous one and the
asynchronous one
and while asynchronous one is great
since we're not blocking the
event loop the problem is that if we're
using this callback approach
well it gets messy pretty quickly
right because we're nesting one callback
inside of the other one
so now in the following videos i would
want to show you the alternative
that we'll use throughout the course and
why in my opinion
it is much cleaner syntax and that's why
of course we'll use it
and first what i would want is just to
kill everything here
and i'll start with the nodemon since
i'm done showing you the event loop and
we're just going to go with npm
start right that was the proper one and
now
i'll delete everything that i currently
have not
here sorry so i'll leave this one the
async one
i would want to remove everything in the
app.js
and now i just want to quickly show you
the code
that would block that event loop again
this is going to be the video
where if you don't want to code along
you don't have to
you can just sit back and relax and
effectively
you'll be in good shape and again we'll
set up the server
like i mentioned before already 20 000
times
don't worry about specific commands we
have
rest of the course where we'll be
building servers so trust me
you'll get sick of it so go with http
and require and of course we're looking
for http module
and then remember the methods create
server and listen
so we go with const and we create the
server
that is http and create server
we pass in callback a callback takes two
objects request object
and response object so again essentially
request
object is what is coming in and response
object just represents what we're
sending out what essentially we are
responding
and then i would want to listen on a
port again so i run server.listen
and then i'll pass in the port of 5000
and then of course we have that callback
once the
server is ready and in here we can just
go with console.log
and we'll simply say server is listening
on port 5000 server
is is listening or just listening
listening on port
and then of course in my case port is
5000
let's set that up so we should have this
listening on port 5000
and then of course in my callback
function
i would want to check 40 urls because i
want to show you
how even if we try to get a different
resource
we're still blocked by other user if he
or she
is requesting some kind of resource
where we have the blocking code and
don't worry
if this sounds like gibberish you'll see
what i mean in a second
so remember on the request object we
could check for the url
so effectively you could check what is
the resource
that the user is requesting so for
example home page would be forward slash
and then the about page would be forward
slash and about
and that is sitting in the property by
the name of
request and url so request is the object
and then
url is the property so again we'll do a
quick and dirty way we'll just say
request url is equal to
a forward slash that means it's a
homepage and then we just need to go
with a res.end
and then we'll say home page again later
we'll have
way more sophisticated approach but for
now this will do
and then we're checking for the about
page
okay awesome so this is going to be an
about page
and then if there's a page that doesn't
match
any of the resources then of course i'll
just send back
i don't know error page i'm not going to
set up the whole link
nothing like that all right we save it
and then this should send back about
page awesome
and then of course in home page i can
just respond
with the homepage so life is beautiful
users can come here and as a side note
multiple users i'm representing with
these tabs
so imagine these are my users and life
is beautiful
we are requesting resources and we're
just going on about our day
now the problem is going to be if i go
to about
and if i set up some kind of blocking
code
now what would be a blocking code well
that could be
a nested for loop so i'm just going to
go with blocking code and then
i'll add some exclamation points and
let's simply set up a for loop
let's say i is equal
to zero and then let's say
i is less than thousand and yep
i plus plus so every iteration will
increase by one
however i'll set it up as a nested
portal so copy and paste and i'll just
change these values
to j so j here
and j here and then let's just cancel
log
and we'll say j and i again doesn't
really matter what we type there
just say i and j
now known dialogue question what do you
think is gonna happen
so if the user navigates to about
i mean we can kind of see that this will
take some time
right now you would expect though that
only the user who navigates here gets
blocked
and you'd be wrong because we'll also
block
the other suckers who are just trying to
get to the homepage
so let me navigate here and check this
out so i run this one and notice
how we're loading now the same thing
happens here now
and here okay and only when we're done
here
then these two can get the resource
again
now of course if i go to my project i
can see that
in the console i have all these values
right
because i have this blocking code i have
the synchronous
code that just takes a long time and
this is just a representation
of why we prefer this asynchronous
now yes at the moment this is messy and
don't worry
in the next videos we'll fix it but this
hopefully gives you an idea why
you should always strive setting up your
code asynchronously
because what we've learned in the
previous videos
if we do that then those tasks are
offloaded
and then only when the data is back
only when it's ready then we invoke it
and that way we're not blocking the
other users
hopefully it is clear and now of course
let's take a look at some other patterns
we can use
so we still get the benefits so we're
not
blocking that event loop but
we also have a cleaner code where
we don't have this nested callback
mess all right and once we have covered
why it's so important to
use the asynchronous approach now of
course let's clean up
our f a a sync so instead of using these
nested callbacks
let's see a nicer pattern and as i say
note if you want to see the code
that we wrote in a previous video and
the one we are about to write
then the files are located in two
async patterns folder so i'll close
everything for now
and then back in app.js i can remove it
like i said if you want to access that
code
it is sitting in the two async patterns
folder
and we'll simply start by recreating the
read file setup where i'm gonna go with
const and
i'm right away accessing that from the
file system module
and i'll set it equal to require of
course and then
file system all right that's awesome we
know that
it is asynchronous so we need to set it
up with
three parameters we go with read file
and then we would want to pass in path
first
so again since i'm in app.js i'm going
to be looking for the content
and then forward slash and then first
txt
the file we already created before then
we have encoding so comma
and then again we're going to go with
utf-8 and then last one is going to be
that callback
where the first value is the error
and then the second one is the data that
we're getting back
okay awesome so once the
file system responds then of course we
invoke this callback
and inside of that callback we have our
logic
so if there's going to be an error for
time being
i will just return like so
and then if i have the data i'll set it
up as
else so say here console log and
data of course and we shouldn't be
surprised
if we've seen a console hello this is a
first text file because we already
covered
the setup right so we're passing the
path we pass in the
encoding and then we set up the callback
now the problem starts if we would want
to perform
multiple actions if i want to read two
files and then for example
write one correct so what would be a
better solution
well a better solution would be turning
this
into a promise and then eventually we'll
set up
async await now please keep in mind that
the only reason why i will type
out the promise stuff is because i would
want you to
understand what is happening behind the
scenes but don't worry throughout the
course
we'll just stick with a sync and a
weight syntax
and essentially you won't have to worry
about what is happening behind the
scenes but
the first example yes i want you to
understand everything
in detail so what we could do is create
a new function
and we can just say const and then i'll
call this
get text now this get text will take a
path
since i want to read two files and then
eventually
write one as well just like we did here
and of course the goal here is to
showcase
how we can make the code in the file fs
async at least that's how i called my
file
much cleaner and more readable so again
we pass
in the path and then what i would want
to return
from this function is a promise so we go
with
return new promise and then
in the promise object we need to pass in
is another callback function so we pass
in the callback function
and in here we pass in two more
functions one for resolve
and then one for reject and then once i
have set up both of these parameters
now of course what i would want is to
move
the read file and place it
inside of the promised one okay
so once we place it here first of all
notice here how i'm passing in the path
so of course i can change this one
around so i can say path
and then the encoding stays the same as
well as the callback however inside of
the callback
once i have access to resolve and reject
what i could simply say that if there is
an error i
will spit back the error so say reject
an error and if everything goes great
now of course let's go with
resolve and then we'll pass in the data
and once we have this setup what's
really cool that
now i can invoke get text and this is
going to return a promise
and then of course we can chain that
then and
catch so below the get text i can go
with get text
and of course we're looking for the path
so we still would need to use dot
and then forward slash and then content
of course and
first txt so that's the path
and then like i said we are returning a
promise
so we can chain that then and of course
here i can have the result
and i'll just cancel log it for now or
result and then i can also chain that
catch
and here i'm passing in the error so
again we can't
log it and we simply would want to see
the error
i save it and beautiful again in a
console i have
hello this is first text file so i know
that it worked
and also if i change the path so if i
make my path incorrect
we should see in the console the error
where of course node cannot find file so
if that works
now of course we can take a look at how
we can make it even cleaner
by setting up async 08 and once we have
our initial setup
once we have turned this into a promise
technically we're not out of the woods
because if i would want to perform again
two file reads and then eventually write
the file as well and if i would want to
do
all of that asynchronously it's still
going to be paying
just by using the promises so what would
be a solution
well since we're returning a promise if
i use
async await i can wait till
promise is settled and then decide what
i would want to do
and the way we set that one up is by
creating a new function
now please keep one thing in mind where
eventually throughout the course those
functions that i'm about to set up
are going to be provided to us so we'll
just attach that async
to the callback functions that already
provided us
by the libraries okay but in this
example
i'll have to create one from the scratch
and again the whole point here is
because i would want to create a
function
a start function that i'm going to set
up as a synchronous function
and i would want to attach a weight so i
would only respond
once the promise is settled so in here i
go
const start and that's my function but
i need to set it up right away as async
because i would want to use
my await keyword correct and then we
simply go with const
and i know that of course i'm looking
for the first file
and i'll just say first and that one is
equal to
get text and basically i want to pass in
the same thing
here now i do need to place this one in
quotation marks
so my bad i messed it up a little bit
okay i passed it in
and that should do it now of course what
i'm missing here
is a weight so i had this await and now
only once the promise is resolved then
i'll get
my response so what i could do here
is just comment these two or you know
what
this one i cannot comment out yet don't
worry we will eventually
this one i can comment out and then
maybe move this below
okay so you don't think that i'm running
this code and
since i have my function now of course i
would need to invoke it
so invoke start and check it out
now of course i don't have the error
which is a good sign i guess
and then we'll simply go with log and
none first
and notice the difference where
previously when we were setting up the
callbacks we had to nest everything
now i'm waiting for this promise to be
resolved and only once
it's resolved then of course i can do
something with the value
now every time we have this async await
approach
what we would want is to wrap this e in
the try catch block
so if something goes wrong then we have
at least a little bit of control over it
so i'll
set up try catch block and then i'll set
up my first
await and eventually we'll add here more
and then in the error i'll simply go
with console.log
and we'll console log the error and
let's just save that one
so now we have nice try and catch block
and by the way
sorry i deleted it we'll still take a
look at the first one and then
if we change the path then of course
we'll get an error
okay so that's good now i have my start
function
it is the synchronous i'm waiting for
the promises to resolve they're
all wrapped in try catch block so what's
next
well if you remember in here what were
the actions
that we were doing well we read two
files
correct and then we wrote one okay so
let's try that one with this new
approach
where essentially i have first so just
copy and paste
and then i'll look for the second file
remember
we should have that in the content so
this is going to be the second one
second over here and then i would want
to write the file
now of course you could say well the
problem here is going to be that
i'll have to write a new
wrapping function to set it up as a
promise because
yes we can of course read the file but
functionality
for the write file again we would need
to wrap it don't worry
there's a way how we can get this
actually out of the node
first i just want to showcase how much
cleaner this
already is where i can just wait for
first
second like so and now notice in the
console hello this is the first text
and hello this is the second file again
i fully understand that you're looking
at this wrapper function and you're like
well this definitely doesn't look that
much cleaner than this one
don't worry there's a way for us to get
those functions
in a way that they're already returning
a
promise what i would want you to focus
on is
this code what i would want you to
understand that this
definitely is much cleaner than what we
have here
we read the file and then we set up
another nested callback
and another nested callback and
hopefully you get the gist
waiting for these promises to resolve is
definitely a
cleaner and more readable approach
all right so this works we have our
start function
it is asynchronous we're waiting for
prompts to resolve and we can see that
it is already much cleaner how we can
set up this code
without the wrapping function well
what's really cool that
in node there is a module by the name
of util and we just go here const
and we'll assign it to a variable and
we'll just be looking for
require of course since we would want to
import the module
and again the name is util
and then instead of this module we have
a method by the name of
promisify and with the use of this
function
we can take our read file which of
course was looking for the callback
and turn it into the function that
returns a promise
and again this is over simplified
version what is happening there but
hopefully you understand that as a
result we'll get again
this promise back now the way we'll set
that up
of course we have read file here already
so i cannot use the same name
that's why i'll go with read file and
we'll call this
promise and that one is equal to util
that is of course my module dot and then
notice the function
promisify and then we pass in that
read file function so now i have my
promise one
so now what i could do is first of all
comment this out
and move it down again so it stays for
your reference
but it doesn't compromise my view
and of course now i have the error
because
well get text is not defined that's fine
don't worry
and i'll copy and paste and since i also
want to write a new file i will get from
the file system one
the right file function and then i'll do
the same thing
where in this case it's going to be
called write file promise
and then we pass in write file and of
course
now instead of calling get text
what i'm gonna do is go with right file
or i'm sorry in this case we're going
for read file promise
and then keep in mind one thing where
this is not
a get text one so we're still looking
for the path
as well as the encoding that's well copy
and paste
and then second argument we pass in is
the
encoding and again our functionality
shouldn't change
where i should see in console the
results from the first
txt now of course i want to do the same
thing
with the second one so have read file
promise second txt
again we have to pass in the encoding
otherwise
we'll get the buffer back so copy this
and paste and again if we cancel log it
there it is we have
hello this is first text file and this
is the second one
and since in the line 4 we passed in
write file into promisify of course
what we could also do is right away
write the file
so i can go with await and i'm simply
not assigning this to a variable
because well i'm getting back on the
finder
as far as data and i'm just going to go
with await
write file promise and the same spiel
we pass in first the path and in this
case of course if the file is not there
node will create one and the name will
be
result and i'll just call this mine
grenade and then txt and then the second
one is data
so for that one i'll set up my template
string and i'll just say this
is awesome awesome
and then let's set up the colon and then
we'll access both
first as well as the second one so we'll
interpolate both of them second
and then once we save if we take a look
at the content
there it is now we have the mind grenade
one
correct now there's probably one where i
was testing yep
there's one where i was testing so i'll
remove this one but if i take a look at
dtxd1
then of course i'll have this is awesome
hello
this is first text file and then i have
the second one
now what's even more cool that
technically we can even skip
this part as well again i'll leave this
one for your reference
but if you go to require
and then you require of course file
system module
but if you add dot promises what do you
think is going to return
well effectively the same thing so now
of course i just need to change the name
from read file promise and write file
promise back to read file
and write file since those are the two
functions
that i'm importing and that will right
away return
promises and again we save and remember
that by default we're just overwriting
stuff so
if i were to go and add a third argument
my options one
and if i'm just going to say flag and
i'll set it equal
to upend once we save well now we have
this is awesome repeat it one more time
again just to showcase
that our functionality still works
i fully understand that there was a
little detour
where we created our own wrapper
function
and then we covered how we would consume
promises but hopefully this helps you
understand that
this approach is definitely way better
so
it is more readable it is more easier to
wrap your head around and that's why for
the remainder of the course
we'll stick with this one again some
things will be provided
to us by default so libraries will
provide the functions that return
promises will right away have the
callback functions
that we'll just set up as async and
hopefully you get the gist
so a lot of things will be given to us
but the core
functionality won't change where instead
of using callbacks
and nesting them inside of the other
callbacks and
nesting more and more and more we'll set
up
everything with async await because
the syntax is cleaner and
way easier to read excellent once we
have covered async patterns we're going
to use
throughout the course now let's talk
about events in node.js
when working on browser javascript apps
a
big part of our work is to handle
events for example user clicks a button
and of course in our program we handle
that
user hovers over the link and again same
deal
in our program we are handling that and
hopefully you get the gist
essentially as our program executes
at least in part it is controlled by
events
of course depending on a program but
it's safe to say that in browser app
those events are mostly external
now that style of programming is
actually called event driven programming
and effectively it's just that a style
in which the flow of the program
is at least in part determined by the
events
that occur as the program executes
now it's easier to imagine that of
course
when you have a gui right the graphical
interface
just like the button and links example i
just mentioned
but what about server side is it also
possible
and of course the answer is yes in fact
event driven programming is used heavily
in node.js and in the following videos
we'll see some of the examples
of it and basically the idea is
following we listen for specific events
and register functions that will execute
in response to those events so once
our event takes place callback function
fires just like
in our imaginary button example now
before we continue let me stress
something
our first examples are going to be basic
and even
somewhat silly but don't let that fool
you
many built-in modules in node.js do use
events under the hood
and therefore making events and event
driven programming
a big part of nodejs
all right and once we have covered
general concepts behind events
as well as event-driven programming now
let's set up
our own events in node and the way we do
that
we come up with a variable and typically
this name
is event emitter because what we're
getting back
is the class and we require
the events module so require events
module
and we assign it to a variable which
essentially is a class
and again a common practice is calling
this
event emitter and at this point you have
two options if you want to create
something custom
you'll need to extend the class
or if you simply want to emit an event
as well as listen for it then you can
just create the instance so go with the
second route
we'll go with const and then whatever
name you would want in my case i'm just
going to call this
custom emitter like so and i'll assign
it to
new emitter so event emitter
or however you call this variable and we
just need to invoke it
so now we have the instance of our class
so essentially we have the object now
there are many methods in
this object however two that we're
interested the most
are on and emit so
on we'll listen for specific amend and
then emit
of course will emit that event
and the way we set it up we go with
custom mirror
or whatever name you used and then we go
with on
and at the very basic setup in the on
method we just pass
in the string where we say the name of
the event
now in my case i'll name my one response
and then of course once i have
subscribed to it i also would want to
pass in the callback function
so essentially when this event takes
place
well then i would want to do something
and in my case i'll just go with
console.log
and we'll simply say data received or
i'll place this one
in the template strings and you'll see
in a second why so we'll go with
data received and then eventually
there's going to be some more data
and of course once we have subscribed to
this specific event
now i would want to admit it and the way
we do that
we just go with custom emitter and of
course
the method is surprise surprise emit
and of course at this point these
strings need to match
so if i'm emitting the response event
and just say here response and what
you'll see in the console
is wherever you have in callback so of
course in my case
i have console log data received and
then once i run it i have
data received in console so that's the
most basic
setup when it comes to events again
we create an instance from the class
that we get back from the
events module and then we have two
methods
we have on method as well as the emit
method
and then in the on method we pass in the
string so that's going to be the name of
the event
as well as the callback function so once
this
event takes place then of course we
would want to do something
and in our case we'll just console.log
data received
and then once we have subscribed to this
event
then of course we need to emit it and
the way we do that we just go with
whatever the name is in my case custom
emitter
then emit method and then we pass in the
same string
that we're listening for in our case of
course response
and then the moment we do that we of
course have whatever
is in the callback function which in of
course of course is just a simple log
data received all right and once we have
covered the basic setup
now let me show you some things that
i would want you to be aware of first we
can have
as many methods we would want so for
example we have the same event
we have here response correct and we are
omitting it
so nothing stops me here just copy and
paste
and listen for the same event which of
course in our case is this response
and then do some other logic in my
callback
again in my case it's just going to be
simple
different kinds of log so i'm going to
say some other
logic here and i'm not going to copy and
paste
the same function 20 000 times just to
prove my
point but hopefully understand that yes
we can emit our event and then yes also
we can have
as many functions we would want here
that our listening for that event
and do some other logic so that's point
number one
point number two that i would like to
make is the fact that
this order matters so
we first listen for event and then
we emit it so for example if i will
place
my emit above the second function
or above both of the functions which
you'll notice
that i have nothing in a console why
well because i first
emit the event and only then i listen
for it
as you can see that doesn't make sense
so first we would want to listen for the
event
and only then we would admit it so in
this case notice
i don't have this some other logic goes
in here
because i listen for response and then i
right away
admit the response and then again i
listen for the response
but i already admitted the event correct
so it doesn't make sense to listen for
the event once it has been
already emitted so that's the point
number two
and then thirdly our also on a showcase
that we can pass
the arguments when we're omitting the
event
so for example i go here with my emit i
pass in the name which is of course
response
and then i can pass in more arguments
for example here i'll go
john and then the id number 34.
so string and a number and then in my
callback function
i can access those arguments as
parameters
just like normal functions so in this
case i'll call them
name and id and simply in my console.log
i'll say name and the second one will be
with id and then whatever is that id
now i'll add here data received user
and then save it and it's no surprise
that in the console i see data received
user john
with id34 now in the second function as
you can see
i wasn't looking for those arguments i
just don't have access to the arguments
because i don't have the parameters
but it's not like everything broke just
because
in the event i passed in the arguments
and lastly i would just want to
reiterate the point that even though
you might not write your own events
events are a core building block of node
and effectively as you're building and
writing out the code for your node
application
you are using those events at the end of
the day anyway because
a lot of built-in modules rely on them
and as a quick side note if you'd like
to see the code
that we wrote in previous two lectures
you can just navigate to 13 event
emitter
and in order to show that i'll quickly
set up a
server and again the code for this one
you can find
at 14 and then request event
so copy all the contents from the file
and then
just copy and paste and notice something
interesting
where again yes we're getting the http
module and
remember the setup that we have used so
far where we go with http
create server and then we pass in this
callback function
and then of course this callback
function will be invoked every time
someone visits our server so
every time the request comes in
now there's another way how we can set
it up by using
event emitter api so we still create a
server
we go with http and then create
server function but instead of passing
in the callback function
like we did previously server has the
method
on does that ring a bell remember our
previous example
we had our own instance and it had the
method of on correct so the same goes
for server
so server has the method on and we
listen for
request event and when that request
comes in
then of course again we have this
callback function that handles it
so behind the scenes server emits
the request event and then of course we
can listen for it
we can subscribe to it listen for it or
respond to it however you'd want to call
it
and the way we do that we go with server
on and then
this is a specific name because of
course it
emits that specific name behind the
scene so make sure that
it is a request and then the same spiel
now how do i know that well if we go to
node documentation
and if we look for http we keep on
scrolling keep on scrolling
eventually we'll hit the server and
over here i can see that it has a clash
okay that's a good start
and that what do you see here well i see
the event
right and what is the event well the
name is
request so that's how i know that my
server
the instance that i create has the
ability to listen
for request events and if you want to
dig deeper
you can just click on a server you
notice that
it extends the net server and
if we keep on digging check it out so
this one
extends what it extends the event
emitter so hopefully that makes it clear
that even though you might not be
setting up events on your own
a bunch of built-in modules rely heavily
on this concept of events all right and
up next we have streams
in node.js and at its simplest
streams are used to read or write
sequentially
basically when we have to handle and
manipulate
streaming data for example continuous
source
or a big file streams come in real handy
and now there are four different types
of streams we have
writable used to write data sequentially
then we have readable
used to read data sequentially duplex
used to
both read and write data sequentially
and also transform where data can be
modified
when writing or reading just like with
events
many built-in modules in node implement
streaming interface
and what's also interesting streams
extend event emitters class
which simply means that we can use
events like data
and and on streams since streams
are somewhat off an advanced topic in
node
i'll try to keep it short and sweet
mostly by showing you examples of
streams
and hopefully that way you get the main
idea
without being overwhelmed all right and
once we know the theory behind the
streams
now let's take a look at the practical
example and a very good use case
is using streams when we are reading
files
because we need to understand one thing
where
when we use the sync or asynchronous
approach
what happens we're reading the whole
file and of course
in our example we were setting this
equal to
a variable correct but if we have
a big file well first of all
you're just using all that memory and
second
as the file size gets bigger and bigger
bigger eventually
the variable is not going to be good
enough you will get an error
that i mean the size is too big and you
cannot place
everything in the string so
what would be a solution one solution
would be read
stream option and the way we'll set this
up
i'm going to start app.js from scratch
but if you take a look at the
repo you'll notice this 15 create big
file
so previously when we were working with
files i just had
some small files right so i had the
first txt
blah blah blah result and whatever now
before we set up the read stream
i would want to create a big file again
this is optional
you don't have to do that but in my case
in order to show you how the streams
work
yes i'll have to set up a big file and
first i'll remove it because of course
i already have it since i was testing it
and now i'll stop my server
and of course in my case i'll run 15 the
create
big file js if you want to set it on
your own
and if you don't want to use the repo
you can just get the
right file sync from the fs module and
then notice
i have the loop where i believe i have
here
10 000 and then every iteration
i just write a big txt i of course
i have the flag upend and then i'm just
adding hello world
and starting a new line so if i'll run
node and then of course i'm going to go
with my file name which is 15
then hyphen create big
file and js like so
then in the content i should have this
big file
and once i have my big file i'll go back
to app.js
and i'll use my npm start since of
course i have known mine in place
and then let's go with cons now i'm not
going to show you
how the setup would look like with file
sync
or the asynchronous one again hopefully
you understand that
the setup would be exactly the same like
we have in 10
and 11 where we had the fa sync and
fa async and now of course let's just go
with
the stream option so the method name is
create
read stream and we require
that from the fs module like so
and then we create a new variable
and in my case i'll call this stream and
we invoke
the create read stream and the only
thing
by default we need to pass in is the
path so of course in my case i'm going
to go with content and then forward
slash
and since i just created that text file
the big one
of course i'm going to go with big txt
and now remember the good old friends
events well once we create this instance
we actually have access to them and the
ones that we're going to use
is going to be data and error
so we can go with stream and then on
and remember the event syntax and then
the
event that you would want to listen for
is a data
and then we have our callback function
and again
it is a parameter so we can call
whatever we would want but in my case
i'm going to go
result and let's just console.log the
result like so and what you'll notice
is that we have 64 kilobytes here
that's our first console log then we
have another one
464 kilobytes and the reason why i know
that
is because by default that's the size
we're getting
and then we're getting the reminder now
just to prove my point
i'm going to go to my folder and i'm
going to look
for my content and then
in there if you take a look the big text
file we created
is 169 kilobytes so as you can see
now we're reading data in chunks
and by default that chunk is 64
kilobytes and every time we cancel
log we see that we have 64 64
and eventually we have the remainder so
instead of
reading everything and placing that in
the variable
we're doing that in chunks and as you
can see
we're using the event and the event is
data
and in order to hammer this home why
don't we take a look at the docs
so first i'm going to look for my file
system
and then let's look for our create
read stream so we go here as we can see
we have this class read stream
and then on this class we have these
three ones we have close
open and ready and as a side note we'll
use this one a little bit later
as well the open one so keep an eye on
this one
and then as far as the read stream well
as you can see
it is created when we go with create
read
stream and invoke it right so i got the
create
read stream that's my function i just
passed in the past
and i invoked it and in turn
that returns the read stream
right then actual read stream extends
from stream.readable so right away i
have these events i have close open and
ready and like i said
we use this open a little bit later now
since
it is extending from the stream check it
out
now of course i have the data one all
right so this is a chunk of data
and as you can see every time we are
getting that data
we can do something with it now at the
moment we're just going to logging
it's very simple but eventually as you
can already imagine
we can do way more useful things
than that beautiful once we understand
the basics
now let's take a look at some additional
info
like i said by default the size of the
buffer
is going to be 64 kilobytes however
we can also control it and the way we do
that
is by passing in the object
when we're setting up create read stream
so first
argument is going to be the path which
again in my case is going to be that
big text file that i created using my
file
using my for loop and then i can pass
in the options object and in there the
property that you're looking for the
property that controls
the size of the buffer has the name of
high
water mark so for example if i go with
90 000 here then of course you'll see
that i'll have
two console logs one for 90 kilobytes
and the second one will be remainder
again keep in mind that
our file size is 169 kilobytes
that's number one number two we can
right away set up the encoding as well
so i go with comma and then the property
name is encoding
and again we'll set it up equal to utf-8
like so and then you'll see in a console
of course the hello world why
well because that is the content coming
from the file
and lastly i also would want to mention
that we have the
error event as well so if i go with
stream and then on and we're checking
for the error
and as always we can do something once
that error happens
so that's our callback function and in
this case i'll just
access the error property and i'll
console.log the error
so i'll say here error and the way we
check that one out
is by providing wrong path so in my case
i'm just going to add
two dots and then once i save check it
out
in a console i'll have the error where
it tells me
that no such file or directory
all right and now let's take a look at
the practical example
when streams come in handy now again
this is going to be one of those videos
where you don't have to code along you
can just sit back
and relax and see how i struggle
and first what i want is to make it even
a bigger file so remember d15 create big
file
i believe i had 10 iterations right so
i'm gonna add one more meaning i'll add
one more zero
i'll stop my server right now again this
is optional you don't have to do that
and i'll remove the big file like so
and then i'll run one more time the file
with node
and then of course this file is going to
be way bigger
so let me navigate to my folder just to
showcase that
and i'm looking for content and now the
big file is
1.8 megs now once i have the big
file i'll go with npm
start at the moment i just have the
stream example
but if you want to see the whole code
just take a look at the
file number 17 and notice again we're
creating a http server
and i'm just using the read file stick
method i'm looking for big txt
the encoding is utf-8 and then i just
place
my variable my text one into
res dot and method and effectively
i'm just sending my big text file
and let me restart the server
here so let me go with npm start
right now so let me select everything
from this file
and copy and paste
and now if we navigate to localhost
5000 we should see a bunch of hello
world
now the problem with the setup is
following where if i go to developer
tools
and if i take a look at the network and
if i refresh
yep this request was successful
take a look at the size do you think it
is the smartest thing to send
these type of files over the wire
and of course this is just going to make
it very difficult
to all your users because you're just
sending
large chunks of data effectively i'm
sending the whole file
and more specifically if i click check
it out
so i have the request url okay that is
good the method is get
now as you can see the content length
is my 1.8 megs right
and you'll see in a second that once we
refactor this
to read stream method that we're sending
data
in the chunks and again the best way to
see that
is by looking at the headers where at
the moment i can see the
content length and that one is at 1.8
megs but once we refactor that the setup
is going to be different so at the
moment i have this text
i'm accessing that by read file sync so
comment this out
and let's set it up with our create read
stream
so i'll go with const and i'll call this
file
stream and this is going to be equal to
fs and then
create read stream now use the same
address
so use the same path and then i'll use
the same encoding as well
so let's go with utf-8 okay
awesome and once we set up the stream
remember we have access to
to events file stream on
and of course i'm going to be looking
for the open
and i'll have my callback function and
we'll set that functionality up
in a second and the second one of course
is the error
so go with file stream and then on
and again we're looking for the event by
the name of error
and then in our callback function we can
access the error
and i'll simply pass it in in my
response so if there is an error
i'll just grab the error from my
parameter
and pass it in now as far as the open
here instead of setting it equal to
instead of going
res dot end and then text file stream
also have the pipe method so we can go
to file stream
and then pipe and what the pipe is doing
it is pushing from the read stream into
right stream
so you can imagine that if we can read
data in chunks
we can also write data in chunks
and what happens under the herd response
object
can be set up as a writable stream so we
have our file stream
so that's our read stream we have method
of pipe
so we're piping this into a writable
stream
and now of course i'll pass in my
response object
and if we go back to the browser and if
we'll refresh
now notice something interesting yeah
still same request
right to localhost 5000 still same size
but if i take a look at the
headers now i can see that my response
headers
are chunked so instead of sending our
file back in one large instance
we're sending it back in chunks awesome
congrats on completing section number
three
node fundamentals and hopefully after
watching the section you have a good
general understanding of how node works
and now that we're big shots let's apply
that knowledge and
build some servers shall we and we're
going to start
section 4 with the general info of how
the web works
more specifically how we exchange data
on the web
and we're going to do that with the help
of few slides
now if you're one of the people who's
already reached a daily slide limit
i hear you once we're done with these
suckers i promise we'll mostly actually
write
code for the remainder of the course
i do believe though that before we build
an actual
web server it's crucial for us to
understand how it works
under the hood and that way we'll have
clear understanding of
what tasks need to be done if something
is iffy
you can always go back to the slides you
already know where they're located
and also as we're going to be
progressing with the course
from time to time i will swing back to
them when i'll need to emphasize
a specific point with that said let's
talk about how we exchange
data on the web um
it's safe to say that if you're watching
this video you know
how to use a web browser but under the
hood
the way it works every time we open up a
browser
and we type the url so the web address
we're actually performing a request
and we are performing a request to the
server
that is responsible serving those
resources
so for example when you look for cnn.com
you're looking for a server that has
those resources
and then that server sends you back the
response and the same works with youtube
the same works with johnsmeld.com
or whatever so you just pick a resource
you say hey
can i get this data and then server who
is responsible
for those resources just sends you back
the
response now that is done using http
protocol and that's why these ones are
called http messages
so the user sends the http request
message and then the server sends the
http
response message and that's how we
exchange
data on web and for the remainder of the
course
we'll be responsible for building
such web server using node
and more specifically express now i'll
talk about it
while we use express as well show you a
few examples
later on in a course but for now just
remember
that yes we'll use node but in order to
make our lives easier
we'll use the framework by the name of
express
js and lastly i would just want to
mention that even though
name server definitely sounds way cooler
than the computer at the end of the day
they're just
computers whose job is to
always make that resource available
so yes those are computers and yes there
are some differences for example
they most likely don't have the
graphical interface
or the gui and also they're probably
much bigger than your laptop
but at the end of the day they are
computers
whose job is to always
make sure that that resource is
available because imagine
if you would have a server that only
works from eight to five so if you go
to your website at i don't know six
o'clock at night
you cannot access the resource probably
that's not the service
that you would pick so next time when
someone asks you
if it rains does the cloud still work
you know what to answer
because at the end of the day when we
talk about cloud
cloud is just a bunch of these servers
bunch of these computers
connected together beautiful and once we
have a general understanding how
data is exchanged on a web let's also
cover how http messages
are structured please keep in mind that
since it's going to be
a big part of our job we'll come back to
this particular slide
more than once so if you're if you're
about something just please be patient
and i'll answer all of your questions as
we move along with the course
with that said the general structure for
both messages
is similar they both have a start line
they both have optional headers a blank
line that indicates that
all the meta info has been sent and
effectively headers are that meta info
as well as optional body and before we
continue again let me stress something
so request messages are
what the user is sending so for example
if you open up the browser
to search the web or that could be
your web application because remember
with web applications we also can
make http requests correct and then
response is going to be our
responsibility
so we'll have to set up a proper server
that sends a correct response
and in general when we talk about the
request
message in start line there's going to
be
a method then the url as well as the
http version now we are mostly going to
be interested
in these two things in the method as
well as the url
now there's going to be a separate slide
about the methods
as well and don't worry we'll cover that
in a greater detail
once we cover them with actual code
examples so
i'll come back to that slide just
understand the general idea that
when we talk about methods effectively
we're communicating
what we would want to do so for example
if
i want to get the resource i'm going to
set it up
as a get request now if i want to add
the resource then of course this is
going to be a post request
and then of course you can read the rest
now
why i'm displaying here this get because
that is the default request
that the browser performs since when we
open up the browser
we want to get some kind of resource
correct
that's why we're performing a get
request and the url
is just the address and that could be
for example johnsmilk.com
or that could be i don't know espn
forward slash
basketball both of them are just a web
addresses
now headers is essentially optional
where this is a meta information about
our request
and just to give you a general idea how
the headers would look like
they would look something like this so
it is a key value pairs
now don't freak out as you know when you
search the web
you don't need to add them manually and
the same
is going to be with our server a lot of
it
is going to be taken care of but yes
some things we'll have to add
on our own basically this is going to be
information
about our message and then
we also have optional body so when the
user is requesting something
if you just want the resource there is
nobody
there's nothing basically what to send
however if we would want to
add a resource onto the server yes
then you are expected to provide that
data
and it's also called payload so again
i might use them interchangeably so
that's the general structure
of the request message we have the start
line we have the headers
that is the information about our
message
as well as the black line which just
indicates that we're done with the meta
information
and optional body which we'll use from
time to time
and now of course we need to talk about
the response message
so response message is what we're going
to be creating
again most of it will be done for us but
some parts yes we'll have to do it
manually
and it's going to be our responsibility
so the start line
has the http version which most likely
is going to be 1.1
then we have a status code and status
text now when it comes to status code
it just signals what is the result of
the request so for example notice here
this 200
that means that request was successful
so that's what we're sending back and
yes
there's quite a few of those codes and
as we move along with the course of
course
we will cover them but please please
please don't rush
over to the search engine and start
memorizing the status codes pretty much
as we're going to be building the
application
i'll tell you which code means what and
for example 400
means that there was some kind of
request error
so the user was trying to request some
kind of research and with 400
there was a request error now for
example the code 404
means that the resource is not found so
when i'm sending back the message
i'm like hey listen here's the status
code for the message
if you are successful here's 200 if
there was an error for example
you get a 400 if the
request is unauthorized then you can get
401
and hopefully you get the gist and yes
of course
as we're progressing we will cover more
status code then again we have the
headers
where basically we provide info
about our message our response message
and again like i said you won't have to
type
everything line by line but effectively
it is
a setup of key value pairs
and the ones that i would like to
mention are these ones notice this
content type
we have text html that is when we're
sending back
the html but also our second
option is going to be sending back the
data
so hopefully you are aware that when
you're building a web application when
we communicate with
api most of the time we're getting back
the json data
because over the web effectively we just
send
over the string so if for example i have
some kind of array
we transfer this into application json
and i clearly indicate that in my
headers where i say that no
i'm not sending text and html i'm
actually sending a application json and
then that application who is requesting
the web application knows that hey from
the server i'm getting a content type
which is
application json so for example in that
case
i could send back here this array with
bunch of these objects and just to give
you
a real-world taste why don't we do this
open up a new browser tab and i'm simply
going to course api because
i think there's going to be less data so
there's going to be less clutter
so go to course api here
and then you can either pick the slides
or you can just look at the home page
and if you inspect and if you look in
the browser tab you'll find a network
and very useful one is this one where we
can just look for
all the requests we refresh and then
check it out
so these are the requests that browser
performed and i'll talk about it
a bit later why there's also this style
css
in fact that's going to be one of our
first examples but take a look at this
one
so i have this course api and then
forward slash and if you remember when
we were building our original server
what i said that if we have this forward
slash that just means home page
so if we're just navigating to
courseapi.com
and that is our homepage we simply add
this forward slash now of course in the
browser that's
automatically added but that's why when
we're setting up the server
one of the cases is going to be if the
user navigates to the homepage
then we simply look for forward slash so
if for example you go to the slides
you'll notice that uh in this case i
would have to refresh
notice here i have the course api
forward slash slides so that is already
a page in my
website correct so i have the home page
course api and then i have the slides
page
where i have the slides and if you take
a look
if you click on it notice all the
useful data that we get over here so for
example
this is going to be our request url
which is going to be again course
api.com
so that tells me well what the browser
is trying to get
then check it out the method why it's
get because that is default
in the browsers every time you open up
the browser and search something
then of course you'll be performing a
get request now check out this one
the status code it is 200 why because
everything is successful
because servers send back the data then
we have this remote address
and basically that is the ip address for
my server
as well as notice this colon 443
and we'll come back to this one when we
set up our own server because if you
remember we were always setting up the
5000
so you're probably wondering well what
is this 443 and don't worry
again we'll cover that one once we set
up our first
server and then again we have
response headers for example and we also
have the request adders
so as you can see using this network tab
we can actually find
a bunch of useful information now
notice here in the second set of tabs
i can see this response and preview
so if you take a look at the preview
this is going to be basically my site
and also i can see the response so as
you can see
pretty much sending back the html so i'm
sending back the website
so you go into the browser you request a
resource
by default it is a get request and then
in that body when the server sends it
back
this is what we get back so we get back
the site
so hopefully this gives you a clear
understanding
of how the http messages
are structured and now let's dive into
creating our own server awesome once
we're done with the slides
now let's start setting up our server
and in order to follow along with the
course
you'll need to have a starter project
and you can get it if you navigate to my
site
again the url is johnsmilk.com
so navigate there in the project or in
home page
look for node express tutorial project
in a home page is going to be at the
bottom in latest project
if you cannot find it there then look
for all projects page or
simply projects page then filter for
node in order to save some time and then
like i already previously mentioned any
of these links will get you
to the repo and then bravely get the
repo in my case i'm going to clone it
so i'll copy the url i'll bump up the
sound size
in my terminal navigate to the desktop
get clone here and then
i'm gonna get the repo and then once the
project
is on my machine i'm just gonna drag and
drop
and then the first thing that i would
suggest
doing is removing the remote
url and you can simply do that by just
wiping out
the git folder so that way if you ever
do decide
you push this up to the github you won't
have some dumb permission errors
so i'm just going to open up the
integrated terminal now in my case
i'm not going to run the command but if
you're on mac i suggest running
rm then hyphen rf and then
get now if you are on windows
some students have just these two
commands now i haven't tested them yet
but
some people have replied to my tweet
that yes they do work and if you want to
see the whole tweet
just navigate to my twitter the handle
is john
underscore smilga and then as you can
see here is the mac command
and for windows i have these two so
run this command and then in next video
i'll give you a brief
overview of the repo all right
and before we get busy why don't i give
you
a brief overview of the ripple
and if you take a look at the first
project
this should look very very familiar
because essentially
this is all the code we have written so
far
everything starting with our most basic
application
and then of course we also have our last
one our http
streams example so hopefully that is
clear and if you ever
need to jog your memory essentially this
is just here for your reference
and then from now on we'll work in a
folder number two
by the name of express tutorial and the
idea is gonna be
exactly the same where basically we
build a bunch of examples and in the
process we learned what is express
and why we would prefer using express
instead of straight up http module but
again let me stress something
where express is built on top of node
and more specifically
on top of http module so it's not like
you can use express without node and in
folder two
the setup is following where there are
gonna be some assets
that i provided just so we can make
more real world examples so hopefully
that gives you a better idea
how the express works and i'm not going
to cover them right now for example
methods public or navbar app
once we get there i'll explain
everything that's happening
i think that it's going to be waste of
our time if i do that right now
however if you take a look at the final
folder you'll basically see all our
examples
so the same spiel if you ever
need to reference the code just navigate
to the final
look for the file name and then of
course you'll find the code just keep in
mind that in order to
run this code you'll have to copy and
paste
and run it in the app.js why
because in some cases there's going to
be paths and since
these files are located already in the
final
the paths won't match okay hopefully
that one is clear as well and then
we also should be familiar with these
files
as you can see i have package.json i
have package.json lock
and then app.js now of course app.js
could be renamed server
or whatever you would want but i already
have in a package.json a script
that spins up the nodemon and
effectively we have successfully
set up a node application so
package.json is of course needed because
we'll have some dependencies more
specifically
two one is going to be nodemod and the
second one is going to be express
and in order to of course keep track of
those dependencies
we have package.json and then
if you notice i don't have the node
modules here
and of course the reason for that is
because i don't want this repo to be
massive
and you can clearly see that in a git
ignore where i have
node modules included so when i was
pushing this up to the github
and of course i omitted the node modules
since i added them
in the git ignore and then in the
package json like i said
you'll find some dependencies and i'll
talk about express once we get there
the moment let's not worry about it the
one that we should be familiar with
is node one which is going to be
watching our application
and i have a script that sets up
nodemon and passes in the amp.js
so any changes in our project nodemon
will be watching
and restarting our application however
we cannot do anything before we install
all dependencies otherwise you'll just
get an error
so that's why the first thing that i
would want you to do is
navigate to the folder number two
and the fastest way probably is just
going to be cd and then
take the project number two and drag and
drop like so
and then once you can see that you are
in this folder
so not in a root not in node express
course
but once you are actually in the folder
number two
before you do anything just run npm
install first and then it's really up to
you
you can either wait for all the
dependencies to be installed and then
run npm start
or you can simply chain it and say npm
and once you run this one then of course
you'll install dependencies
and if you see in a terminal express
tutorial
that means that everything is correct
and you can continue
with the videos if you don't see that
then please troubleshoot
because none of the things that we're
about to do next are going to make sense
if you're not running the project number
two with all the dependencies
more specifically nodemon and express
and lastly i just want to mention yes
there's also this data.js
and again this is one of the assets that
i added
that we're going to use a little bit
later so if you see express tutorial in
a console
and the reason why it's there because
that's the only line of code i have in
my app.js
that means that everything is correct
and we can move on to
our next topic and why don't we start
the express tutorial part by setting up
the
server one more time with straight up
http module
and in a process let's struggle a little
bit
let's see why we would want to use
express
e in the first place so yes we'll build
one more time server with http module
however now of course we'll dive deep
into the topics that we kind of skipped
over
before and in order to set up the server
we know that we would need to
require the module right so i'm going to
come up with some kind of variable
and in my case that is going to be http
and of course the name is not required
you can call this whatever you'd want
but
it is somewhat off a convention to call
this hdp
as far as the variable name then we go
with require
and we just go with http again keep in
mind
this comes built in node so you don't
have to install it
we didn't install when we ran npm
installed in last video
we installed two other dependencies but
this one is built in so we don't have to
do anything
we just say require and it's always
going to be available to us
then we need to set up the server and
again convention is calling the server
but you can call this box bunny and in
order to do that we go with http
and then on this object we have a method
by the name of create server now
this method takes a callback which is
going to be invoked
every time the user hits
our server and in this callback we have
two parameters
and again we can call them whatever we
would want so again
common convention is just shorten this
up a little bit
and call it request and res so
rec and res and the first parameter
references
the request object and second one is the
response object
and at this point it should be clear why
we have access to those two parameters
because in the http cycle
we have request message that is coming
in
every time user requests the resource
and also we have the response message
right so that's what we need to send out
so that's why
in this function that runs every time
user
hits the server we have access to
rec and res so that way we can find
info about the incoming request because
it makes a total sense if we have access
to that info
i do want to know what is the method so
what the user is trying to do
i do want to know what resource the user
is trying to get
whether that is the contact page or
about page
and also i would want to know whether
i'm getting some data
whether user is trying to add
something onto the server and as far as
the response
well in order to serve the data
i need to be extremely specific
about what i'm sending so i need to
explain to the browser
what is coming in hopefully that is
clear and in here we can just go
with log and we'll say user hit
the server and then we return the object
from this create server and on that
object we have
a method by the name of listen so
in order for the server to work we need
to invoke listen
and we need to be a bit more specific
and we need to say well what
port are we listening for and you're
probably wondering well what's up with
this port
what's up with this 5000 value
and the best explanation i can give you
is this one
imagine scenario where you have some
kind of issue
with your bank what do you do or that
could be a phone company it doesn't
really matter but
i'm just going to give you a bank
example what do you do
you call the customer service and what
is the first question that they ask you
they say please describe your issue
so we may better assist with your call
and what do they do they give you
options right so they say
if you want to increase your credit
limit this is going to be option number
one all the way to
canceling the account which maybe is
going to be option
number eight so they don't just randomly
assist you a person
they say hey what is the issue and this
is the person that can serve you the
best
so if you press 8 you can assume that
you're probably going to be speaking
with someone who deals with that
all the time and same goes here
so if you go online and if you search
for port this is just going to be a
communication endpoint and we need to
understand that for http
traffic we have specific ports
so for http we actually have port 80
because there's other ports as well if
you keep on scrolling here and by the
way this is wikipedia example
we have port 20 which is for
file transfer protocol so this is going
to be for data transfer
then we have port 22 for secure shell
so http traffic is only one of the
things
that we set up on a server and
once our application is in deployment
we have specific ports for that we have
80
that is going to be for just http and we
also have 443
which is going to be 40 secure
communication that's why
when you go to course api or any other
website that uses https
you'll notice that there is a
ip address and then more specifically
443
and you can also think of this as a
apartment building
so every apartment building has the same
exact address right but the apartments
differ
so the same works here so on that server
if i want to access it
using ssh so secure shell
i'm going to use port 22
but then if for example i want to use
http protocol and if i want to access
resource that way then i'm going to use
port 443
so once your server is already in
production
yes these ports are not random there are
specific ports
for specific things we would want to do
again back to our bank example
if i want to cancel the account then i'm
always going to be directed to that
person
because i'm going to click option number
eight if i want to increase the limit
then of course i'm going to be directed
to a different person
now while we're in development this is
really arbitrary
i can go here with five thousand i can
go here with three thousand eight
thousand
wherever you would want i believe the
ports between
zero and thousand twenty four are
already taken so you shouldn't be using
them
but in local development again this is
an arbitrary number
and that's why you can use anything you
would want
and again the most common example create
react app
where we spin up the server
on localhost 3000 then gatsby has i
believe eight thousand
and then netlify cli has 8080 and i can
go on and on and on
so in my case i just went with 5000 but
if you don't like this number just use a
different port but
of course please remember the actual
value for the port
because you'll need it once you need to
access
now if you're wondering well what
happens once we deploy
our application just put the pin on that
and once we get to deployment of course
i'm going to cover
how actually we set it up that we serve
that traffic
on the port 80 for example for http
or 443 for https
and now of course we can go and test it
out so let me navigate
to my browser and i'm just going to go
with
localhost and eight thousand
and or i'm sorry i just said five
thousand and for some reason i went to
eight
which is gonna be the gatsby one and
you'll see
this interesting spinner so what's
happening over here
well the thing is yeah the user hit the
server
as you can see user hit the server that
is what i see
in the terminal however remember
we have the response right so we have
access to the response object
and now we need to send back some info
to the browser
otherwise the browser is like okay so i
hit this resource
but nothing is happening and there's a
method that we
always always need to include in
our response and the method name is and
and i right away went to node docs of
course
again if you want to navigate there
yourself please do so
but i already right away went for
response dot end
and as you can see this method signals
to the server
that all the response headers and body
have been sent
and as a side note we'll do the headers
in the next video because this one
is already getting quite long that
server should consider this message
complete
the method response and must be called
on each response so
for the browser not to be confused we
need to go
with res that end so res dot
and that is one of the methods that is
available on this
response object and here we can either
pass the text
or we can set up for example html
and in this case i'm just going to say
home page that's it i'll just pass in
the string and
if we were to go back to localhost 5000
there it is now we have our homepage
response
and we can clearly see that in our
terminal because every time you refresh
the browser
you'll have this console log in a
terminal
user hit the service hopefully
everything is clear
again we have access to http module and
that is built in node
and we just set it up some kind of
variable most common convention is
calling this http
then on there we have create server
method
that takes in the callback which is
going to be invoked every time the user
hits the server
and as parameters we have a request
and response object and common
convention
is just calling the american res now of
course you can call this stockhold
burrito if you want
but again common convention is calling
this iraq and res
and the reason why we have access to
those objects
is because in the http cycle
that's what happens we have a request
message
that is coming in where we can find a
bunch of useful info
about the request that is coming in and
then of course
we need to respond to the browser in a
meaningful manner
so that's why we also have the response
object
and in every response we should always
have
end which is going to signal that the
communication
is over and then we just need to set up
the port
and again in development we just come up
with arbitrary numbers
and in my case we go with 5000 and we
pass in that port
in the dot listen method which is
available
when we invoke create server because we
get back the object
hopefully the basics are clear and now
we can start expanding
on our knowledge all right we're done
with the basics
but there are two major issues with our
current setup
first of all we don't provide any info
about
the data that we're sending back so we
don't have
any metadata about the body
that we're sending out so we're not
providing any information
we just go rest that end and then pass
in the string
so that's issue number one and then
issue number two
if i were to go to the local host
5000 and if i type about or if i type
contact or whatever you'll see that of
course we're sending back the same
response
each and every time so if we go with
contact again
this is going to be a home page so why
don't we deal with
issue number one first where we provide
more info to the browser of what we're
actually sending back
and then in the next video we'll deal
with the
request and the way we provide more info
we just need to add more methods
now specifically one more method and
that is going to be
res dot write head and in there
you can probably already guess that
we're just providing headers
so we're providing metadata about our
response
and we go here with res dot and then we
go with
right head so right head
and then we need to provide a few things
we start with a status code
and i'll talk about the status code in a
second and for time being i'll just pass
in 200
which just means that the request was
successful
and then we pass in the headers and one
of the
most common headers is the content type
so this is where i specifically say to
the browser hey listen
i'm sending back html or i'm sending
back css so where i'm sending back the
image
so browser knows well what to do how to
render
that content and like i mentioned
already previously
this is done using key value pairs so we
go with content type so that's the name
of the header
and then we pass in text and then if for
example
i want to pass in the html i go with
text
forward slash and then html and now of
course in this case
where i have the res.end i can set up
the html so for example i could go with
heading 1
and i'll say homepage same deal
home page now if you want you can keep
it this way
where you have res that end and you
directly
pass in the html however i like
to use better this approach where i go
with res dot
write and we do the same thing we pass
in essentially the body
and i set up my html here in the right
or any content that i'm sending back and
then explicitly call
res.n again if you want you can pass
this heading 1 into the end just
make sure that you have the end and you
saw that in a docs
where it says if data is specified in a
similar effect to calling
response.write and then we pass in the
data
followed by res.n but you always
always need to call res.n so this is
really up to you
if you want you can pass this directly
into res.n
i like to write it a bit explicitly
where i say res.right so that is my body
and then i just end the communication by
calling
res.n and now of course
if i go back to the browser again i'll
still have the same issue
where it's going to be displayed for
every
request meaning either contact page
homepage or whatever
but now i provide way more useful info
to the browser
where browser knows hey i'm getting back
the html
so i'll need to render html and this
stuff matters
so let me show you if i change the
content type
back for example to plain and if i
save and if you refresh now notice this
is now treated
as a text it's not treated as html
so whatever you set up over here in the
content type
yes it does matter now express takes
care of that
so we won't have to do that but i just
want to let you know that if you will be
setting up the headers yourself
yes the stuff that you type here matters
and as the note it is also called
mime type or you can think of it as
media type so whatever we're sending
back and
now let's go over the status codes as
well as other options
for mime types and this is where i would
like to introduce
an awesome resource for anything http
related
and that is going to be no other than
the mozilla docs
so if you go to http and status codes
you'll see probably the first link is
going to be to the mdn
and as you can see http response status
codes indicate
whether specific http request has been
successfully
completed and like i mentioned before
there are quite a few groups
over here and there are quite a few
codes but i would strongly discourage
you from spending your weekend
on memorizing the codes as we're going
to be progressing with the course as
we're going to be
creating more complex applications of
course we'll introduce
more and more status codes but the main
idea is following where
when we send back the response i'm just
saying
is it successful maybe the resource
wasn't available
so then i sent back 404 or maybe there
was a bad request
that's why there's also option 400 and
hopefully you get an idea
where we are setting up that status code
so the browser knows
what is happening with the request
was it successful was there an error
maybe i don't know
you're not authorized to access it and
on and on and on
and if you keep on scrolling notice
so the 100 ones are going to be
informational responses
then for successful one we have 200
so that probably is going to be the one
that you'll use the most
so that means that request has succeeded
then we have 201 also something that
we'll use throughout the course
a lot and this one is once
the post request is successful so if you
add the resource successfully onto the
server
then you just send back to one we have
300s for
redirect and then these are the ones
that you probably don't want to get
if you are surfing the web so 400 is for
bad requests
so for example you are requesting some
kind of data or you're trying to do
something on the server
but you don't provide the info so
i don't know i'm trying to add the user
but i don't provide the username
something along those lines
then 401 is for unauthorized then 403
forbidden
and 404 not found so in our case we'll
set up
a response if the user is trying to
access the resource
that does not exist so
hopefully it is clear that is the status
code
again i wouldn't suggest memorizing it
as we are
moving along with the course of course
we'll cover more status codes
just understand the main idea where you
attach that status code
to let the browser know hey what's
happening
and it is very important that you use
the correct status codes because
we are in charge here nothing stops me
from
sending back the 404 here meaning the
resource is not found
and then when you navigate to the
contact page for example here
and if you inspect again the browser
network tab
you'll see this confusion info where 404
is technically not found right but
at the same time we are sending back the
correct resource
so yes whatever we type as far as the
status code it does matter
it's not just some random info and that
just
reflects what is happening with the
request and then lastly let's talk about
mime types same deal
just go to your favorite search engine
and just type
mime and types and again i suggest using
the mdn
and these are just going to be media
types so whatever we're sending back
there's quite a few out there now again
express takes care of that so we don't
need to worry about it
but if you ever need to set it up i
don't suggest memorizing them
the ones that you'll need to use you'll
pretty much
be able to google it right away you can
also use the npm packages
so no you don't need to go and memorize
them
again just remember the main idea where
you're sending back something right and
you need to describe to the browser well
what are you sending back
are you sending back the image are you
sending back css are you sending back
the html
and as you saw in a previous example if
you change
that mime type if you change that
content type header
yes the browser will interpret that
differently and once we successfully
have set up
more proper response now let's start
dealing
with the request object beautiful
and with our basic headers in place
now let's deal with the request object
and like i already previously mentioned
it's just a giant object and
if of course we can slog it then we'll
see it
in a terminal so i'm going to go back to
my localhost
5000 and as i said note this is getting
quite busy
so i can just remove some of the tabs
and if i just refresh the browser i
should see
in a terminal a giant object so what are
we looking for
well let's go back to our slide and
remember the start line
we had a method so that signals what the
user is trying to do
either get the resource post a resource
or whatever
and then we have the url now in order to
save us a little bit of time
i won't cover the methods with http
we'll just deal with the url but we will
cover of course methods
once we hit the express for now i'm just
going to assume
that the only thing that the users are
trying to do
they just want to get the resources from
our server so that's why we won't look
for the method just keep in mind that
yes
of course those methods are available on
this
request object there is a property by
the name of i believe
it was just simply a method so if we
cancel log
and if i refresh notice here
in a terminal it says get so
the user is performing a get request so
the user is trying
to get the resource so that's one thing
that we could take a look at
and the other one is actually the url
so let me uncomment this one and i'm
looking for the
url property and again i refresh and now
in the console i should have this
forward slash contact so that just means
that the user
is trying to access the resource by the
name of contact
and if of course the resource is there
awesome we send something back if not
then most likely would send back the 404
now if i delete that contact and if i
simply go with 5000
notice i'm going to have the forward
slash so again this just signals
that we're getting the home page so
forward slash is going to be the home
page
and then whatever other resource we
would want we would have
port slash and then the resource now
sometimes those resources
are going to be forward slash resource
name and then
another forward slash and another
resource name and on and on and on
you can really type here whatever you
want so again i go with localhost about
and then info and i don't know something
john
right so i can add that here and there
it is now i'm requesting
this resource and if it's not there we
send back 404 if it's there then of
course
we send back the useful info so
hopefully that is
clear yes this will just mean that it is
a homepage
and whatever comes after the homepage
well that's the resource that the user
is trying to access and now of course we
can set up the if statement
whereas say yes if it is a home page
please send back this html if it is
about page
then send something else and then if
i cannot find that resource that you're
looking for then we'll send back
404. now there's going to be a little
bit of copy and pasting
just so we can save a little bit of time
we're just going to go with if
and actually we can set this up as a
property so let's go to const url
is equal to request url and then we'll
say if url is equal to forward slash
what does that mean well that means that
it is a homepage
so let's grab these three lines of code
and move them up
and now of course i want to set up else
if now
i'll just set up one for the about page
so if url
is equal to about page then we'll do
something else
and if none of those match
well then i'll just say else and i'll
send back
404 now i will add some comments here
just so we are clear on what is
happening so this is going to be about
page
then this is going to be called home
page
home page and then we're going to have
the 404
so resource not found so again
in order to save us a little bit of time
let's just copy and paste
one and two and again content type will
be exactly the same so that is going to
be html
because we'll send back the html i'll
say about
and i don't know page let's call that
and then last one is going to be the 404
so in here of course we're not going to
send back 200.
200 is for successful request
now of course i want to say hey listen
the resource that you're trying to
access
well it doesn't exist on my server so
here i go with
404 and again i go with the same content
type
text html and then let's just send back
the
heading 1 with page not found
so save this one and now of course once
i refresh
check it out i get this page not found
why well because there is no resource
forward slash about info and john
but if i go to just about there it is
now of course i have my about page and
then
if i go back to the homepage of course i
have heading 1
with a home page now we optionally
if we want we can add the status
text as well and in order to see that
let's just go back to the node docs
so this is going to be the http and of
course i'm looking for
right head and we have a right head here
notice we have status code optionally we
can pass in
status message and then we have the
headers
so again let's go back to our slide this
is the most important one
status code and then the status text
essentially
is just going to be added in this case
we don't need to do anything
because again if we were to go back to
the
browser network tab and if we take a
look at our localhost
there is first of all this is forward
slash that just means that we're going
to the homepage
and the status code is 200 and then we
have this
status text now again if i navigate to a
page that doesn't exist
for example john then of course i'm
going to get the
404 so that's the status code
and then the status text is not found
so hopefully it is clear now we have
a bit more meaningful server
where we have multiple resources
we have home page we have the about page
and also we have the error page
and with this in place now of course we
can start working on
more complex setup nice and with our
most basic example
in place now i'm going to start throwing
mine grenades at you
first of all i want to let you know that
of course we're not
limited to passing in the html directly
into the dot right or that end
meaning imagine if you would have to
every time
just set it up or your html in methods
directly
of course what we can do instead is set
up the file
then require the file using the file
system and then just pass it in
now keep in mind one thing though where
we will be passing in the
contents of the file not the file itself
and that's very important we'll be
passing in the contents of the file so
that means we still need to use this
content type just because we're going to
be getting
the data from the html file doesn't
really mean anything
yes it's nice it's going to make our
lives easier if you want to set up
a more meaningful web page but we still
need to set up
the content type now this is going to be
a temporary file
because in the next video we'll cover
a more serious example
and i already prepared all the files for
you
so this is where we'll really struggle
and this is where i'll show you why we
use the express
but for now if you want to follow along
just create a simple
index html or about html doesn't really
matter how you call the file
in the folder again this is really
optional
i'm going to go with new file and i'm
gonna call this index
html and again the whole reason why i'm
doing that because
i wanna set up a more proper page
and i don't wanna type everything here
in the right or
end i mean it's much more nicer here
right so i'm just going to go with emma
setup in visual studio code
i get my basics and i can say home page
home page and then i'm just going to go
with a heading 4 of hello world again
this is just a showcase that sky is the
limit
just like you normally would set up to
html you can do exactly the same thing
and then i'm going to go back to app.js
and first of all i'm going to get
the read file so i'm gonna go with const
and then
read file and sync and i'm gonna talk
about why i'm using this thing
in a second so don't freak out i know i
mentioned before that
we need to be mindful of the methods
that we use
that there is a difference between the
blocking and non-blocking and i'm just
going to go with
fs over here and we need to
come up with some kind of name and again
in the next video there's going to be
more data here so that's why i'll say
get
all files for time being in this video
i'll just get one
and i'm going to call this home page
again call it whatever you would want
you can call this bobby lee
doesn't really matter it's just a
variable and we're going to go with
read file and sync and of course where's
the file
it is in the same folder so we go with
relative path and i'm just going to call
this
index html now again we're getting the
contents
now why i'm using here they read file
sync
well there's two reasons first of all we
need to keep in mind that
we're not invoking this every time
someone comes to the server please keep
in mind that
we require that file when we
instantiate our server so basically that
initial time
when the server starts running so it's
not like when the request comes in then
again
every time we're requesting the file yes
of course if i
were to place this in the if block yeah
that's a different scenario
meaning if i were to even place this in
a create server again
same scenario but not in here again
we're just requesting this once
that's the first reason why i went with
that and second it's just an example so
i want to make my life a little bit
easier
what i want to focus on is something
else with this home page
in place now of course what i would want
is to go back
to my if where i'm checking for the
homepage
and instead of going with res.right and
then typing it out
i'm just going to go with our content
now again we're still keeping this one
the text.html and i'll show you in a
second what happens if we change it to
a text plane and now we go with a
homepage
and now be prepared to be amazed because
if i go
to not john my resource of course
doesn't exist
there it is check it out we have home
page as well as the hello world
so we can start making some meaningful
html pages and we can serve them
with our awesome server and just to
re-emphasize my point
if we change this to a plane and save
and refresh
now of course we're getting a text so
yes it is very important
of what content type we are setting up
so let's go back to html
and now of course we are in good shape
awesome we have
our homepage and now of course i can go
to index.html
and go wild and crazy
with my page setup not bad not bad
now we know that we can access the
contents of the file directly
so of course we can set up proper pages
but now let me throw you a mine grenade
where we'll have to add way more
code here if we want to really serve
some meaningful web page and the example
is going to be following
if you navigate to navbar app so that's
the folder
you'll find index.html you'll find style
css logo svg as well as
browser hyphen app.js and i simply call
this browser app file
so you're not confused between the two
so this is going to be for our server
and this is
our browser app and effectively this is
a
complete app that we set up i believe
in my javascript course when we were
building projects
so effectively this is a little navbar
with a toggle functionality and let me
assure you something
right from the get go the app works so
if you get any issues along the way it's
because the node is not working
the app itself is going to work and i
can simply showcase that
if i go to navbar app and i'm going to
copy that one
and i'll place it on my desktop
and then if you spin up the index html
i can guarantee you that this is going
to work there it is
that's my application and i can make it
smaller and there it is now i'm toggling
again our goal is following i want to
take
this project index.html
with style css logo as well as the
javascript file
so the html structure the
styling the logo that you can see over
here as well as the logic
i want to take all of it and serve it on
my server
and i know that the app works so
all that is good so let's see what
struggles
we're going to have along the way so
here i have the home page right
and instead of getting it from the
index.html which by the way i'm going to
delete because again
this was just temporary now of course i
would want to access this one
from the navbar app that's the folder
name right
and then i'm looking for the index html
and i simply just need to change my path
where instead of getting it index html
from the root
which doesn't exist anymore i'm going to
go to navbar hyphen
app and then of course i still get the
homepage
and as you can see i'm still serving
also the contents
from that index.html the only thing i
did
is just change the path that's it and
technically
we should see exactly the same right
but here's the kicker we navigate here
and if i refresh
what is happening i don't have the logo
i don't have the button i mean i do have
the button but it doesn't do anything
and i can see only the structure
and we have quite a few 404s here
and actually to give you a good idea why
is this happening
i want to navigate back to our project
and let's just console log
the urls and i think this is going to
give you
a clear message why this is happening so
let me go back
and i'm just going to refresh one more
time
and check it out so we're requesting the
homepage
so that makes sense right so i come here
i request the home page
and i serve this html file
from the navbar app and then i have
three more requests
i have one for styles one for browser
and one for logo
now why is that happening well because
in my index html
if you check it out of course i do
reference the style css
because i want to add the styling right
i do reference the logo
because the logo is right here in my
folder
and also of course i do have the one for
the app
right the one where i have my logic
so this is what happens we send back
the initial html content and the browser
starts reading the content
and every time we have basically a path
to our server browser is like
hey server give me this resource so give
me style css
give me logo svg as well as
whatever we have here the browser app
right so keep in mind that
these ones are for icons and actually
they are external so this one goes to
phantasm
that's a little bit different scenario
yes the browser still performs
this request but of course this is
external resource
now these ones are on our server but the
problem is following
are we handling these requests in our
create server
and of course the answer is no we handle
forward slash
we handle about and then for everything
else
we have this 404 so to answer your
question
yes now manually we'll have to
request all the files so
lower svg style css as well as the
browser app
assign them to some kind of variable and
set up these paths
again this is just an example if you
don't want to follow along
if you just want to see how it's going
to work
just sit back and relax but in my case
i'm going to request
all these resources here and then set up
more else if statements where if
the browser wants to get the css then of
course we'll search css
if the browser wants to have logo then
of course the browser
is going to get local and again if you
take a look here
in the elements you'll again see exactly
why
because we have our html structure and
then there it is
we have style css so notice how browser
is going to
http localhost 5000 forward slash what
well style css right well do we have
that path and again
the answer is no so let's do this way
i'm going to copy and paste and i'm just
going to come up with different
names here i'm going to say home styles
and then the third one i guess is going
to be home image
and then the fourth one will be home
logic so that
is going to be my app one then we'll
have to change some files here as well
so i'm looking for styles css i believe
right
that's the file name then i have logo
svg
that's where my logo is sitting
so logo svg and then finally
let's just delete this one as well and
call this
browser hyphen app and
js so home styles home image and logic
and like i said
yes manually one by one we'll have to
add
all these resources so instead of about
page
i'll just call this styles and the value
that i want to check for here
is exactly the same like in my browser
so they need to match
so then of course the browser will get
the contents
of the css file in this example so i'm
going to go
with styles and then css
now i do want to change right now the
content type because am i sending back
the html
of course the answer is no we're sending
back the css so we go
text css now let me say this one more
time please don't zero
in on these mime types if you
will ever need them you'll be able to
find them within a matter of seconds
just type along with me and we're going
to be in good shape
now as far as the right in our body so
in our response that we're sending back
are we going to send back html
of course the answer is no now of course
i want to send the
styles right and the variable for that
is home styles so that's where
my content is for the styles
css and once i save check it out
now we are moving along in the right
direction
because i do have the styles so it looks
already
somewhat decent now the logo is still
missing
and there's no logic because i don't
have the app.js
or the logo svg but we are
moving in the right direction so copy
and paste
and you can probably already guess that
we'll just repeat over here
we'll say if the url is equal to logo
svg
and i'll say image logo as far as the
comment
and we're just going to go with logo and
3g
and as far as the mime type for this
sucker it is
image image forward slash svg
and plus xml like so
and let's go with home and i believe i
named this home and image like so
and then the last one of course is going
to be our javascript
so let's say here logic and the resource
that i would want to provide is browser
app js like so
and then the content type is equal to
text and then javascript
and of course now i would want to send
the home
and logic so let's save this one
and now if i go to my browser and
if i refresh check it out now of course
we have everything we have the logo
as well as the proper functionality
with browser app and notice how
all our requests are 200 instead of 404
where the previously browser wasn't able
to find those resources
and now of course we are providing them
and
if we want to test out the functionality
there it is now i can just go here and
notice how
i can toggle the menu as well and now of
course we'll switch gears
and start working with express because
hopefully
it's clear that yes we can
set up our server with just http module
but imagine a scenario where you have
a website with tons of resources and
then of course you need to set up
every single resource in this matter
now i don't know about you but i would
go nuts
somewhat quickly all right and once we
have struggled a bit
now let's make our lives easier by
getting to know
express js express is a minimal
and flexible node.js web app framework
designed to make developing websites web
apps
and apis much faster and
easier if i have to be honest it's
almost unfair how easy
and fast it is to spin up the api with
the help of
express and while it's not officially
part of node
meaning unlike http module express is
not
one of the built-in modules at this
point in time express is pretty much a
standard
when creating web applications with
node.js
express has awesome documentation which
we will reference from time to time
and you can find the docs at
expressjs.com
again the site is expressjs.com
and as far as the install you simply
need to run the command
of npm install and the package name
is express now they do suggest this
hyphen hyphen save flag and effectively
the reason why they do that
is because in the earlier node versions
if you did not add this flag then
package wasn't saved to the package json
meaning when you push this up to the
github the next person who was getting
your project
well he or she did not have the
reference for the package
so of course that caused the errors now
currently
that issue is fixed so this is just a
good precaution
but technically you shouldn't have any
issues if you don't run the command
again nothing bad is going to happen if
you
add this dash save but technically
these days you can skip it so just grab
the command
like so and just navigate back to the
project
just keep in mind that of course i
already installed the express
for the express tutorial this is just
for your own project
if you want to install the express if
you set up your own package.json and all
that
if you want to install the express just
run this command now one thing that i
would like to mention though
is that i'm using version 4.17
so maybe by the time you're watching
this they already have
a version 5. now at the moment version 5
is in
alpha meaning they're still testing
everything but maybe by the time you're
watching this
this is already stable now if that is
the case
when you run npm install on express
of course you'll get the latest version
so your version
is not going to be this 4.17 now
i wouldn't worry if it's for example
four point i don't know 24
but if it's five there might be some
breaking changes
and at that point you have two options
if that is the case if
the version is already five then you can
either
reference the api docs for yourself
meaning you can take a look at the
methods and all that what
the version five provides or
if you want to use all the methods and
properties that we use
in tutorial simply install the same
version
how you can do that well you just need
to go to npm
install express so this stays the same
and again
you can remove it you can leave the dash
dash save doesn't really matter
and after express you go with add and
four and then again i'm gonna go with
the same one just keep in mind
as long as you have four you're not
gonna have any issues
and then one so this is going to install
express
with this specific version hopefully
everything is clear
and now let's get to know express all
right and once we have covered
the express library basics now of course
let's spin the sucker up
and see how we can make a server
way easier and with way less headache
and i'm going to start by removing all
the code
in my app.js just keep in mind that
if you ever need a reference go to the
final one
and then of course http basics is going
to be where we set up
the basic http server and then for
example
the http app example is going to be in
the file
number two and the way we work with
express
we start by setting up some kind of
variable and of course
we'll have to use the require so we go
with require and then we're looking for
express library again we can do that
because we have installed the library
but if you haven't
then of course you'll get the error keep
that in mind and then we go with const
and then app
is equal to express to whatever
we imported and then we invoke it
now if you're a bit iffy about this
syntax just keep in mind that
it is very similar to our previous
example
where we went with http then created the
server
and as a result we had
our server instance correct so this is
similar
we're getting a function back from
express and we just invoke it
and we right away have our server
instance with
bunch of cool methods now what you'll
also see
on a web is something like this where
since this is a function we can invoke
it right away
and then just call this one app again
this is really your preference but
mostly you'll see
the first option where we first
import the module and only then we
invoke it so once we have this setup
then of course we have a object with
bunch of
useful methods now the methods that
we'll use the most
are following amp.get and i'll just copy
and paste here
and i'll just change it around a little
bit post
and put as well as delete
and also there's going to be all
use and a listen
now listen we already covered before in
the
http module and this one is pretty much
the same
where we just go with app.listen and
then we just say what port we're going
to be listening on
so in this case of course this is going
to be 5000 and then we pass in the
callback function
so when we instantiate that server we
will
run this function and a common
convention
is just setting up a console log where
we say that
yeah the server is listening on port
such and such now for time being we're
hard coding this value
later i'll show you how we can make this
one dynamic
so for now i'll just say console log and
then server
is listening on
port and then we go 5 000.
so let's save this one and i'll run my
npm
start and i should see in a console
server is running
or listening on port 5000 awesome
so what about the other methods and the
first
four methods here just represent http
verbs now if you remember when we talked
about the http request and
response messages well one of the things
that we're looking for in the request
message
was the http verb and yes
i set up some more meaningful examples
where we'll see all of them in action
for now just remember two things first
this just represents what the user is
trying to do
whether read the data insert data update
data
or delete data and by default all
browsers perform
a get request so that's why we have here
amp.get
that post put and delete now all
just works with all of them and we'll
see that in a second when we set up
the 404 page so essentially a response
if we cannot find the resource on a
server
and app.use is responsible for
middleware and since it's such a crucial
part of express of course i prepared
more examples on that
where we cover everything from the
scratch so for now just remember this is
middleware
but don't lose your sleep over it we'll
cover it a little bit later
in the course so we have app.listen
beautiful we're listening on port 5000
but since i know that all the browsers
are performing a get request
i simply go with app dot get
and then i need to specifically add two
things a path
so what resource the user is trying to
access
and it would make sense if we would
start with root correct
and then the second thing is the
callback function
so this callback function will be
invoked
every time user is performing
a get request on our route
so basically on our domain and then this
callback function
gets the same two arguments we go with
request as well as the response
so this is going to deal with incoming
request message
and then this is going to deal with our
response
and in express we go with res and then
the method name
is send so in here we can pass the
string we can pass
in the html and i'm just going to simply
start with
home and page so we save this one
and now of course i'm going to navigate
to my browser
i'm going to say localhost and then 5000
and there it is now we should have
homepage if you don't again
please troubleshoot because otherwise
it's not going to make sense
what we are about to do next but if you
see the home page
you are in good shape so we're listening
for get request
on our route and then every time the
user
navigates to the root then of course we
just send back the homepage
now if you want you can of course go to
log and
user hit the resource or something like
that doesn't really matter
and then if you go back to the browser
and if you refresh
there it is we have user hit the
resource awesome
and just like in our previous example
the basics one let's set up the about
page
as well as the 404 so i'm going to go
back to my app
js and right above the app that listen
i'm going to go with another app that
get
and in this case i'm looking for about
so
that's the resource and of course in
here again we have
rec and res and then as far as the
response
well i'll cheat a little bit and i'll
just say res.send
and we're going to go with about page
and then of course i would want to
handle the 404 as well
so if the user comes to
my server and tries to access a resource
that doesn't exist
well what am i going to send back and we
can take a look at the default one
so if i'm going to go with about i
should
see the about page but if i go with for
example
a contact page let's see what the
express is doing and in this case i have
cannot get the contact
and if i inspect i can clearly see that
in my network tab i have contact
and this is a404 so that's going to be
the default response
now i can alter this of course and i can
set up
my own 404 response so i'm going to go
with app
and this is the case where i'm going to
use all methods
because again user can do multiple
things on a server
and i want to cover them all not just
getting the resource
or inserting the resource or whatever i
want to cover
them all so that's why i'm going to use
my own method again
this just handles all http
verbs whether get post or whatever and
again this method
takes two arguments first one is going
to be the path and the second one
is going to be a callback function and
as far as the path
i can say all of them so whatever
resource you're trying to access
the response is going to be exactly the
same if i cannot find the resource
then i'll just send back this response
so again
i have a callback function rec and res
in here
and then we're going to go with res dot
send
and just like in our http example i'm
gonna go
with heading one and we'll say resource
not found and let's close the heading
one
but of course i also would want to add
the status
right so that would make sense i don't
want to send back 200.
that would be very confusing so before
we invoke
send method i can also add status here
and as you can see i can chain it so i
have res
not status so this is where i'll pass in
my status code
and then i go with send so in our
not found example of course i would want
to pass in the status code
of 404 that is going to be more correct
and the same goes here technically we
can rely on express
and it does a decent job of adding those
status codes
but a more common approach is explicitly
setting up the status code so that way
you have more control
of what is sent back to the browser so
in here i go with
res and that send but before
i set up that method i set up a status
one first
and i go with 200 so this just means
that
the request was successful so similarly
i'll do that
in the about where i go with status
we pass in the 200 and then we set up
a chained send so now if i go back to my
browser
and if i refresh now of course i have
resource not found
that is my heading 1 and i can clearly
see my 404
and if for example i'm looking for about
there it is i have my about page
as well as the homepage so if we go to
localhost
and 5000 that's going to be our route
that
is going to be our homepage all right
and we're done with our basic example
hopefully you can see that it is already
way less code than just using the
built-in http module
and in the next example you'll see how
express truly shines
when it comes to setting up a server
beautiful we're done with our basic
example now let's tackle the big beast
our navbar app and the setup for the
following
examples is really up to you
if you're not a fan of retyping
something you have already learned you
don't have to do that you can just
remove
app.get all the way to app.all
so basically leave the import as well as
instantiation
and listen as well however
i am a fan of repeating something
because that way whenever i need to
create something from scratch
i already have done it quite a few times
so i don't have that blank page syndrome
where you're like looking at the
empty file and you don't know what to do
so in my case i'm going to remove
everything and we'll start from the
scratch so const
express is equal to require and of
course we're looking for express
and then i'm going to set up my app that
is equal to express we invoke it
and again we go with app.listen and
we're going to go with 5000.
now i'm not saying that i'm going to do
that for every example
but i'm just showcasing what is in my
approach
when i'm starting something new so when
i'm learning something new yes i do like
to
retype some of the stuff quite a few
times because
that just makes sure that i remember it
better
and in here i'm going to go with server
here's listening
on port and we go with 5000
and then dot and in order to set
everything up
we're going to go with app.get so again
i'm looking for the root
and of course i would want to start with
my index html correct
that's the start and we go with app.get
so we're listening for all the incoming
requests
that go to our route and of course we're
specifically listening for get requests
then we have our callback function rack
and
res and we'll set up the functionality
in a second
before we do anything let's also set up
all
and this is of course going to be for
all the requests
that will hit 404 so we're going to go
with
rack and res and here let's say res
and then status so let's add here a 200
or i'm sorry four four my bad and then
we're gonna go with
send and instead of the send let's just
go with the resource
not found now when it comes to get
in this case i would want to send the
file more specifically
i would want to send back the index.html
and in order to do that i need to use
send file
method that comes with express now in
there though
i do need to provide a absolute path so
we'll have to use
one of the modules we covered before and
that is going to be a
path module so i go with const path is
equal
to require and i'm looking for path
module again we don't have to install it
comes preinstalled with node so we are
in good shape
and then where we have our callback
function we go with
res and send file method
and here let's pass in path and then
resolve so path dot resolve remember
that was one of the methods we cover and
effectively i would want to pass
in the dirt name so this is going to be
path
to our directory because we do need to
provide that absolute path
and then of course we're looking for our
index.html which is sitting
in the navbar app so forward slash and
then
navbar hyphen app
and then we have another forward slash
index
html now if i have to be perfectly
honest in this case
we can also use path dot join it doesn't
really matter since their name
provides that absolute path but just to
be
a bit explicit that we are providing
absolute path
i went with path dot resolve and then
the their name
and then whatever is the path to my
index
html and the moment we save it
we'll have the same errors just like in
the http module
so i go to my localhost 5000 and i still
have the same issues
i still don't have style css there's no
sign of browser app
as well as the logo now in express
though
we don't have to do this whole song and
dance
like in http module in express i can
simply go
above all my app.gets and amp.alls
and i can go with app dot use
and this is going to be the case where
i'll type out the code
and then i'll explain everything that is
happening
and we'll pass in the express so this is
what we're importing
so this is not going to be our server
instance instead we're going to go with
express
and then static that's the method and in
here again we just need to provide
a path now common name is setting this
up as the folder by the name of public
please keep in mind technically you
don't have to do that you can just point
to our navbar app but in my case i will
do that
i will set up here dot forward slash
and i'll call this public so now of
course what i need
is to set up a folder by the name of
public
and then all my static resources
all my static files i would want to
transfer there now don't worry about it
i'll cover in length
what in a server land means static
resources
for now what i would want you to do is
go back to
our folder and that is going to be
express tutorial
and of course you can do that in visual
studio code i just think that this is
going to be
a bit easier to see so i'm going to
create a new folder
again common convention is calling this
public but
you can call it whatever lobster it
doesn't really matter
and then in my case i'm just going to
copy these files
so take browser app take logo
and take styles if you want you can move
them just remember that the previous
code
is not going to work as far as the http
module setup
so i'm going to copy these ones and
paste it here
in my public so now of course i have
browser app
logo svg and style css
so of course now i can zoom
out and once i save
check it out when we navigate to
our route there it is this is
our application and what's really cool
all those resources
are right away available so if i go to
my
localhost 5000 remember browser was
looking for what well it was looking for
example for
style css if you go here
there is a resource by the name of style
css and of course
in here i have all my css code
and notice how we didn't have to set up
the statuses we didn't have to set up
the content types or any of that
express takes care of it all now
of course you probably at this point
have more questions than answers
so let me start clearing them up and
first i'm just going to add a comment of
setup static and
middleware middleware and like i
mentioned
app.use is for setting up the middleware
and we have more serious examples coming
up
so for time being please don't worry
about this
line okay so please don't worry about
app.use what is
express static that is essentially a
built in middleware i will cover
everything step by step in this video i
would want you to understand
what the term static asset means
and it simply means that it is a file
that server doesn't have to change it
so instead of our http example
where we created a path for every such
resource
and if i were to have i don't know 20
000 images i would have to repeat
the same steps instead since this is a
static asset meaning an asset where the
server doesn't need to change it we
simply
place it in designated folder
again the common name for those folders
are public
or static and then we just dump
all those assets in there so if i were
to have i don't know
20 000 extra images in here i can just
dump them
and express will take care of it all it
will set up the paths
it will set up the mime types it will
set up the status codes
and all of that good stuff so hopefully
that is clear
static assets are just files that
server doesn't have to change and an
example
of a static asset is an image file
here's the style file
and also a javascript file and here
comes the next question
what is this guy with weird eastern
european accent talking about
because all my life i've been told that
the javascript
makes my apps dynamic
it adds all the functionality so how
come this is
just another static asset and to answer
your question
yeah you're right javascript does make
our apps dynamic however think about it
this is a browser app so it makes
dynamic
on a browser as far as servers is
concerned
it is just a asset doesn't need to
change
now if you're wondering well how to set
up something dynamic
just please put the pin on that and
we're going to cover that when we cover
server-side rendering because there is
such thing
as template engines and the simplest way
for me to explain that
is imagine the scenario where you can
actually
log in or in other way just showcase
whoever is visiting the site and then
dynamically i would display for example
name
so if the peter logs in then i'm sending
back the html
with the text of hi peter now if the
john logs in
then of course i'm sending back the
username
with the value of john so hopefully you
get the gist
where in this case notice this is just
same old index html that i'm sending
back
regardless of who is visiting the site
but yes there's also
an option of setting this dynamically
where depending
on who's visiting the site or what the
user is trying to do
i'm actually modifying my file before
i'm sending it back so hopefully it is
clear
how much easier it is to work with
express
where if we have static assets we just
set up
designated folder and just dump them all
in
and static asset just means a file
that server doesn't need to change and
of course we can start
working on our next example nice
hopefully we are clear on static acids
and before we cover more complex
expressed topics i would want to throw a
mine grenade at attribute
and it goes something like this so if we
put
two and two together i talked about
static assets
in the previous video but if we're
looking
at the index.html isn't this
a static asset as well and of course the
answer
is yes so instead of sending this file
we can add it to static assets and we're
going to be
in good shape and if i have to be
perfectly honest with you
when it comes to send file
if we're using it to send back for
example index html
actually we use other two methods
instead
so first i'll show you the first one
where we just dump everything
as far as the static assets so i'll just
add index.html to all my static assets
in the public and that will effectively
do exactly the same like we're doing
here
with send file and the other one is
going to be using
templating engine so of course that one
will cover
when we go to server set rendering so
i'm just trying to showcase that
yes there is this option of send file
and we might use it from time to time
throughout the course but not for
sending back
index html files so first let me just
say that
the other option one of the two other
options that we'll use the most
throughout the course is just adding two
static assets
like so and then the second one is going
to be server side rendering
where basically we'll use template
engine for that
so in order to set everything up now of
course i just need to take
my index html and again if you want you
can just move it
or in my case i'm just going to copy and
paste
so again i'm going to go back to my
folder i'll
zoom in massively so you can see better
so express tutorial
there is my navbar app and i'll just
take the index.html
and i'll copy and paste and now it is in
the public
so what happens index.html
is always going to be a root so when
the user hits the server by default
server will serve this index.html
and since our index.html basically has
all the paths
to browser app to logo svg and all that
we're going to be in good shape more
effectively we don't even need to set up
this send file option so now
of course i can just save it and once i
refresh
notice how nothing changed i'm still
serving
my app so we're still in good shape and
if you take a look at
the network tab notice everything still
works correctly
i'm still getting all the css
all the browser javascript functionality
as well as the logo and to answer your
question
yes that is effectively how you can set
up the simple sites
you can simply just dump all your files
in the public
just make sure that you serve them up
and that's it
and you're in good shape now we still
have the 404
but as far as just serving straight up
sites with html css and javascript yes
you can simply dump them into public you
can simply set up
the middleware and serve all the static
assets
and you're going to be in good shape
beautiful
we are successfully done with the
initial express setup
and ready to cover more complex express
topics
before we do that though there's
something important i want to mention
you see when it comes to express in most
cases you'll use one of the two
following options
you'll use it to set up api or templates
with
server side rendering now since term api
is probably one of the most overused
terms in the community
and in various scenarios it can mean
different things
let's start by understanding that in
express
or in http case when we talk about api
we mean setting up an http interface
to interact with our data now data is
sent
using json which stands for javascript
object notation and in order to send
back
our response we're going to use res.json
method
which will do all the heavy lifting like
for example setting up the proper
content type
and stringify our data the other flavor
we
have is server side rendering where
we will set up templates and send back
entire html
and css and javascript ourselves and
we're going to do that using
res.render method now since i'm a big
believer in actual
examples over slides if you are a bit
iffy
on either of these flavors just hold on
a bit
and once we cover some examples i
promise you it will all make sense
now why am i telling you all of this you
see when it comes to
more complex express topics it only
makes sense
if we cover them properly using one of
these flavors
instead of just bunch of random examples
and the option i picked is the api one
so in the following examples we're going
to construct api response
using more advanced express setups
the reason why i picked apr route is
because i believe it lets
us focus more on the actual express
since templates by themselves add a bit
more unnecessary overhead
especially while we're just starting out
with express
with that said let me be very clear if
you grasp the concepts
with api so using the api flavor
you'll have no problem implementing them
with templates as well
since for the most part express concept
setup is exactly the same
we'll cover server side rendering later
in the course
so you'll have to wait a bit for the
actual example
and since we're going to start with api
let me just stress the main point one
more time
and how it looks like in a real world so
like i said the main idea with apis
is that our server provides data
and what that means that any front-end
app that wants to access it and use it
can simply perform
a http request and using our data
set up the api and functionality how
does that look like
in a real world well if you navigate
again back to course api
and of course not the slides slides are
just images
but if you take a look at any of these
examples
you'll notice something interesting
where we're sending back
the json and you can clearly see that if
you go again to your
browser's network tab and here again
let's refresh and you'll see that this
is our response
react tabs project so again the full url
is
course api.com and then react
tabs project and if we take a
closer look we can see that this is the
response that we're sending
so we're sending back a json
data and i can clearly see that in my
headers
so in response headers as you can see
content type
is application json now where
is this data used if you took either
my react course or the vanilla
javascript course
you know that in the course we build
quite a few projects where we practice
data fetching
either using vanilla jazz or react
and in some examples we use external
apis and in sum
we use the apis that are here
in the course api so for example with
this
react tabs project if you navigate to
react project nutlify.app
and keep on scrolling keep on scrolling
you'll hit the tabs project
and here this is the app that we build
using the data so again on a server
i set up my data i set up the api
and i share the data so i create the
http
interface and then the frontend app just
simply
grabs this data and again if you want
you can check it out here
if you refresh notice this request
request goes to
course api react tabs project so we grab
the data
on a front end and then we set up the
functionality
as well as user interface hopefully this
is clear
from now on we are going to be
responsible for
sending back the data so now since we're
setting up the server
it's not going to be our responsibility
to do something with it
like we were doing on a front-end in
this case
we are responsible for setting up the
responses
so we're going to be setting up apis
that our http
interfaces to interact with our data
not bad not bad i think we clearly
covered
our two options so one is sending back
the json data
and the second one is server set
so why don't we start by covering the
most basic
json response and here's what i'm trying
to
mimic if you go to course api
and then if you look for the tours
project
you'll hook the url of course and here
you can see that
we're getting back a json data it is an
array
and each object represents a tor
and if you took my react course you know
that we were practicing data fetching
in react and effectively we hit this url
and we got the data we got our json data
back
and then we built an app using that data
but again the whole point here is
following where
it doesn't have to be react it can be
vanilla javascript application it can be
swelled framework
it can be any setup where you're able
to fetch that data so in here on the
server
we just share the json so in this case
of course
that is stores and then anywhere
anyone who wants to access this data
they can just access it
and build something using that data and
that's why it is
so so powerful and
essentially this is what we're going to
do we're just going to send back first
a most basic array and then we'll see
how we can make this more dynamic please
keep in mind two things
first of course eventually we'll use
database for that
and of course i will mention that
probably 20 000 times
as we're building these examples and the
second thing that i would like you to
understand that
when it comes to express basics
so essentially how we set up the server
it doesn't really matter
whether we're using server side or
whether we're using json again
if we understand the principles we'll
have no problem
using any of those options so first what
i would want
is to navigate back to my project and
again this is going to be the time where
i do write everything from scratch but
then
starting with next example i'll just use
some options that we already covered so
for now
yes i'll remove everything and again
we'll set up express
one last time so we're gonna go with
express require
and express okay awesome then const app
is equal to require or i'm sorry not
require
we need to invoke the express like so
and then let's go with app.listen port
5000
and then let's call our callback
function
and then let's go again with console.log
and server
is listening on port
on port and of course the port number
is 5000. then again i
want to set up app.get because that is
the http method
that all browsers perform by default
so i'm going to go with app.get and i'm
not going to go with specific path
just keep in mind that you can and of
course we'll do that later for example i
can go here with
api and then i don't know i can call
this product or whatever
for time being let's just make it simple
and we'll just handle
all the root requests so that way we can
save a little bit of typing in the
browser
and again we have our function our
callback function
rack and res and as far as the response
we're going to go with res and then the
method name
is json now
we will go to the docs just so you
understand
where i'm getting this information from
but
before we do that let me just tell you
that i might
omit here and there the status one just
so we can
save a little bit of typing but don't
worry once we go to some
more serious examples of course we'll
still use the statuses
because in my opinion that is just a
better approach where we actually have
control
over the status and as far as
documentation
if we go back to express documentation
we're looking for api reference
again we are using four point something
so we are using version four so make
sure you look for the same one
and don't confuse with express json so
this is going to be
a middleware that we pass in effectively
we're looking for
response in a docs and then we're
looking for
this json option so res object
as the json method and what happens
we send back the json response and this
method sends a response with correct
content type
that is a parameter converted to a json
string using
json stringify this parameter can be any
json type including object
array string and blah blah blah so
hopefully you get the gist
so the only thing we need to do is go
back and for example
i'll provide an array where
there's going to be two objects and
first one will be named
john and the second one will be susan
so another object and we'll say name
is equal to susan and we have our most
basic api so if i go back to my
localhost 5000
and refresh there it is so now
anywhere in the world i can access this
data
and build something using this data now
there's tiny caveat
when i say anywhere in the world there's
still going to be at the moment
a course error and i'll cover that once
we
actually cover middleware so again
please please please please
be patient we will get there but
hopefully you get the gist
where this serves our data
and now we can just access that data and
build
the front-end app using this data now
this default setup is nice
but of course we can do something more
meaningful
where if you take a look at the folder
you'll notice
this data js now what is data.js
it is simply a file with
some arrays and the first array is going
to be products and
here as you can see i have objects and
then each of these objects
represents a single product and
all the way in the bottom we're
exporting both arrays we're exporting
products
as well as the people array that we're
going to cover a bit later
so now what i would want to do is import
product array in my address
and then instead of hard coding this
value
like so where i just pass in the array
with two objects i'll just dump the
whole products data
so let's go with const we already know
how to do that
now since i'm exporting multiple things
since i'm exporting an object
i will be explicit of what i would want
so i'm going to go with
product and basically i'm destructing
right away i'm going
say product is equal to require
and remember the file is data js
like so and then instead of passing
array directly i can simply go with
product
and what do you know when you navigate
to the root
there it is now we have more meaningful
json response where actually this is
a product data so on my front end
i can grab it and i can build some kind
of
nice front end using this data now
lastly before we go let me just showcase
that of course
there's going to be a content type set
up correctly as well
so if you go to network tab and again if
you refresh
localhost like so and take a look
now of course what is the content type
that is
application json so now of course we're
correctly
getting our json data so hopefully
you have a clear understanding how to
sound
json data so now of course let's make
things a bit more interesting
and cover some more advanced express
topics
nice once we're familiar with the most
basic json setup
now let's build a more meaningful api
and in a process we'll cover route
parameters
as well as query string parameters
and i would want to start in following
way
where essentially i'll leave all this
code
but when it comes to my route when it
comes to my home bridge
i'll essentially send back the heading 1
with the link as well and that link
will direct a user to a forward slash
api
and then product and then later we'll
cover the params
as well as the query string so let's
start with sending back html instead
so i'm not going with json one and i'm
not gonna send back the file
i'll go directly and i'll say send and
here we have the string of course so i'm
gonna go with heading one
and then home page
then i'll make sure that i close because
i believe in one of the previous videos
i believe it was the express basics
i think i messed it up here notice i
didn't add
the closing one so now everything is
correct
and now i'm gonna go with my link then
as far as the href
i'm gonna direct a user to api
and then forward slash
and then of course i'll also
set up a text here so products and i'll
close
my link so that should do it that is my
home page
and of course if i go to localhost 5000
there it is i have my homepage and once
i click the link
i navigate to api products now of course
the moment i have the default
response from the express meaning the
default 404 response
where the resource cannot be found
and as i said note if you want to take a
look what response do they send again go
to the network
this is going to be very very useful tab
refresh
and take a look at their response so
notice the response
that's the html that they send back
so cannot get and then api products now
we already know
why there is this get the http verb
because
that's the method that the browser
performs okay awesome
so now of course our job is to set up a
get request for this resource
so we go with app.get and
i specifically want to handle api and
product
so this one just looks a little bit more
realistic
so in here i go with api and products
and keep in mind
of course those values need to match
otherwise you'll get
that 404 again i have my callback
function
and now of course i would want to send
back the product however
in this case we'll make it a little bit
different where previously
notice the product we send back pretty
much the whole thing
right but a more realistic approach
is following where when you're
requesting
a bunch of data so when you're
requesting collection of the data
you're not always returning everything
for that one specific product
and to give you a real world example
again i'm gonna go back to my react
projects and i'm simply using them
because this gives you a visual
representation
during the course we built a e-commerce
and then in the products page notice how
we're fetching the products
but you need to keep in mind one thing
where
we're only fetching about the product
the title the price the image
and i believe also the id and only when
i go to that
single product page this is where i get
the rest of the data
whether that is for example a
stars the reviews the description
the availability and all that stuff so
what i'm trying to say
is when you're requesting a collection
of data there's going to be cases where
i simply want to
send back some minimal response
so for example again that could be name
image and the pricing
scenario and only if i look for this
specific product
then i send back everything and in order
to mimic that
in our example in this response
what i'm going to do is i'm just going
to iterate over my product
i'll use the map method and i'll just
remove my description so when i'm
sending back the product
it's going to be without a description
so again
if we were to send back everything i
would simply go with
response json and then i pass in the
product
so again if we go here and if we refresh
now everything is cool i'm getting my
product on the api
product route however i'm going to make
it
a bit more realistic and we're going to
go with const
new product is equal to product
dot map so i'm mapping over and i'm
creating a new array
and i'll reference each item as a
product
and then as far as the return well first
i want to structure
the properties out of the product and
the reason
why i can access them is because those
are the names that i used
when i'm setting it up so id name image
and all that
and that is equal to the product again
i'm just using
simple javascript structuring and then
as far as the return whatever i'm going
to return
from my function well that is going to
be the new value
so now i'm going to go with id name as
well as the image
and once i have this setup in place
instead of returning
product now of course i'm going to go
with
new products and if i go back to my
browser
there it is so now i'm getting a
collection
but i'm not sending everything
that i know about this specific item so
i'm being selective
of what i'm sending back so yes there is
a resource by the name of api
product and we're sending back the array
but we know that
if the user wants to access that
description
he or she will have to look for a
specific product and in the process
we'll cover what are the url parameters
all right so we're successfully sharing
a list of items
so now of course let's take a look at
how we can provide
info about that one specific
product so for example if i navigate
to product and then forward slash and
one
and then i'm going to get only the info
about this
first product because it has the id of
one and
not only i'll get these three properties
but also
get the description and our initial
approach
would go something like this where yes i
see the product okay beautiful
and we already know how to set up the
route now since i'll delete it
eventually anyway
i'm just going to copy and paste so we
can speed this up so i'm going to go
with api
products and then forward slash one that
just means that
i'm going to be looking for item number
one
in here and then instead of map we'll
use the find method
so i'm importing all my products and in
order to get the single product
i'm going to write the following code
where we're going to go with const
single product and don't worry we will
reuse this code so it's not like we're
just
randomly typing something so let's go
with products and then find
now again i'll reference each product
with a parameter of product in my
callback function
and then if the product id product id
matches one because that is my
route here then of course i'll return
that single product
so i'm going to say single product and
technically this works
so notice now of course i have only info
about this one specific product and i
have the description
however it feels like using bazooka on a
cockroach
yeah it gets the job done but probably
is an overkill because keep in mind
at the moment we have only four products
so yes if i really wanted to
i could set up four routes but
what if i have hundred two hundred three
hundred well
that's not gonna work and in express we
have something called
route parameters which essentially is
going to be way
better solution so instead of hard
coding this
1 2 3 or whatever
id we want we set up a route parameter
and it's going to look something like
this where i go with my route
and then i have forward slash and then i
go with colon
and then whatever name out one
so think of this as a placeholder so you
can call this bobby lee you can call
this chicken burrito
in my case i'm gonna go with product
and the id just to be
explicit of what i'm expecting over here
but again naming here is really up to
you
and what is more important is the fact
how we can access it
now if you want you can actually console
log the request object again
this is just going to be a giant object
and for now i'm just going to leave this
one the way it is
so i'm still going to be returning a
product number one
and also let's look for request
and then we're looking for the params
property so let me count to lock this
one and then again once i navigate
back and if i refresh in the api
products number one what you'll notice
again
this giant request object where we have
bunch of useful properties and methods
and of course i'm not going to cover all
of them right now but
similar to http of course in the express
we also have
access to bunch of useful things in that
request object and one of them is the
params
so check it out now i have this product
id
and the value is one now please keep in
mind one thing
that whatever you're going to be setting
up here
in the url as that route parameter
is always going to come back as a string
and this is important in this case
because if you take a look at our data
the id is a number and of course we'll
deal with that
in a second and whatever we set up
as far as our name is going to be right
in here
it's going to be in this request and
then parameters object
so now of course what i could do is i
could just destructure it
from the params and then use it in order
to find
that specific product so that way i
don't have to hard code
products number one product number two
and on and on and on
instead i just set up my route parameter
and just come up with whatever name i
would want just make sure that you add
this colon here
and then we'll access that value and get
a specific product so i'll leave these
two suckers for your reference
just in case you would ever want to
console log them
and we'll simply go with const and the
name
is product id and that is equal to
request that's my request object
and params then i'm going to use this
product id
to get my product but remember
it is a string we can clearly see that
and in fact here in the array well
the ids are numbers so if we'll just try
to search it the way it is
of course we won't be able to get our
product so instead what we want
is pass in the number and then
product id now of course if your ids are
set up
as strings which is somewhat typical
setup
for the databases and all that as well
as the headless cms is then of course
you don't need to worry about it
then you can just pass in the string and
now of course
i'm going to be able to get my one
product
so now if i go back and if i refresh
everything still works and if
i go to my url and start changing these
values
hopefully you can see that now of course
i'm getting
a different product now i'm getting
product number two
and i go to product number three and on
and on and on
so now with these few simple lines of
code
i can access any product in my array
now of course there's also a case where
we cannot find the product
because keep in mind here i can type
whatever i would want
so i can go with products and then let's
imagine that
the user types abc now
do we have a product with an id of abc
of course the answer is no so what's
happening over here
now i don't get anything back right well
i don't get
anything back because if i go to log and
then
single product let's see what we're
going to get back again
let me refresh abc and this one is
undefined
so that's what we're sending back as a
single product
so what would be a solution well a
solution
is setting up a if statement here where
i say
get me the single product if you cannot
find that single product
if basically that product doesn't exist
if the id that the user passed in
does not make sense you cannot find the
product with that id
then return 404 so how's that going to
look like well
we can go here if and then single
product
so we set up a if condition and of
course i'm going to go with if
single product doesn't exist so i'm
going to add exclamation point
and of course this is going to be our
case with undefined
this will be true if it is undefined and
then we just go with a return
res and in this case i will add a status
because that is extremely important
that i go with 404 and then we go with
send and product
does not does not exist
like so now if everything is correct
then of course we go with res and json
so in here i say
return and res dot json
so once i go right now to product and
then abc
there it is now of course i have proper
404 product does not exist and if i
again
take a look at the tab and i have my abc
now if i'm going to navigate to a route
where i can find the product then of
course i'm going to get
my proper product response so whenever
you think
of route parameters think of them as
placeholders where user provides a data
and then using requests and params we
can access that data
and then set up some kind of logic and
before we continue
and cover query string parameters let me
just mention
that route parameters can get way more
complex
than this so for example imagine this
scenario
i can go with app.get again i need to
come up
with some kind of routes i'm going to go
with api
then products so i'm looking for
specific products so i'm going to use
a route parameter let's call this
product
id then i'm going to look for
all the reviews and then maybe there's a
review id
so review and then id and now of course
again i have
rec and res like so and then i'm simply
going to send back
some kind of dummy data but i would want
to
console log the rec params just so you
understand
how everything works and now let me send
res.send so res not send
and i'm just going to say simple hello
world
let's save this one and again in the
browser
let's go here we have products again
some kind of id
whether that's abc whether that is a
number in this case it doesn't really
matter
since you can see that there's not much
functionality in there
but we need to type in here reviews and
then for example the
review id would be i don't know abc
so once i navigate here of course i'm
going to get my hello world
and then in the console notice how i'm
accessing all of them
so i have the product id as well as the
review id
so again they can get way more complex
than just this simple approach and one
more thing
i would like to mention this reviews
though is hard coded
so if i go back i can change the abc
and 4 however i would like but if i'll
change
from reviews to review i'm going to get
a 404 why well because review
is not a route parameter so that's not a
placeholder
so if this is incorrect then of course
i get d404 hopefully that is clear and
now let's talk about the
query string parameters all right and
once we're familiar with
rot parameters let's talk about the
query string parameters
or they're also called url parameters
and essentially that is a way for us to
send
small amounts of information to the
server
using the url now this information is
usually used as parameters
to for example query database or filter
results
and that's really up to the people who
are setting up the server
they decide what parameters are going to
be accepted
and what functionality will depend on
those values
and to give you a real world example
let me go to my search engine and i'm
just looking for hacker news
algolia api so when you're working on a
front-end app i'm not sure
whether you worked with this api but
that is a very cool
api and essentially it's going to work
as a good example of how we should be
setting up the server
and this is as a side note but notice
the url here so they go with
a domain which in our case is of course
localhost 5000
but here it is actually a algolia domain
so algolia.com forward slash api
like i said that is a pretty common
practice then a version number
and then whatever list you're getting
so in here it is items now check out
this one
doesn't that ring a bell of course that
is
a route parameter where they say yeah
here's the list of items
but if you want to be more specific
please provide
the id and then if you keep on scrolling
you'll notice the same thing with the
users again
we have the main domain api version one
users that's the list and then if you
want to get a specific one
then of course again there is a route
parameter
now this is just to showcase that i'm
not randomly coming up with those things
no that's how actually the servers work
in real world and let's keep on
scrolling and now we come to this
interesting part where we can sort
so we're getting the data from the
algolia api
but then in my app i can sort i can say
hey
you know what get me specific hacker
news story
or get me stories based on
some kind of search term and hopefully
you get the gist where
instead of just grabbing the whole thing
i can say you know what
get me all the stories that match
through
so again we go with the url and this is
really up to you how you set this up in
their case they use
search and then here we have this
question mark
and whatever is after this question mark
is not technically part of this url
meaning
it's just a way for us to send that data
to the server and then server decides
what to do with this data so the url is
still this one
the one that ends with search and then
we have a question mark
and basically this is just a specific
info
about the data that i'm requesting so
here the user
adds a query parameter and then the
value
is full and then also has tags of story
and that means that we're going to get
all the stories matching full
now what else you could set up here in a
query string
pretty much anything a pretty typical is
going to be page
for example if you have a list of things
and i don't want to get 100 items at a
time i can say
you know what split it up in pages and
get me initially page number one
and then only if the user clicks on a
button that
fetches the page number two then i get
the second page
then for example in here they have hits
per page so that is going to be how many
items per page
so again after that question mark
if the setup is supported by the server
then of course you can add those key
value pairs
and the way we add them as you can see
is by using key value pairs
so we have question mark and then we
have a key
which in this case is query and then the
value
now before we continue let me make
something very very clear
it's not like you can randomly search
the web and just start
adding these query string parameters and
then expect
that as a miracle you'll just get the
data that you're looking for
a as far as the keys they're designed on
a server
so if i'll set up a key of chocolate
milkshake
algolia api is going to be like i don't
know what you're talking about
and the same goes for the value so where
i'm going with this
now we are in charge of that server so
it's up to us
to handle those query string parameters
and i'm going to go back to our project
and i'll purposely set up a new route
please keep in mind one thing where a
pretty typical setup
is adding this to the list so again
we'll
look for specific property on our
request object
and then if that property is provided
then of course
we return a more detailed
response meaning there's maybe some
filtering or something like that
but if not then we'll send back all the
products now i'll purposely set up
a new route just so we don't jam all our
code
in this one route but then
in the next video probably i'll show you
how we can combine
both routes so let's keep on scrolling
so this is going to be our more complex
params example and let's go with app.get
and again the route is really up to you
i'm going to go with api
now in order to make it interesting i'm
going to add that version 1
just like the api of algolia has it
and then i'll say query now i don't need
to add question marks nothing like that
i just set up query
that is my route and then i have my
callback function
rack and res now in this callback
function
in order to access those query string
parameters
i need to go with rec and query so let's
go with console.log
and we're going to look for request and
not params
sorry we're going to go with query over
here
and again let's go with simple hello
world just so we can speed this up
and then if i go to the local host
and more specifically i'm going to look
for
localhost then 5000
then api then version number one and
then query and then if i add
this question mark i can add as many
query string parameters as
i would like so here i'm going to go
with the name that will be equal to john
then in order to combine them we just
add this ampersand
so we're going to go with name john and
then id4
just keep in mind that you can add as
many query string parameters
as you'd want and then once i navigate
there
at the moment i'm just going to get the
hello world so that's
my default response from this url but in
a terminal notice
i have name john and id number four
again this is a string
and this is going to be important in a
second
but what this allows us to do is access
those parameters
and then based on them do some kind of
functionality
now first of all i would want to change
this around a little bit where i'm not
going to be looking for name
or id i'm going to be looking for search
query parameter as well as the limit so
if the user
wants to search for a specific product
he or she needs to provide that
search query parameter as well as
limiting
where the user can limit of how many
products
they are getting back so let me navigate
back and just to showcase that
so again instead of name i will
zoom in we'll say search is equal and
then
whatever i would want so in this case
i'm just going to go with a
so effectively this will return all the
products
that start with a and then the second
one is the
what that was the limit right so i'm
gonna say limit
and for now let's just go with two of
them
so this will return two products
i'll zoom out and again i have search
and i have limit
after you so now of course let's set up
that functionality
and we'll simply start by creating new
instance of those products
i'm gonna go with let and you'll see in
a second why so say
sorted product and in here
we'll use the spread operator so we
imported the product
and now i'm just going to copy the
values so this is going to be my
new array and the reason why i'm using
let because we will modify
this value a bit now instead of just
cancel logging the query
i'll comment this out and we'll set it
up as const
and then again i'm looking for two
specific keys
i'm looking for the search and i'm
looking for the limit so if the user
doesn't provide them
well then we'll send back all the
product so we're gonna go
with query like so so i can see the
search and limit beautiful and now
instead of just sending back hello world
i'm going to check if the search
is in my query string parameters then i
would want to filter
my product so i'm going to say if and
then
search like so and we're going to go
with sorted products since i'm using let
i can do that
i'm going to go with sorted product and
then filter method again
straight up javascript again i'll call
this a
product like so and what i would want to
return
are the products that start with the
value
of my search term so here i can say
return
product and name so if the product name
starts with now again this is straight
up javascript
and i'll pass in the search if that is
the case that is going to be my value
in stored product and i can right away
check for the limit as well
where i'm going to say if and then limit
and if it exists so if the user has
provided it
again let's go with sort product and
filter more
and in this case i'm going to use the
slice method where i'm just going to get
specific items from the array
so i'm going to start with 0 and then
remember we're getting a string
so we need to go with number and then
again we'll pass
in the limit let's go here below both of
them
and let's just say res dot and then
status and we're going to go with
200 like so and then a json response
now when it comes to json response
we're just gonna go with our sword
product right so we go back
and let me just showcase something where
if
none of the query string parameters are
provided i'm gonna send back my whole
data
why well because i copied my products
right both of them were false both of
them were undefined
and as a side note there is a error here
cannot send headers and i'll talk about
it actually in a second that
is one of my next topics so let me just
deal with this hello world by deleting
it and
we're going to be in good shape but i'll
cover why we got this error
and what gotchas you should be aware of
so let me go back again
let's see again we're getting all the
products because
the user did not provide that specific
query string parameter
so if we right now navigate to the url
and i'm gonna start with a limit and if
in the limit i'm gonna say that i'm only
interested in two products
check it out now of course my limit is
two
so i only have two products and if it's
three then it's gonna be three
and then four and hopefully you get the
gist where
whatever value i provide here in a limit
well i have the functionality for it now
keep in mind again
name needs to match if this is going to
be limi instead of limit
again i'm just going to get back all the
products regardless
of what is my value and the same goes
for the value of the query string
parameter
if this is limit but for example i
decide to pass
in abc nothing i get empty array
why because my value wasn't what my
functionality
was looking for and similarly of course
we can add the search option as well
and i'm purposely showing them one by
one so you don't get confused
so let's say search and again the
functionality is set up where you need
to provide
a starting character so in my case i'm
looking only for the products
that start with a and there it is
i have two of them now if i want a limit
i can just add and
here and let's just type limit and i'm
only going to be looking for one product
and if i add this limit one
there it is now i only get one product
now there's also obviously going to be
the case where we return
empty array why well because
i could go with search and look for the
products
of b and unfortunately when it comes to
my product
data i don't have products that start
with b
so we can handle that instead of sending
back empty array
i could check what is the length of my
array
and if for example it is less than one
then i explicitly
send back the response where i say yes
the
request was successful but i couldn't
return any product
so we can go with if and then sorted
product
if the length of this array
is less than one if it is less than one
then of course i can just go with res
dot
status now this is one gotcha where
you're not sending back the 404 you're
not saying the
url doesn't exist or the resource
doesn't exist
in this case you're trying to filter
the product but nothing came back
so whatever query string parameters were
provided
they didn't yield any results so you're
simply saying
status and then you can go with send
and we can go with no products products
matched your search
like so so we can go here and then if we
refresh again with the same ones
we have no product match your search so
that is one option
you can send back the string but a
more common one is this one where i'm
going to comment this out for your
reference again
and instead you go with return and
you're going to go with res
dot status and again we have this error
in the server and again
i'll talk about it in the next video why
we have that one
so we're going to go with res dot status
and we pass in the
200 and instead we send back the json
one
and in that json again you can pass the
string if you want
but a more common approach is setting up
the object
where you explicitly say that the
request
was successful or a failure so you go
with
success and that is equal to true and
then
again you come up with whatever name you
would want a generic one
is data and then you send back the array
again you are in charge here you can
really do whatever you want i'm just
showing you
a pretty common approaches to the
situation so again
i'm looking for some kind of product
using my query string parameter
now unfortunately server can return
any data meaning any product
and then of course i just get this
success true because
the request was successful there was
nothing wrong with my url however
i'm just yielding a empty data so that's
it
i can just delete it and if i don't
provide anything
then i'm going to get all the products
hopefully that is clear
how the query string parameters work and
now we can cover a few gotchas
all right and two things that i would
like to emphasize are following first
remember those errors that we're getting
in a server
when we're setting up if conditions in
javascript
if we don't explicitly return
then of course javascript just keeps
reading the code
correct so if i'm going to omit that
return
i'm actually going to get the server
error where i send back
one response and then javascript just
keeps reading the code
and then express is confused express is
like hey wait a minute
i already sent back the response so
while you're sending another now keep in
mind that
it is happening in the same request so
you cannot send basically
two responses in the same request one
after the another
yeah of course you can send one based on
the condition so for example
if there are no products you send back
one response
and if you can yield some product then
great then you send the second one
but you cannot send both of them one
after another
in the same request and if you want to
see that error again in action
go to the query you'll add a question
mark here
and we're going to go with search and
again it is equal to b
for example that is my value that's the
starting value that i'm looking for
and once i do that notice yeah i'm
getting back the success true and data
but again i have this big fat error in
my server
and it says cannot set headers after
they are sent to the client
so we can have only one response per
request and in order to avoid that we
just go with return so always always
when you're setting up the condition
make sure that you go with return so
that way we are returning
from our callback function and one we
set up over here
and that way you'll avoid those errors
now of course in this case there's no
more code to read
so yeah it is a better practice if you
just put this return here
but you won't get the error since again
there's nothing after that
and one more thing that i would like to
mention normally
you're not going to set up a separate
one
just for the query yeah there might be
some
cases maybe there's some apis who do
that but normally again
you can just add it to where you're
getting a list
so basically if there's a query
beautiful you're maybe gonna sort that
data you're gonna filter it you're gonna
i don't know set up some pages or
whatever and
if no query string parameters are there
then you send back the whole product and
if you take a look
pretty much nothing stops me here from
just changing this
to api and products and the
functionality
is going to work where if there
are some query string parameters present
beautiful
notice how we're filtering our product
if not
then i always send back these products
anyway
and as you can see those are just copies
of the products that are coming from my
data
js hopefully that is clear and now let's
move on to our next topic
nice and once we're familiar with route
params
and query string let's really kick
things into gear and talk about
middleware in express.js express
middleware are functions
that execute during the request to the
server
each middleware function has access to
request
and response objects and when it comes
to functionality
literally sky is the limit in order to
hammer this home
i have prepared quite a few examples
where we cover middleware step by step
since in my opinion actual code examples
are far more helpful
than text based explanations before we
continue though let me just stress
something middleware is literally
everywhere in express you can even make
an argument that express apps are
nothing but a bunch of middleware
functions stuffed together
to make one nice express cake or dessert
if you are in that sort of thing and
since that is the case middleware
is not one of those topics you can just
skip or avoid
it is at the heart and soul of express
so
please don't dismiss it with that said
since you'll encounter it more than once
if you struggle with it in the beginning
don't panic the more examples you'll do
the better you will understand it now
let me start
by cleaning out my app.js and this is
going to be the case
where i will leave the code at least
some of the code
from the previous lecture so let me
delete
all the middle part and i'm just going
to leave express
we are instantiating our app and we're
listening on
port 5000 and let's just start by adding
a comment here
for your reference so there is a
incoming request
and so far we have been just sending
responses
right so what middleware does
it sits in between hence the name so
middle
where over here and then we pass
the response so the request comes in
we'll do something so we'll have access
to the both to the request and
response we'll do some kind of
functionality again
the most basic you can just cancel log
something
and then we'll send out the response and
again i know it
probably looks confusing at the moment
but trust me
the more examples you'll do the better
you'll understand
and let's start by simple scenario where
i have two routes i have the home route
and i have the about route and in those
routes
i would just want to log the method
that the user is using the url that the
user
is trying to access and for example a
date
and if you think that's silly there's
actually npm packages that do that
because
as your express apps grow bigger and
bigger
it is very useful to see those incoming
requests
in that manner so let's start here by
setting up
add.get again this is going to be my
home page
and for time being i have my callback
function
i pass it in and i just go with the res
dot
send and i send back the home
and i'll do the same thing here with my
about
so there's going to be two routes at the
moment home and about
unless it's just going to say about so
i'll save it and
it's not going to be surprised if i
navigate to localhost 5000 if i refresh
this is my home and this is my about
again something we have covered already
before
now here's the kicker if i go with
logger
and if i set up that functionality in
the
route forward homepage i'll also have to
do that in the about
so let me showcase that so i have
request object
and in there i have method i have url
and i'll simply set up the year because
i don't want to deal with javascript
types so let's go with method now that
one was
on request dot method property
then we also have the url so url here
and that is going to be a request url
property
like so and then like i said i'm going
to go with const and
i'll name this time but in order to make
it easier i'm actually going to get
a full year so i'm going to go with new
date and i'll invoke it
and i'll say get full year and invoke it
as well
and of course i'm sending back home yeah
that is nice but before i do anything i
would also want to
cancel console.log all three of them so
method url
as well as the time like so so i save it
and now
every time user is gonna hit this
resource
of course i'll see that in a console log
so there it is
if i go back to my home page
like so and if i refresh quite a few
times
there it is now in a console i can see
that the method
was get so the user was trying to get
the resource
and then the path was the homepage
that's my url
and then the year is 2021. okay
awesome but here's the problem if i want
to have the same functionality
in about what do i need to do right now
well again i need to copy and paste
now if i have 15 routes does that
sound like a reasonable approach of
course the answer is no
a better solution would be if we set up
a
function and in that function we have
all this logic
and then i can just attach it really
nearly to all my routes
and when i say well in italy it just
just means that for some routes
i maybe want to attach it and for some
maybe i don't
so here's the deal i can go above
both of my routes and i can just simply
say that there's going to be a function
by the name of and for time being
we're not going to look for any
parameters but yes there will be there
and then we just take all our
i believe four lines of code right and
we just
cut it out and pass it here okay
awesome and now of course where do we
attach
this function so we don't have to
duplicate our code
and the place is following where we have
the path
and then we have the callback function
now in between them we can
stuck a middleware so in this case as
you can see
i'm referencing the function please keep
that in mind
so i'm going to go with logger that's my
middleware function
but now there's the second question well
in the logger i'm accessing request
object right so how can i do that
because at the moment i'm not passing it
in well the good news
is that express passes it in
to our middleware function so in here i
just set up the reference for my
function
and express will do that behind the
scenes it will supply
the rec res and also a next
and you'll see in a second why we need
this
next function as well so again
we don't have to do anything we just
pass here the middleware
express supplies them but of course it's
our job to access them as parameters
and then set up our logic so for them
being i'm not going to do anything with
next
i will save and we should see something
where in the console i'm still going to
get
my log but the problem is going to be in
the browser
so if i navigate back and if i refresh
notice something where i have this
spinner
okay so what's happening here well
i successfully logged but
i didn't pass it on to the next
middleware so here's the deal
when you work with middleware you must
must must must
must pass it on to a next middleware
unless you're terminating the whole
cycle by sending back the response and
don't worry there's going to be examples
where we do that as well so for now just
keep in mind that
when you have a middleware where you set
up
some kind of logic unless you're sending
back to response yourself
for example since i have access to
response
i simply can go with res dot and
send and again i'm going to come up with
testing or whatever it doesn't really
matter what we send
back if we refresh notice it doesn't
really matter
if i try to access the home page since i
have my middleware
i'm actually sending back the testing
and this is why the middleware is so so
powerful because you can literally do
whatever you want over here
you can set up all kinds of cool logic
and
you have two options either you pass it
on to the
next middleware which in our case of
course are going to be
our methods our get methods or
you simply terminate the whole cycle and
you just say res dot send
and i'm sending back my own data so
let's not be brutal over here i will
actually
remove this line of code and if i want
to pass it on
to the next function meaning in our case
that is going to be my method app.get
i simply go with next and we have to
invoke it again
please keep that in mind there's going
to be more functionality later
in these middleware functions but you
always always
either you terminate so either you send
back your own response
or you pass it on to the next middleware
that is
very crucial so now if i go again to my
homepage
there it is i successfully navigate to
my homepage
i can clearly see that that is my
response and i also successfully
logged in my console the method the url
as well as the full year and now of
course
instead of adding this logic line by
line to
every request simply can go and i say
yep i would like to invoke the logger
here
as well so if we go to logo host 5000
and if we're brave enough and we
navigate to about
there it is now i have get request about
url as well as the full year
hopefully that gives you a good initial
understanding
how the middle works and now i can talk
about
more complicated topics beautiful we
are familiar with the middleware we have
our first middleware
function but there are two issues with
this current setup
first our appdress is getting somewhat
clunky
because i mean we have this logger then
we have the methods
it's definitely nicer if we have this
logger function
in a separate file it's just going to
keep our app.js
lean and in turn it's just going to make
it easier
for us to navigate and essentially
work with our application and the second
issue
what if i have 50 more routes
and i don't want to add this function
manually to all of them
wouldn't be nicer if there would be a
method
that essentially just adds my middleware
function to any route
and of course the answer is yes there is
such a function in fact we used it a few
videos ago
now let's start though by moving this
sucker into a separate file
so i'm gonna go to my not navbar app
sorry
this is what happens when you have a
bunch of
projects open meaning a bunch of folders
open
let me go here where i have my app.js
and i'm just going to create a new file
and this is still going to create it in
the final sorry so let me go here
and i'll create a new file and i'll call
this logger
js now if you really want you can add
the middleware there
in name as well but in my case i'm just
going to add
the name of my function then i'll cut it
out
and what's really cool that we know how
to export this right
so we have cons logger and then we go
with module
exports and we'll just set it equal to
our logger so now we have default export
that's our logger
so of course in the app js i simply need
to go with const
logger is equal and then i require it
i go with logger and
if i navigate to localhost 5000
i still should see in a console my log
and if you do
then everything is correct so that's the
first part
now the second how can i apply this
logger
to all my routes
so for example let me just copy and
paste
these ones and i'll say api
and then product
and then api and i don't know
not about maybe items again doesn't
really matter what you place here
i'm gonna go with products as well as
items again i can add them manually
but the more routes i'm going to have
well
the bigger issue this is going to become
right
because for every route i need to
manually add this logger
so a better solution is this one where i
select all of them
i just remove them like so now of course
if i go to any of these routes i'm not
going to have anything
in a console but there is a method by
the name of
app dot use and in that app.use
this is what we do we pass in the
middleware
so we simply go with logger and
once i save check it out now if i go to
about for example or if i go to home
or api and then products and hopefully
you get an idea
all the time you'll get this log in
console why well because app.use
will invoke this for any route
now please do keep in mind two things
first order matters here
if i'm gonna place this below app.get
and if i'm going to try to do that in a
home page
i'm not going to see anything in the
console why well because
i invoke my use only after get
and express everything goes in order so
if
app get is before the used one
the one that applies to all the routes
then yes
well first we'll hit the home route and
then we'll send back home
so there is no logger so that's why
you'll see
all the middleware functions all the
app.uses
at the top of the document so you'll
have your
middleware functions first and only then
you'll have
all your roth methods whether that's get
post
and you get an idea so that's the first
thing that i would like to mention
now the second thing that i would like
to mention is the fact that we can
add here a path so if i go to app.use
that's my method and instead of
providing only one argument
which in my case is the logger i can set
up a first one and that
is going to be path and i just need to
come up with a value
now in my case i'm going to type api and
you'll see
e in a second why so if you save
with an api you'll notice something
interesting where
this is going to be apply to both of
them
to the products as well as the items
so here's the deal once you apply this
path over here
basically it's gonna apply to any route
after this api so for example if i go
with api
and then some crazy one home about and
then products
all the time is going to keep on
applying this middleware so that's
something new right because previously
we worked only with a specific route so
forward slash or about or products here
in this case so of course these are
different
now when we add this path to use
then of course it's going to be applied
pretty much to
anything that comes after the path that
you provide over here
so in my case since i provided api and
of course it's going to go
for any path that's after that
now if you want to find out more info
about app.use i suggest
navigating to docs again we're looking
for api reference in our case that is
four
and if you take a look at the app.use
mounts
specified middleware function or
functions and we're gonna cover that
later as well at the specified path and
middleware function is executed when the
base of the request path
matches so this is going to be our base
and then whatever comes after will still
invoke
that middleware function and if
you omit the path then it's just going
to be applied
to all of your requests
so if i were to remove the path
now it's going to be applied to home
about api
product as well as api items
nice we're familiar with app.use
and now i want to make our example even
more interesting
by adding another middleware function
and in the process
we'll take a look at how we can execute
them in
that use what is the syntax in order to
add it as well as
what is the execution order and let's
start simply by creating a new
file and i'm going to call this
authorize
authorize dot js again
i'll zoom in just so you can see that is
the file name
and in here i'll just set up a function
similarly
to how we worked in the logger one so
i'm going to go with const
authorized or authorized it doesn't
really matter
now it's going to be a middleware
function so of course i know that i'll
have access to
rec res as well as next
and then in function body for time being
i'll just
invoke next and maybe i'll cancel log
i'll say
log and authorize like so
okay let's save that one remember that
we need to export it so
module exports and that's equal to
authorized awesome and then in the
app.js
i'll just copy and paste and i'll say
authorize like so and of course the file
name is also different it's not a logger
so we can go with authorize
and once i have this setup in place the
way we
execute multiple middleware functions in
app.use
we simply place them in the array so i'm
gonna go
with my logger first so logger
and then we're gonna go with authorize
and now once you navigate
to a localhost 5000 again any of them in
this case because notice
there is no path first in a console i'll
see this get
and then authorize and that's something
to keep in mind
where they will be executed in the order
so if we flip this one if i go with
authorized first
and then i go with logger then of course
in the console
i'll have the opposite order where i'm
going to have
authorized first and only then get
so that's something to keep in mind now
i'm going to go back to my previous
setup the logger
and then authorized and now let's take a
look at how we can
have the if condition in our middleware
function
now before we do anything let me just
stress something very very important
where this is just for demonstration
purposes
this is just an example and it's not how
we're going to
authorize users in our express
applications i just don't want to
overwhelm you from the get go
so i'm just going to show you simple
example using the query string but again
this is not this is not how we
authorized
users in our express applications and
with that said
i'm going to navigate back to my
authorized
middleware and in here i'm just going to
set up
a query string so i'm going to say if
the user
provides a query string in
my url then i'm good to go then
i'll send back the resource that the
user is requesting however
if the user doesn't provide the user
query
so query string parameter in the url
then i'll just send back 401 which just
stands for
unauthorized so let's start i'm going to
go with const and i'm going to be
looking for specific query string
i'm going to be looking for the user my
url parameter
and of course we know that it is
available in
rec dot query like so and i'm going to
say
if the user exists so if it's there with
any value it doesn't really matter
which one or i don't know maybe if you
want to make it more interesting
let's go if the user equals john okay
if that is the case then i'm going to go
with rec.user
and notice what i'm doing here i'm
actually adding
a property of user onto the rack object
and i'll show you why it's so powerful
so i'm going to go with recuser
that one is equal to whatever
i mean that could be a object for
example and i'll say here
name john again this is just for
demonstration purposes
and then id i don't know four or three
or whatever
so that's my user now i still need to
call next
if i won't do that then the whole setup
is gonna go bananas
so i'm gonna go with next here and now
of course
i just need to set up a response if
the user or whoever is visiting
doesn't provide the query string with
a key of user and then value on john
and in that case i'm going to go with my
else and i'll say
res and then let's add a status
and the 401 is going to be for
unauthorized
and let's just say send and simply
let's try to spell this sucker
unauthorized let's save that one
and now notice something interesting if
i'm going to go
for example to my home page or product
again any of the routes because there is
no path
in my app.used check it out i have
unauthorized and if i inspect and in the
network tab the same deal
i have 401 because i'm not authorized to
access this resource i have my
authorized
middleware whereas say you didn't
provide
the query stream parameter with a key
of user and more specifically you didn't
provide here
a value of john and since you didn't do
that
you cannot access the resource so now of
course if we change things around
and if i go with my question mark and if
i say
user equals john what do you know
i have my home why well because
now the condition is met and now we just
go to next
now why it is so powerful because in the
authorized we add
the user right so now of course not only
i can check for that query string
parameter but and also
access this info again this is just
demonstration normally what
you're going to do you'll check for the
json web token
and then if the token exists then we
communicate with database and actually
get the user
again this is coming up for time being
we're simply
hard coding these values so back in the
app.js
in any of the routes now i'm not going
to add in all of them
but just to showcase i'm gonna add for
example
in app items i'm gonna set up here a
log and i'll look for rec and user
and you'll notice something really cool
where if i leave this
query string parameter and if i go to
api
and items check it out first of all i
have the items and second
in console what do i see over here i see
that user
and that's why it's so powerful because
we can add our middleware
we can do some kind of functionality and
now basically i'm attaching this
to my request object so i have the
request object and now i'm attaching
this property here and now in any of my
routes now of course i
went with items but in any of my routes
i'll have
access to that user that's why
middleware
is so so crucial and that's why it is a
big part of
express applications because it truly
allows us to structure
our applications as lego blocks so we
have this piece of functionality we have
that piece of functionality
and when we combine them we have this
nice working express server now like i
already
previously mentioned middleware is all
over
express so just because we're done with
our initial introduction doesn't mean
that you're not going to see middleware
you'll see it all over the place but
just to complete
our initial introduction i want to
cover two common questions first
well if we have access right now to
app.use since we know how to use it
are we going to add the middleware in a
route
and actually the answer is yes because
imagine the scenario where
i don't want to apply this app.use
to all my routes for example i only want
to check for
authorized users in the api forward
slash items
what do i do well i simply add my
authorized middleware correct so now
i'll be able to access
all these routes without any issues but
the items want yes
i'll check for that silly query string
parameter and if you're wondering well
how we can pass
two middlewares if you would want in a
single route
same we just simply grab this
array so we copy and paste and now of
course
once i hit the items not only i will log
but i'll also authorize so
let's go back and i'm going to take a
look
where in this case everything is fine i
was
able to access the resource since i
provided the john so notice here name
john id number three i also have my
console log but
if i were to go to just my home page
like so i have the home and as you can
see
i don't get anything in a console i
don't get my logger
and i'm also not looking for any kind of
authorized user so that's the first
thing that i would like to cover
second what are our options
when it comes to middleware so far
we have covered the first one our own so
we can
always set up our own middleware now
our other two options are express so
express provides quite a few built in
middleware functions
again in this case we don't have to
worry about setting up the functionality
we just need to reference the docs to
see what options are provided
and then of course supply those values
and if you remember the
express app example we used app.use
and i said put the pin on this i'll
explain this a little bit later
if you want you can retype this but in
my case i'm just going to copy this
from the for express app.js
and if we copy and paste and if i place
it here notice
so this is a app.use method
now what argument the app.user is
expecting
it is expecting a middleware so in
express
we have a built in middleware by the
name of static
again somewhere in the express source
code
there is a code similar to this now of
course this is silly
they have way more complicated setup but
hopefully you get the gist
so there is a method and the only thing
this method is looking
for our public folder and then i already
told you that
it basically places all the contents of
public folder as our static assets so
they're publicly available so we already
covered that one
and now let me show you a simple example
of third-party
middleware now for a third-party malware
we'll have to install it
and one of the most popular ones i guess
for the login is this
morgan npm so again just go to your
search engine and type
morgan npm that is going to direct you
to
the docs i guess for the morgan
and as you can see in order to install
we just run
npm i morgan so that's how we install
the package
and the syntax is following where we
just go with
morgan we required a morgan and then we
just pass
in morgan tiny now of course this one
we need to set it up in our app.use
so this is really optional you don't
have to install it you don't have to run
it but
in order for me to hammer this home i
will do that
so let's go back i'll stop my server and
remember the command was
npm i and morgan
okay i installed this one so now of
course this package
is going to be in my dependencies like
so so not only i have expressed i also
have the morgan
and then in the app.js of course i'm
going to have to require it
so i'm going to go with const morgan and
that is equal to
require and then again i don't have to
provide the path
that's the module that i installed so i
go with morgan and then where i have
app.use
and go with app.use since i would want
to add to all my rows again
if you want to add for specific one
there's a different scenario but
if you want to add for all the routes
you just go with morgan
and then they basically give you
multiple options
and the tiny one is just going to
provide you the most essential
data and again if you want to reference
the docs please do so
so i'm going to go with morgan and now i
just need to spin up my app and i go
with
npm start now i will remove logger
and authorized from my api items
just because i think the terminal is
getting quite busy
and now of course once i navigate for
example
home page in a console i have get
i have forward slash now this is a
status code and then i have 2.8
milliseconds and that essentially just
signals how long it took for the server
to respond and if i were to go to
localhost and forward slash about now of
course
i'll see that i have get request i have
about
the 200 and now of course time is a
bit different as well so hopefully this
gives you a
general idea why middleware functions
are
so crucial and how powerful
they are and yes the bigger your express
applications
will get most likely the more
middleware functions you'll have
now they could be your own ones they
could be the
ones that provided by the express or
there's also going to be tons of
third-party
middleware functions not bad not bad we
have general understanding
how middleware works in express and now
i want to cover
rest of the http methods
so if you remember which seems like an
eternity ago
we covered the cycle the request message
as well as response
and in request well get was by default
performed by browser
but of course we have other methods as
well
and i also provided a second slide just
for these methods
and here you can see rest of the methods
so get
is again by default set up in a browser
and this allows us to read data
then we have post that is for inserting
data
so for example if we have some kind of
api orders route we can add an order so
user makes an order
and we just place that order on the
server
so of course eventually we would say
that in a database
then we have put if we want to update
data and of course we also have one
for deleting the data and before we
continue let me just mention something
we're not going to persist this data so
yes we'll have working examples of post
put and delete and hopefully i'll be
able to convey my message
in a manner where you understand the
general setup
for rest of the methods but since we
haven't covered how to connect to
database we won't persist this data
now i could have went the file system
route where essentially we are
persisting this data
by writing in a file but i thought it's
a waste of your time because
most likely you're going to work with
database anyway
so we might as well skip that part so
once we understand how we can connect to
the database
what are the methods by working with
data
in our database then we'll have a proper
example
where we're persisting in as well
and in order to kick things off i'm
going to navigate back to my address
again the previous example is going to
be in the file number 10
middleware options and again we're just
removing pretty much everything starting
with morgan so right after app and
all the way to app.listen
like so now there's not going to be a
home route however
i'm going to go with api and people now
why do i go with api people
because in the data file in the data js
where we had the product there's also
this one
people people is an array each person is
an object there's an id
as well as the name as you can see very
simple
example so with this data array
i want to showcase how we can read this
data how we can
add for example an extra person using
the post
how we can modify the person as well as
deleting one
and now of course i want to navigate to
app.js and first
i want to get my people so we simply
go with import i'll structure it right
away
and as a side note since i might make
some modifications
i'll use let in this case and i'll set
it equal to
require and then data hopefully this
part is clear
since we have covered it quite a few
times
and let's start with the one that we
already know
and that is going to be a get method so
i'm going to go with
app dot get like i said i'll purposely
set up my route
with a value of api and people
so that's going to be my path i'll say
api and then people
now this is a get method and simply will
return
this array so rec and res and again
i'm just going to go with res status
let's
hard code the value of 200 then let's
set up
our json and since i want to be kind to
my users i'll send back the object
i'll say that the success property is
true
so the request was successful and as far
as data property
well i'll set it equal to people so
let's navigate back
to our browser and we're going to go
with
5000 and of course cannot get
so this is going to be 404 if i just go
to the homepage
and instead i have a route for api
and i believe the whole path was people
like so
so we run that and now of course i have
zoomed in already massively here
so let me zoom out in my browser and we
should see
that we're getting our object the
success property is true
beautiful and then of course we have the
data property
and in there we have the people's array
so a bunch of people in here so of
course that is
our first http method
that is the get one where effectively we
read the data
and like i already have mentioned
probably 20
000 times that's the default method
that the browser performs so when you
set up a request with your browser you
right away use the http verb
by the name of get and that's why you
can
read the data all right so we're clear
with get method that's how we can read
there
however how we can add data onto the
server
so how we can insert data and in order
to do that
we need to use a post method but
it's not like i can somehow configure
browser
and start making post requests
unfortunately
that's not how it works that's why i
provided
a little bit of help now keep in mind
one thing
where after we set up a post method
effectively once we take a look at
two flavors of how we can set up post
request
we will install one more tool which is
going to be crucial
in our express server development
which is just going to allow us to test
everything much faster but since
for the post i do want to show you two
flavors that we can have
we'll use a little bit of static data
meaning
there's an app that i prepared but don't
worry it's not like you'll have to do
that each and every time to
test any of these methods and you'll see
what i'm talking about
in the following videos so first let's
start
by jogging our memory a bit we have
app.use
now what app.use is doing is just
applies the middleware to all our routes
correct and i also mentioned that we
have this option
of setting up a public folder
now we can call whatever we would want
but for
this methods example i prepared a
methods.public as you can see it is just
a folder
with index.html with javascript html
some css and once we navigate there of
course
i'll show you how the functionality
works so this is just prepared so we can
test those other methods meaning more
specifically the post method
because we cannot simply just perform a
post request
from the browser so first let's set up
that methods public as our public folder
that's step number one so let's set it
up as our static assets
and in order to do that i'm just going
to add first a comment
and i'll say assets and then i'm going
to go with
app.use again remember that is our
method
and this is going to be a built in
middleware
and the name is express static so i just
grab my
express instance i look for the method
of static
and if you remember we just need to
provide here a path
and instead of going public or static
like i showed you previously
i'm just going to go with forward slash
and then
methods and then public because
this is where i set up my static files
for these examples we invoke it
and now if we go to the home page we
shouldn't get
this error so once you invoke there it
is
we have a somewhat decent looking html
file
with two options we have this javascript
option
which we're going to cover second and
first one
is going to be a traditional form
example and again the reason why we do
that
is because you cannot simply just
configure
your browser to perform a
post request you either need to use a
tool which we're going to install by the
name
of postman or insomnia here's another
popular one
or you need to set up basically a
working application and if you take a
look
in the methods public we have this
working application
all right and once we have the basic
setup in place
now let's take a look at our two flavors
when
it comes to the post method
and i want you to navigate to index
html and in there you'll find pretty
typical index.html file with some
styling
with nav as well as deform
and in form we have two attributes we
have action one
as well as the method and as you can
clearly see the value for the method
is post and this action one just says
where we're going to send it and notice
now we have forward slash login
so that means that this url this path
is on our server but of course we know
that
in the app.js we're not handling that so
for the form there's going to be one
path and then for the second example
when we used
straight up javascript then of course
there's going to be a
different path for that so this is going
to be the url or path where we're
submitting the form
and inside of the form we have label we
have input
so basically we have name attribute for
this one we have the id
as well as the autocomplete so we'll
type in some kind of value
and then we'll send this to forward
slash login so localhost
and then forward slash login and of
course we also have a
submit button so now let's start
by taking a look what happens when we
simply submit
this form so go here type some kind of
gibberish
in my case i'm going to go with john
bravely
press enter and of course we do have
kind of
post login okay that's fine we're not
expecting anything anyway right
we know that there is no route that
handles
the post for the login
but what's really interesting here is
in the network tab of course i can see
my request in this case this is login
now this is 404 and again i'm going to
repeat this 20
000 times but check out the method so
method is not
get method is post and then we're going
to localhost 5000
and then forward slash login now what's
also
really interesting all the way in the
bottom
what do you see here you see this forum
data
and then we have key value pair we have
name
and john and if you remember
when we talked about http messages i
said that the body is optional
so for example when we're sending a get
request we're not sending a body
but when we're sending a post request
it's very crucial
so if i want to add something onto the
server
of course i want to get that data i mean
otherwise
how i'm going to know where to add to
the server
doesn't that make sense i hope it does
so
let's go back okay i see this name and i
see john
and if you're not familiar basically the
way it works
is whatever you provide here for the
name
is going to be a key so for example
if i'm going to set this up as testing
you'll see that now when we perform the
same request
the same post request again with the
same value different value it doesn't
really matter
now of course that key name is going to
be testing
so whatever value you provide over here
that is going to be the key
and of course the value is whatever
you're submitting
so in my case it's either peter
or john okay that's out of the way so
i'm going to change it back
to name and now we need to understand
something
where the request is coming in
but a we're not handling that and b
we don't have the middleware that
actually adds this data
that the form in this case
is sending to our request
so let's see how we can fix the first
one and we simply need to come up
with a round now in this case remember
we're dealing with post
this is not get and we're going to go
with
forward slash and then log in here
because of course
that's what i have in my form again we
go with rec
and res and technically we can come up
with
some kind of info i can say send and
i'm simply going to say post and that's
it
just so we can save time on typing again
let's navigate back
and in this case let's try susan
let's send it yeah i see the post so i
don't have the 400 anymore
or 404 so that's cool but
unfortunately i have no access at this
point to
whatever i'm being sent so unfortunately
i cannot access that susan
or john or whatever value so
unfortunately
i cannot add for example to my list
if i wanted to now how do we add it well
this is where the middleware comes in so
previously we covered
static assets with express static
in order to get the form data
we need to go with url and
coded middleware so i'll add here
parse form data and essentially this is
just going to parse that data and add
the values
to rec.body so where we have
a post request in the rec.body property
we'll find all the info and in order to
use this middleware surprise surprise
we're going to use app.use
and then we'll pass in express
and then url encoded and then you also
pass
in flag where you go with extended and
you set up false and if you're wondering
why are we adding this
extended false flag or you just want to
get more info
about this url in coded middleware
simply let's head back to the
documentation
in this case we're looking for the
express and notice here
i have express url encoded
this is a built-in middleware function
in express
it parses incoming requests with url
and coded payloads and it is based on
the
body parser so in the previous
versions of express you have to actually
install the body parser
now in this case you don't it already
comes built in
and as far as this extended this option
allows to choose between parsing url
encoded data with
query string library when false meaning
this is our case or the
qs library when true again i wouldn't
lose my sleep over this one
then the common approach is using this
extended and false
and once we can access it then we can do
some cool functionality
so first let's just scroll down a bit
where we have the login
and first i'm just going to start by
console logging rec
and body let's save that one and again
back to our browser again i'm going to
go
with susan this was 200 so everything
was successful and now of course in the
right dot body i also have a name and
the value is susan
so now we can start doing something with
this data
now i purposely set up two examples
one is going to be for form which of
course is this one and then
one is for javascript now with the
javascript example
this is where we'll actually manipulate
this people
array fourth time being with login this
is a separate issue we're just dealing
with the form
so we'll just try to make things
interesting
by checking for the name if the name is
provided
then we'll send back welcome and then
pass in that name
if the name is not provided so for
example if the user
is trying to submit the form empty for
example like
so we'll just send back 401 please
provide credentials again
please keep in mind this is just a
example and i'm fully aware
that we can check for empty values here
on the front end
again the goal of this example is to
show you how to handle this
on the server so i have wrecked that
body okay i can see that
in this case i have name but it is empty
so now of course let's set up our logic
first
i'm going to go with const name and that
one is equal
to rec that body so i'm destructuring
my name property and i'll just check if
the name exists
whatever the value that could be b
that could be bobby lee not could be
again
taco burrito whatever you want and as
you can see i'm getting quite hungry
so let's go with return res dot
status then let's set up a
200 which just says that
we were successful and we're gonna go
with send
and we'll set up a template string
welcome
and i'm just going to access my name
so if there's some value i'll send back
200
and i'll say welcome whatever is the
value if not
well here we're going to go with res
and let's just add status here and again
just for kicks
i'm going to go with 401 and we're going
to go with
send and of course let's say please
provide and credentials
like so let's save this one and now we
should
truly see how it works in the action
now i'll leave i guess the tab for now
and let's just try to submit so for
example if
i submit with empty values
i'm going to say please provide
credentials and as far as my login it is
401
that's what the server is sending back
however if i type in some kind of value
for example anna comes to mind i have
welcome
and anna so that's our first flavor when
it comes to post request
where we use the form and again this is
just front end
where we come up with an action and
since this index.html is on the same
server
we simply go with forward slash and
login
of course if your front-end application
is separate from your server then you're
going to provide a full path
where the server is hosted so basically
a full domain and then we go with method
post
now this is technically a front-end part
but it is crucial that we understand it
so then we perform of course a post
request we hit our url
so in this case we hit our forward slash
login
and this is the part where we handle
that on a server
in order to get that data whatever
we are being sent we need to use a
middleware
this one is built into express so again
we simply just need to use
app.use which is going to apply this
middleware
to all our incoming requests
and then we just pass an extended false
flag
and the moment we do that indirect.body
will have access to our form values so
whatever
is set up here as a value that is going
to be our key
and whatever is passed into our form
well of course that is going to be the
actual value that we're getting
so if i go here with name i'm gonna see
either susan
anna or whatever user provides
now like i already previously mentioned
this is just for demonstration
this is just so we have a bit more
interesting example
e instead of just sending back the name
so hopefully this part is clear and now
we can focus
on our second flavor where we use
javascript
to send the request all right
and once we have the form set up out of
the way
now let's take a look at the javascript
option before we do though
there's one more thing that i would like
to mention
if you take a look at the headers you'll
notice
something interesting where we have a
content type for the request header and
of course
this is going to be application and then
we have this
form url encoded and the reason why i'm
showing that because of course
for javascript it is going to be a bit
different
so just keep this one for your reference
now let's navigate back to our
static files basically to our front end
and now let's take a look at the
javascript approach
and interestingly here where i have the
javascript
i do have the form keep in mind we'll
still handle this form but
in this case it's going to be done
strictly using javascript
and we'll use javascript to send our
http
requests and that is very very crucial
that is going to be the difference where
instead of form now i'll be sending that
request using javascript
and of course the content type will be
different that's why i
showed you the form example but what
you'll also notice that
right away we have our list and if you
don't believe me you can double check
in data we have john peter susan anna
and
emma so what's happening well let's go
to
javascript html this is where we have
our frontend logic
and again let's take a look at our index
html
a little bit of css nav
and then we have the form now in this
case i don't have the action
and i don't have the method okay
interesting
so i have name attribute it still has a
value of name
so i should expect probably
that this is going to be the value
that's coming in with
my request then i have a little bit of
form alert
this is where we'll display a little bit
of functionality as well as the result
now if you're not familiar there's a
package called axios
which essentially just makes it easier
to set up http
requests so instead of using the
built-in fetch
which i could have used i think axios
provides a cleaner api
and better error messages and
since i don't want to spend three hours
on explaining
all this code i simply went
with axios and the way i set it up i
just set up the cdn link so this just
gets me the axios library
and then the moment i install it of
course i have axios
in my front-end project please keep that
in mind those are two separate things
this is a front-end project and in order
not to confuse you more i just
set up a few script tags instead of
going with
a separate javascript font so
as you can see here i'm selecting the
result so that is my div
and i have this fetch people
so that is the function that fetches
people from my server now notice the
path
it is api and people why
well because in my server
i have also api people so this is for
get requests
that's the default one however in this
case we're not doing that with a browser
we're doing with javascript so axios
has the method by the name of surprise
surprise get
that just means that on the front end
we're performing
a get request to the same server that's
why we go
forward slash api and then people so
make sure these urls
match so if these paths won't match then
you'll have
an error and to showcase that if i go
with
p poles then if you navigate to the
front end and if you refresh
can't fetch data so we try to fetch
people from our server then we do a
little bit of logic
and this is just vanilla.js not going to
cover it basically we tear it over
and then we just set up a nice heading
5s and all that
and then we invoke the function but
if there is an error we'll look for the
error property
now in this case i'm not the structuring
it i'm actually not using it i just say
can't fetch data so that's step number
one
now the second one is of course using
the form
so then i select the submit button i
select the form
i also select the alert because we will
display
an alert if the value is empty and again
let me repeat i'm fully aware that we
can check for that
in the front end i just wanted to
showcase
the server setup and then notice
something interesting
where i have this try and catch block
in my functionality so the moment the
user
is submitting the form of course i
invoke my callback function
it is a sync because for the actuators i
can wait for response
and notice this one so i have axios and
again
surprise surprise the method name is
post why
because we are sending a post request
and this is just an axiorys thing but
again
we provide the value in this case the
url value is
api and people so something that we're
not handling yet
on our server and this is the value
so again this is just axio syntax where
in order to set up whatever data you're
sending
you just pass it as a second argument
and you set it up as a key value pair
now what's really cool that would axios
they set up all the content types and
all that good stuff for you
so again you just save a little bit of
time now
if there is an error in our case that is
going to be if
we're trying to submit something and in
fact there's no value
meaning we just try to submit empty form
value
then we will display the error message
and again this is really cool because
axiorys just provides a very useful
error api unlike the fetch where you
really need to
jump through the hoops so let me save it
back to people
so we can see of course all the people
that we have in our array currently
and then of course we'll focus on this
post one
so as you can see i get the input value
and i just passed it in
as a name property awesome
so now back in our app js of course we
need to handle it
and please keep in mind one thing where
app dot
post and then api
and people is not the same as api get
and api people even though the url is
the same
methods are different and that goes for
all the methods we're going to use
whether you're talking about put delete
or whatever so
just because the urls are the same
doesn't mean
that they mean the same thing no the
method is different
here i'm just reading the data i'm
reading data from
api people here i'm actually trying to
add data and again we're going to go
with wreck
and res and let's just go with
some simple response now for time being
i'm just going to say that my response
is going to be 201
now that's the response that we send
back if we are performing
a post request and we are successful
so i'll just say res that status
201 and for time being let's just say
send
and i'm just gonna say success and of
course now what i would want
is to navigate back to my javascript one
hour fresh i'm getting all my people and
now let's try it out
so i'm gonna send this one so i sent
again here nothing changed but if i take
a look at
my network tab i should see and by the
way
sorry i'll have to do that one more time
let's go with i don't know
susan here let's try to submit
and there it is now of course i have api
people
and 201 so that's the response that i'm
getting
on my front end so let's bravely click
on this one
and we can see that the request url
is api people okay the
method was post now the response was 201
so it was successfully created and now
check it out
when we look at the request headers
of course we have application json
so on our front end we do need to add
this content type
when we are sending the data now again
what's really cool about axios
it adds for us but in general you need
to keep that
in mind and there it is again we have
this request
payload and the name is equal to susan
so whatever i'm going to pass it in if
i'm going to send it empty
then i'm going to still have the key
name and the value
will be empty now the gotcha here is
even though we're handling
a form submissions we're not handling
the json data so yes we know how we can
send back the json data
but we're not handling the incoming json
data
and this is where another middleware
comes into play
so i'm going to say parse json here
and we simply need to go again with
app.use
and we go with express and json now in
this case i'm not going to go to
documentation
if you want you can do that in my case i
will try to save us a little bit of time
and we'll skip that and here we have api
people
and now similarly to our login
we have access to the form data that is
being sent
with javascript in the rec dot body
previously before this was added no
we have no access yes when it comes to
form
that was one setup now when it comes to
straight up http requests for example in
this case sent with javascript
no we had no access so we were getting a
json
and now we added a specific middleware
that handles that so of course in this
case now
we can set up more logic correct we can
say that we're looking for the name
and if the name is provided then awesome
then i'm going to send back that new
person that was created
so we can add it to our front end and
again this is the case where
we're not persisting this data anywhere
later we'll learn how to do that
for now i already have the code that
adds it to
our front end however if the user tries
to submit
without any values well then there's
going to be
a error message so in the api people
in the post method let's set up our
logic
where i'm going to go with const name is
equal to
rec.body the middleware makes it
possible now
and then i'm going to say if the name is
not provided
well then i'm going to send back the 400
then i'm going to say
please provide name value so there's
going to be a
error message so i'll say here if and
exclamation point and if the name is not
provided then let's go to return
res dot status and
for the request error we go with 400
that's the status code and then let's go
again with json
and in this case we're gonna go with
success
now this success will be false and then
we're
going to go with message again i would
suggest using the same properties
because of course i'm handling them
on the front end as well so in here i'll
say please
provide name value like so
now if the value is provided whatever it
is
then of course we can send back
res.status 201.
hey guys it's john from the future with
a small update
as you'll see in a second while i was
recording i
forgot to change the methods so instead
of writing json i just left it as send
and while we can get away with it in
this example normally you
always want to use json instead so make
sure
you change your method from send to
json and in this case let's just
set up a proper object we'll say success
is true
so now we're being successful and i'm
just gonna send
back that person now i'm going to set it
up with
person key and the value will be named
whatever i'm getting again please use
the same ones if you want to have
a same result now let's navigate back we
can refresh
just so we are all on the same page
and if we type susan now we should see
another susan added to our list and then
again we can go with
john and i'm just being lazy on coming
up with original names
and as you can see every time we add
value in our form we're being successful
we're actually getting back this value
from our server
and then we dynamically added to our
front end and again the reason why we're
doing this way
is because we're not persisting this
data so that's why
the setup is following later of course
we'll learn how to persist this
in a database as well and if i try to
submit
with empty value check it out now of
course
i have people and this one is what 400
right
notice here and it says please provide
name value now if you want to do a bit
of
console logging you're welcome to do
that on the front end
if for example you are iffy about the
syntax
but just to let you know when we talk
about axios here
effectively we're getting back the whole
thing so
when we perform a request http request
with axiorys we're actually getting back
a
giant object now what we're interested
in that object is a data property so
that's the response that
is coming back from the server and then
in here as you can see i set up a
heading 5 with data.person
so that's the person that we're sending
back from
our server now if for example there is
an
error we go with error response again
data property
because that's where the useful
information sits because the
object of course is giant with lots of
useful information but
as far as what we're sending back it is
sending in data
and then message now i'm looking for the
message property
of course here because i set up a
message property
on the server hopefully it is clear this
is
our second flavor where effectively
we perform a post request from the
application
and of course in that case we do need to
provide content type as well as the data
and next video we'll install and cover
some basic setup for a
very useful tool that is going to save
us
a lot of trouble when we work with post
delete as well as put methods
all right so at this point we're
familiar with
two ways how we can send a post request
so we covered how we can do that using
the form as well as
straight up http request in our case
using javascript however there's a
major problem in our current setup and
the problem here is following
if we need to create a frontend to test
something
for every route as you can see
i mean our development is going to be
extremely slow
because we can clearly see that it's
probably going to take us
way longer just to set up a front end
than setting up just one simple route so
every time i create a route i'm probably
going to spend i don't know five
six times more on setting up the front
end
where i can test this route and of
course there has to be a better option
and that better option
is a tool called postman and postman is
just
awesome for quickly testing our apis
so at this point i strongly suggest that
you navigate
to postman.com again it's a free tool so
you're not going to have to pay anything
but for mainer of the course yes we'll
use this
so if you're kind of iffy about
installing something new
this is something that is required so
navigate to
postman.com and then they'll try to
sign you up you don't have to do that
just keep scrolling down
keep scrolling down and all the way in
the bottom
you'll see this download app option go
here
and they'll right away detect which
operating system you're using of course
in my case that is mac so download the
application
once it's on my computer i'm going to
navigate back to the desktop i'm going
to go to downloads
i'll crack it open then of course i'll
just move it to
my applications like so and i already
had one on my computer but
i removed it so we can do these steps
together
then this is the application let me zoom
in
that's the postman so just click on it
and then it's going to spin up the app
and eventually you'll hit the dashboard
and i'm not going to spend half an hour
on this setup
but of course as we're progressing we
the course
as we're progressing with our examples
we will cover more features
that this app provides and basically
here
you'll have all your requests that you
can actually group
in collections and again that's
something that we'll cover
a bit later and this is where we can
make those requests
and in order to create a new request we
just click on this plus sign
and check it out so at the moment i have
untitled a request
in here i need to enter the url and i
can send
my request not orders here on left hand
side
what do i have i have get but what's
really cool
i have all these methods available as
well
so first let's test out the get route
and then we'll see how we can deal with
post route
as well now as far as our url what it is
well it is localhost 5000
and of course the full url is
api and people now this is for the post
as well as the get
and since we're testing it of course
that's why we have a method
with the value of get so let's go here
local
host and then five thousand
then forward slash api and people
and the moment i click send check it out
what do i see here in the bottom i see
my object the success value is true
and there i have my data so as you can
see the moment
i create my route for example post route
or put route
or whatever i can test it immediately
i can test it within a few seconds
instead of building the whole front end
just so i can test one route
and of course once we have covered get
route now let's see how we can deal with
a post route
so we need to change the method of
course now
the url still stays the same because i
do have a route for the post
as you can see and in here what i'm
looking for
i'm looking for the name in the body
and how do we construct a post request
in a postman
well we do that in a following way first
we go to the body
and we look for raw and instead of text
i go with json because i'm going to be
sending
a json data so this is not the case
where
we're working with the forms in this
case we're sending
a json data and what you'll notice
something really interesting in headers
right away
there's going to be a content type so
let's see
let's set up first the body and you'll
see how it gets added
so we're gonna go here with a name again
this is what i'm looking for that's why
i need to pass it and then
i'm gonna set up some kind of value now
since i'm setting up the json please
remember that we need to use
double quotation marks so i'm going to
go here with john
and if you paid attention previously we
had
eight headers and now we have nine so
i'm gonna go back
and there it is now i have content type
application
json so that's really cool we don't have
to do anything
the header gets added for us and of
course the moment i click
send check it out now i have
success true and person john why do i
have that well
because that is my response i have
success true and
of course whatever name i received i
just sent it back so now of course let's
quickly test out our 400
as well so i'm going to navigate back
and then in the body
i'm just going to send a empty string or
you can remove
name altogether that's really up to you
and now of course i have
400 bad requests and
success is false and of course i can see
the message
so as you can see we can test it within
seconds
and to really hammer this home why don't
we create
another post route and quickly set up
some kind of response
and let's test it out in our postman as
well
so i'm going to go in between the post
and
login i'm just going to go with app.post
and the route is going to be following
i'm going to go with path
of api people people
and i'm going to add a postman here or
you know what let's do it this way
let's go postman and then
people like so and then as far as the
callback function
again we get rec res
and then in the body again i'm going to
be looking
for the name property so i want to get
that name
so i'm going to say that i'm expecting
it we'll go with
name rec dot body again if you want to
cancel log the body
you can do so but i think we have done
that quite a few times so i'm going to
omit that
then i'll copy and paste my response
so again if the name is not provided
meaning if the property is not there or
if it's just empty
i'm sending back to 400 however if i'm
successful
then i'm just going to take my array
i'll add that extra person
and i'll send it back now i'm not going
to add the id
i'll leave that one blank because
eventually database will do that for us
so
i don't really see the point of doing
that manually
so i'm going to go back to my api
postman people
and then again this is my error response
and now let's copy
and paste our status and then instead of
sending
that one person we created why don't we
do this
why don't we go with data and then of
course the
array name is people and now as you can
see i'm using the spread operator
and i'm just going to add that one
single person
so i'll save now of course we do need to
change the route
so it's not going to be api it's going
to be postman
and then people like so now let's add
for example peter
and the moment i click send there it is
i have my success true and as far as
data
all the way somewhere should be peter as
well
so again we just grabbed that peter and
then we added
to our array hopefully this makes sense
and now of course we can work on
other http methods as well all right and
once we're familiar
with postman now let's work on the other
two methods
so now we're gonna be working on put
method
as well as the delete so i'm gonna
scroll down
and below the post login route
i'm gonna go with app and then put now
again this method is for editing
the data so put method is for
update and again the convention
is following where if we have a list
for example in this case that would be
api and orders
if we want to edit or delete
we go with our route parameter
where effectively we set up a route for
api orders and then we go with colon
id and this is going to get me that one
specific item
now please keep in mind one thing where
this
is a convention so technically there are
multiple
other ways how you can set it up but
there's a reason why that convention
exists and that's why throughout the
course we'll stick
with this convention i'll cover the
official name of this convention a
little bit later
as well as a bit more details about it
for now i just quickly want to cover
both of the methods so i'm going to
navigate back i have my put method
that is for modifying the data and in
our case
what is the url for the whole list
because that is api people so this was
just for testing correct and then we go
with
api forward slash and then we go with
people
and then of course i also want to add
that id
so this is going to get me that one
specific item
and again the reason why we're doing
that because when we'll send
our put or delete requests
we'll send to a specific path so this is
going to be that
one item and if that item exists
then in the body there's going to be
data to update
or in the case of delete there's going
to be nothing in the body
we'll just remove that item and you'll
see how it works
in a second so please be patient so
we're going to go with people
and then remember again we have route
params
and in this case i'm not going to call
this person id i'm just going to say id
just remember that we can call it
technically whatever we would want
and now in this case there's two things
that i'm looking for first
i want to get the value here in the
params and remember
we access that using the rec params and
the second thing
when it comes to update when it comes to
the put request
i'm also going to send something in the
body why well because
if i'm updating for example if i'm
changing the name
from peter to susan or whatever of
course i
also need to supply this value so you
need to understand that there's
two sides of this request not only
we're looking for that specific item
that's why we use the params
that's why i specifically say hey i
would like to get
the item number one or item number two i
also need to supply this value
because otherwise what's the point of
updating something
so let's access both of those things
let's say that i'm gonna get
the id from rec params
so this is going to tell me which item
and then the second thing
since of course i want to update that
item i need that value as well
correct so we're going to go here with
const
and i'm going to be again looking for
the name and we'll say reg dot
body and that's it that should do it
so these are the two values that we're
gonna get from our question
and just to make things interesting i
will console log them right now
so i'm gonna go back to the postman
and remember we need to change the url
it's not gonna be
api postman in this case it is going to
be people
and now you can select any of the ids
whether that's one all the way up to the
five
so we go here with one and then as far
as the value
what is the value for the first one it
is john so kind of makes sense if i'm
updating
that i go with peter correct so we have
put request
we have api and then people and then
check it out the moment we
send it now of course the request is
hanging don't worry about that
but in a console we should get
api people and then the id
and of course the reason why i don't see
anything because i was smart enough and
i didn't console log anything
so i'm gonna go back with id name and
you know what for timing let me just
send back
hello world okay let's go here
let's actually send it one more time as
you can see
could not get the response that was the
error this time in this case
i am getting hello world so that worked
beautifully
and as you can see the status code is
200 as well
and then in the console i have one
and i have the repeater so this is going
to be the id
and of course this is going to be the
value now if i'll change it of course if
i'll say number two and if i'll send it
again
i get back my response and now the value
for the id is due hopefully this makes
sense
so now of course at this point we need
to set up the logic again
we are going to set up the logic with
our local data
with our people array eventually in
next examples we'll work actually with
database
but the main idea is exactly the same
where
from the postman while we're testing
we're sending
the id in the url basically we add that
url parameter
and then in the body we'll send the
value
so that part won't change just the
functionality in here
and as far as this functionality well
since we have
a simple javascript array first i would
just want to
get the person with that id if the
person doesn't exist
then i'll send back the error response
and if the id does exist then i'll just
change the value
now i'm not going to be looking for the
error message if
the value is not provided we're going to
cover that once actually we work with
database
i think is just going to be at the
moment waste
of our time so let's do it people
i'm going to remove both of these
console logs hopefully you understand
how we supply both values in the postman
and i'm going to start by creating a
person
and this is going to be equal to people
dot find
again i have the array so i have access
to all the array methods
and then if the person id matches
to my params id then of course i'm going
to get the person
now let me check in the data notice
i still have it as a number so i'll have
to change the type as well
so i'll say if person id is equal to a
number
and i'll pass in the id that i'm getting
from my params
whether that's one five or maybe it's
going to be id that doesn't make sense
all right good and if the person doesn't
exist
well then i'll send back the response
now again in order to save us a little
bit of time i'll scroll up
and i'll look for any of my error
messages
since i just want to copy and paste and
change some values around
so in this case i'm going to look for
this name if it doesn't exist
then of course we have the error and in
our case of course we just need to
change it around
if the person doesn't exist so if we
cannot find that
in the array then we're sending back 404
remember that was the status code if we
cannot find the resource
and as far as the response we have
success
and of course it's going to be false and
now let's go with message
and in the message we're going to use a
template string we'll say
no person with id
and then i'm just going to pass in the
id so that's the first
response if of course the person doesn't
exist
so if in the primes we enter for example
value six
we know that we have only one to five or
abc
now the second thing if the person
doesn't exist now of course i just want
to iterate
over the array and for
that specific person for the person
whose id
matches my params value i'll change
the name since i'm expecting that one to
be in the body again
we're not going to deal with this error
for now we'll do that once we work with
database
and we're going to go with new people
new people here
and we'll say people map so i'm
iterating
over my array again i'll reference
each and every person as a person and
i'll say
if person id matches
to that one i have in params
so number id again then i'm going to say
person name
since that is the only other property i
have
is equal to my name now where i'm
getting the name
because i'm getting it from the body so
if the id of the person matches to that
one
in the params then please change the
name that i can find
in the body if not then simply return
a person return a person
and now of course all the way in the
bottom i'm going to go with
res dot status and then
we're sending back 200 since the request
was successful
as far as the json we go with success or
sorry not super we're gonna go with
success
true and then as far as data well now
i'm sending back the new people
so let's go back at this point i have
two
so let me change it back to 1 because i
know for sure
the first value was john so again
the path is api people
and then id of 1 and i just want to
change it
from john to peter so let me double
check in data
this should be john uh it's a good thing
i didn't go
with the idf2 since that one is already
peter
so now let me send it and check it out
now i have success true and data
of course is my array and instead of
name being john for the person number
one
now the name is peter and of course if
i'll do the same
thing for example for the person number
three
again we send it back of course now i
have three peters because i just keep
changing those values again we're not
persisting that data
but while we're making requests you can
clearly see
how we are modifying this data and we do
that
using http put method
and then of course the path is
api people and then whatever the id and
again
the whole reason why is that happening
because on our server
we are handling that all right and the
last method
i would like to cover is a delete method
so below the put method below the modify
option i'm going to go with app and the
method name is delete
again the convention if you have a list
is going with a list url
and then add that specific id because
the setup is going to be extremely
similar to a put one now the only
difference is going to be that of course
in this case
when we're deleting we're not expecting
anything in the body
the user hits the url for example api
people
and then one we just remove that sucker
from our list that's it so let's go down
where we have app delete and again the
path
is following where we go with api and
then
people and again let me stress one more
time
something where these routes are
different
when we talk about app.get and api
people
when we talk about app.post and api
people
or even if we talk about app.put
and app.delete just because the path is
the same since the method is different
these are different requests that is
crucial
please don't think that just because you
have a different method
you have to set up a whole new path no
you can have the same value for the path
if the method is different
that is totally different request so
let's go here again with our callback
function we should already be
comfortable with this one
we have rack and res and in this case
i'm not gonna the structure out the id
from the prompts i just want to showcase
that we also have this option
of accessing the params directly so
first
again i want to look for the person then
we'll send back
this response and yes oftentimes put and
delete are going to be extremely similar
and then if the person does exist
then of course i'll just filter out the
array and remove that person
from the array since again the whole
point of this request
is to remove that person from the array
so in this case you can actually copy
and paste and
i know that some of you might find that
annoying
but at the same time we do need to speed
this up and start working
with a database so hopefully you can
forgive me
i'm just gonna grab everything starting
with the person
all the way until the end of our error
response d404
let's scroll down copy and paste and
this is what we're trying to do
so i'm trying to find a person whose id
matches that in the params and of course
in this case
i haven't destructured out the id right
so i just need to change this around
where i go with rack
and then params and the id
again the setup is exactly the same the
difference is that
i'm directly accessing the params
object and if the person doesn't exist
then we send back d404 so
let's try this response i'm gonna
go back to my postman again the api
is people but we need to change the
method right
so now i would want to delete and since
i want to test out the error
and as a sign up you can send the body
doesn't really matter
we're not handling that on server anyway
so it's
really irrelevant but since i want to
test out the error
i'm going to go with abc so again the
path
is localhost api people and then abc
and if everything is correct i should
see the error
and of course there is but something
tells me that this
is a different error so let's go back
and check it out
and of course the issue is following
notice here
in the json how i'm accessing the id now
of course i haven't destructured it
right
in this case i went with rec params and
then the id
so i'm going to go with rack params and
the id
let's save it and let's try one more
time again i'm looking for a person
whose id doesn't exist so
i'm gonna get the error and there it is
i have
success false and as far as the message
no person with id of abc
so i was looking for the person with id
that's not in my array so that's why of
course
i got back the error response so now i'm
gonna
go back to our app delete request
and here i just want to filter out the
array and the way we're going to do that
i'm going to go with const new people
is equal to people.filter
that's my array and i'm just filtering
it i'll pass
in my callback function and i'll
reference
each object with the person parameter
and i'll just say if person id
does not match the id found in rec dot
params
then return that person if it does match
then it's not going to be included
that's why we go with exclamation point
and remember that we still get our id
as a string so we must do the number one
first
and then only we go with params and the
id
so that's our new array without that
specific
person whose id matched the one
in params so now of course let's just go
with our return
return res dot status
here and this is going to be 200 of
course
and i'm going to go with json and we'll
set up our object
success is true and i'll send back
the new people array so we're going to
go with data
and then new people let's save it
and let me test that out e in the
postman
where of course now i'm gonna go with id
that
is in the array and that's gonna be
number one
so if i send notice how it is irrelevant
if i send body again because i'm not
handling that
on the server anyway but if i take a
look at my data
well the person with id number one
john is missing why well because his id
matched to the one
that i passed in the primes so now of
course
he was removed from the array so if i'll
go with five
same deal now the john is back here
because again we're not persisting data
but the person with id of five
has been removed from the array
hopefully this gives you a good
understanding how we use
other methods as well not just get and
why we go with postman instead of
setting up the front-end
but before we cover router in express
let me just stress something
that yes while we're developing our
server
of course we'll use postman because you
can clearly see
how much faster it is i set up the route
and i quickly tested otherwise if i
would have to build a front end for
every route that i'm creating i mean the
process
would be just very very long but
at the end of the day when you set up
the api the expectation is that
there is going to be someone who's using
that data
now that could be on your own server so
for example if you're building a
full stack application with mern that's
one of the options
that could be decoupled application
remember how i showed you
a example where i have the api on my
server
but then there is a react application
that uses it
it doesn't mean that you have to build
that front-end application yourself
just be mindful that the whole idea of
setting up the api
is that someone is going to be using
that data
that's it that's all i want to say and
now of course we can talk about
router in express all right
i think we're moving along quite nicely
but as you can see the moment we're
starting to have
more routes and more functionality
we have another issue and that issue of
course is the fact that
our app.js is getting quite busy
and technically we don't even have that
many routes
so what is the solution well the
solution is
using express router where we can
group those routes together and then as
far as the functionality
and actually set them up as separate
controllers
now eventually in the next example when
we work with database
i'll cover again the common setup
which is called mvc basically it is a
pattern
it's not a rule but it is a nicely used
pattern
when you're setting up the api but we
are missing the model part
in the mvc pattern because we haven't
connected the database so
i'll just leave it at that just please
keep in mind whatever i'm about to show
you in this video
and in the next yes it is a pretty
common convention and pattern
so i also suggest sticking to that
now also i want to mention that in this
video
we will do a bit of copy and pasting
meaning we'll have to refactor the code
because i think this is a perfect
example for us
to set up the router where we already
have some code
so you can clearly see the benefits of
setting up the router instead of
me coming up with some empty routes and
then saying that yes
that is the best pattern so with that
said
first where we have the request the post
request
for api postman people i want you to
change this around a little bit
so as you can see i keep going back and
forth in this case i want to go with api
people and then let's just say postman
again it doesn't really matter we're not
going to make requests anymore from the
postman
in these examples anyway this is just
about our
code structure and then once we change
this around
i also want to move this login up just
so it's a bit clearer what we're doing
so take this login route and keep moving
moving moving moving
and just place it on top of your routes
and there it is now of course i have my
login
and now notice the pattern whereas
i have one route for the login but then
rest of them
i have api people api people
api people postman api people id
and hopefully you get the gist again i
have api people id
so wouldn't it be nicer if
i could somehow group all the api people
and also add one for the login
but basically in a separate file and the
way we can do that
is by setting up the router now again
common convention
is just creating another folder
so i just want to make sure that i'm
actually doing that in the express
tutorial
let's create a new folder and common
convention is calling this
route and then you just come up with
whatever name you want
now in my case i'm gonna go off for the
login
because we're just gonna imagine that
maybe there's going to be one for
register
one for logout or whatever and then
there's going to be one
40 people so that's going to be for my
api
and people so let's set up these two
files i will zoom in massively
just so you don't think that i'm
cheating so let's go here with alt
js this is where i'll place my login one
and also right away set up
my people people
just okay awesome i'll start working
in people.js because it's going to be a
bit interesting and then we'll do the
same thing
in the auth as well and the way we set
this up
we simply start by requiring the express
so we go here express require and of
course
the module name is express and then
instead of setting up the app
we go with router and we explicitly get
the router from the express
so this is going to be a router instance
that takes care of the routing instead
of the app
so we're not going to do the routing
anymore in our app.js
well sort of we will we'll use the
middleware but
as far as the specific urls we'll handle
that
in this routes people file and the way
we set up the router we go with
router and that one is equal to like i
said
express dot and then we go with capital
letter
router and then we invoke it awesome
that's a great start we can save this
sucker
and now i want you to go back to app.js
and don't grab the login that's why i
set it up
separately above all the routes but grab
all of the ones with api and people
so take these suckers here all the way
up to delete basically stop at listen
cut it out and then copy and paste in
people
like so okay great so now of course i
have
all my routes here now our next step
is actually changing from app
to router because i want the router
to handle the routing so in my case i'm
going to select
all of my apps like so so i'm just doing
that with command d
in the visual studio code and
at this point i should have multiple
cursors like so
and i'll set up my router and now
all the way in the bottom i want to go
with
module not exports and of course
at the moment i'm exporting my router
and then once we export a router of
course
in the app.js i want to set up a
app.use where i'll say yes for the path
that starts with api and people
i want to use my people router
and the way it's going to look like
we're going to go back
and at this point we have people here
and as a side note
actually we need to cut it out but we're
not going to use it here as well
eventually the setup is going to be
different so for now
yes please cut it out and copy and paste
in people but since we'll be setting up
the controls we'll have to do that
one more time anyway so i guess i'm
going to go below the router
i'm going to look for my people
otherwise my functionality
won't make sense and in this case
remember
we are sitting already in routes so i
need to go
two levels up and i still need to look
for my data
correct so now of course our
functionality
should work hopefully we don't have some
weird bugs
and then like i said in the app jess now
of course i would want to use my
app.use so i'm going to go below
express json and i'm going to say
app.use and now i need to set up that
base route
now what is my base route here well it
is
api and people correct because
this is just my route and then in some
cases i have the postman
or i have the id that's it
but the base stays the same okay awesome
so we provide this path
we say api and then people
and now i want to set up that router and
of course
in order to set up the router i need to
import it
and you can call it people router you
can just call it people
again that is really up to you i'm just
going to say people
is equal and now we need to require it
and remember we have a folder by the
name of what
routes and then we also have people file
okay awesome we require our router
here correct so that's our router
and we're exporting awesome so we get
the people
and like i said with use we can use the
path
if we want so this is not going to be
applied to all of them
this is only going to be applied to the
ones
that start with api people and then we
pass
in the people we'll save it but there is
a problem
you see once we set up this router with
a base path in the people actually
we have a mess right now because we
already have the base
for our router in app js where we have
api people
and now in the people.js if you check it
out we actually have api people
forward slash api people so i fully
understand that
this is going to look a bit drastic
but in order for this to work we
actually remove everything we remove
that base
so we go here with just a forward slash
why well because we already have the
base here
we have api people so that's how the
route is going to start and then
we just have the forward slash so this
will match
whatever i have in the address and
since in the get and in a post both of
them just have api people
well i simply go with forward slash
again i fully understand that
this might look a bit confusing in the
beginning
but again the more routers you'll set up
the easier
it's going to get so this will just
match
whatever path i have here whatever base
path
i set up in my app.js so i'm just saying
yes i'm using this people router and in
the people
since i already have base path in place
i can simply
reference it using the forward slash so
this is going to match
whatever i have in app and
once i have spent what seems like an
eternity
on the base path i can keep on scrolling
and again notice
i have api people and then postman so
what's the only thing
that i need here it's just a postman
because i already have api people
so i remove this sucker here keep on
scrolling
then the same with id right we only care
about this one that's the whole point of
setting up the router
so we can start splitting up our
functionality
in multiple files same goes with
this last id and even though i think i
said that we're not going to use the
postman
i do want to quickly check and i'm going
to go with get simple if the get works
trust me
the other ones work as well so we go
here with api people
we send but unfortunately i get the
error
hmm that's interesting so let me check i
think the problem here
is in the app.js i don't have the
forward slash
so let me try this one let me send it
one more time
and there it is now of course everything
works
so my apologies i forgot to add here
forward slash
that's why we were getting the error and
of course everything works
i can go with get i can get my list
if i want i can also maybe delete a
person
so i'm going to go delete and we're
gonna test three
so let's see we send and as you can see
the
person with id of three is missing so as
you can see
our route works so that's the first step
so now
here's the challenge try to repeat the
same thing
with login now with login it is going to
be
a bit simpler because we don't have that
long of a path but again
stop the video and try to set up the
login yourself
and then once you're ready resume it and
we're going to do it together
how was it hopefully you were successful
and i'm going to give it a shot
so first remember we needed
a file so in this case i do have auth
js awesome so i'm just gonna
cut this sucker out from my app.js
and place it in off then of course i do
need to have the boilerplate
for the router so again let's go with
express
require we require the module by the
name of express of course
then we set up our router router
and that one is equal to express dot
router
we invoke it then we change this value
around like so and then
we're just gonna go with module
and then export and that one is equal
to our router we do this
then we navigate back to app.js and
we'll have to import it as well
so we go with auth i guess let's call it
that
and we're looking for auth file
that's where our router is coming in and
then of course
i just need to set up my middleware
myapp.use
where i provide a path of what
well of login and in this case i'm going
to be more careful and i will add the
forward slash
and of course i'll set it up as auth
so let's save this one and then the only
thing we need to do
in the login is simply change it around
where
i'm already handling the login in the
app.js so forward slash login
so again my route now is forward slash
login so i simply go with the forward
slash
i already covered the route in the
objects so
i don't need to do that anymore in here
and you know
for this sucker just to make things a
bit more interesting
why don't we use the browser now keep in
mind you can still use the postman if
you want
but i'm gonna go the browser out so
we're gonna go
with new window i'm gonna go with 5
000 here and of course this is going to
be the small screen
i have traditional form so let's go with
some kind of name
peter and i send and i have welcome
peter
and of course if that is the case i know
that my functionality works
so we are in good shape again probably
the
most confusing thing is this one where
we use
app.use to set up our route
so all the routes that will start with
this api people
are going to be located in the people.js
in the routes folder and in there
instead of using
app we use the router and then since we
already have the base
setup in the app.js when
we have a route that exactly matches the
base
we just go with forward slash now if
there is something else
after the base route so some additional
info
of course then we go with forward slash
which just means that we match the base
path
and then we add whatever value we want
and hopefully you can see how much
cleaner
is our app.js where now we're splitting
up the functionality
in separate files for our routes
beautiful i think we really clean up our
app js
but we're not out of the woods yet
if we take a look at our auth js yeah
this one looks somewhat clean but we
need to keep in mind that
we only have one request we only have
one post request
to our login however if we take a look
at
our people.js it is still somewhat of
a mess because we have a bunch of
functionality
since of course we have more routes and
of course a better setup
is if we would be able to split this up
into a separate file and i'm talking
about
the functions so imagine this scenario
where
we only would have a router then
i'm gonna set up my method whether
that's get post
or whatever then i'm still gonna have
the route but
the functionality this one the
controller
is going to be in a separate file so
it's going to be a separate function
and you'll see how much cleaner our file
is going to look like just in a second
so again we need to head back to our
express tutorial now i'll zoom in
i'll create a new folder and again
common convention is calling this
controllers
for the reason that there is a pattern
called
mvc so model view controller and then
again we come up with the name in my
case i'm going to go with
jobs or i'm sorry not jobs i'm going to
go with people
and i'm not gonna set up one for the
other one for the auth
since there's only one but for people i
will set up
a controllers file by the name of
people.js
and here i just to set up first
my functions and the way it's going to
work
we're going to go with const and then
again you just need to come up with a
name
so for example for get request where i'm
getting people
i'm just going to call this get people
keep in mind this is just a function
so the name is really up to you and
since i'm going to have the same
functionality of course i need to keep
in mind that
i do need to have access to rack and res
now it's really cool that once i pass
this function as a reference
it's still going to work so i simply go
here with this
rack res and set up the functionality
now probably faster
is just going to be doing like this
where i cut out
and then back into controllers i copy
and paste
now i know that some people might find
this annoying but yes
i'm purposely refactoring the code so
you can see the benefits
right away and i'm going to do that for
all the functions and
for a little bit it's gonna probably
look messy
where i'm gonna do the same thing for
the post
so i guess first i'm just gonna cut it
out and then
back in the controllers nothing routes
in the controllers
let's come up with that function as well
so const
and in this case i'm going to call this
create person
i'll copy and paste the code okay
awesome
back in the routes let's get the postman
one
so in a controller let's also call this
const
and create person and
postman like so copy and paste
that's my function then back in routes
i have one for put so i think
it would make sense if i call this
for example update person again cut out
everything starting with a function
and then all the way to the closing
parenthesis
cut it out back in controllers
we're going to call it const update
person
like so copy and paste and lastly
let's deal with a delete one as well
so let's keep scrolling again we cut
everything out
like so and then back in the controller
let's create one for deleting the person
so const
cons delete person
and copy and paste and if you remember
which
seems like an eternity go when we
covered
the exports i said that of course we can
also use right away
module exports and then whatever
so for example in this case that could
be get people or create person
or create person postman now in my case
i always prefer to do my exports all the
way on the bottom
where i say module exports now this is
going to be the object
and now i just want to access all the
functions keep in mind
it doesn't change the functionality
functionality is the same where i'm
basically exporting an object
with bunch of functions so here i just
need to reference their names
so it's get people it is create person
create person postman then update person
and lastly it is also for deleting the
person
now one thing that is missing of course
is the people like i said this is just
going to be temporary
so i'm going to go to the controller
here
and i'll copy and paste now in this case
the path is correct
because the route was already in a
separate folder
so that should still work
and of course now i can save my
controllers and in the routes
what i need to do is of course import
all of them
so in this case we go with const and
again i'll write away
the structure all of them so let me just
copy and paste i think it's going to be
faster
like so since the names of course are
going to be exactly the same
i destructure them and i'd structure
them from
require and then of course we're looking
for controllers
and then more specifically i'm looking
for the people
like so and once we have required them
of course now we pass
in the function reference so for example
here i can say
get people now i do need to add a comma
and if everything is correct our
functionality
is still going to work so in the
controllers
we're still accessing rack and arrays
and we're still sending back the
response but of course the benefit
of all of this work is the fact that
our routes file is gonna get much
cleaner
so in here remember the name was create
person
like so and then we have one for create
person postman and let's set it up like
so
then we have also one for update person
and lastly we have one for
the leading person right so we go here
with delete person
i save again i'm not gonna test all of
them out
but i'm gonna go with for example delete
and i'm gonna look for four this still
works
i remove the person number four and also
if i check out
the get one for the people this also
should get me back the array so i know
that my functionality still works but i
nicely cleaned out my file now
lastly before we talk about the
databases
i just want to mention that when it
comes to setting up the routes
we actually have two flavors so
i'm gonna comment these ones out and
i'll show you another way
how we can set up the routes and
effectively the benefit
is that we can set it up in fewer lines
of code
keep in mind the functionality is going
to be exactly the same
so again this is going to be the case
where it comes down to your preference
if you prefer setting up your routes
this way you can definitely do so
there's no rule against it
if you prefer the method that i'm about
to show you
then of course you can use that one
instead
so we go with a router and then we go
with
route and then in the route i set up the
path and again since there's
get and post that match exactly what i
have in base
same situation i just set up the forward
slash and
instead of setting up them separately
for example get
and post i can just chain them so chain
one after another so i go with get that
is of course
my method that is not changing and then
i need to pass
in my controller function okay
as you can see almost the same in this
case however
i can change it now the method names did
not change
the paths did not change they're still
actually
referencing the base path in here what
we have in app.js
but since we can chain it we can simply
write it in one line of code
so of course the callback function is
gonna be
create and i believe it was person so
create
and person like so then we have of
course
one for the postman so in this case of
course it's not going to change
it's pretty much going to be the same
logic where we go the router
route like so and then we go with
forward slash
postman and then of course i want to
chain dot
and i believe it was post right and then
we go with
create person postman and then we can
again
set up one line of code for the put
and delete so in this case i think i'm
going to just copy
where i have router dot route then we
set up
our route and in this case it is going
to be forward slash
and then id and then we have two
we have one for put and we have one
for delete so we go with delete and then
as far as the callback functions
we go with update person
and also we have delete person
and finally let me just stress it one
more time
where whichever setup you choose is
really up to your preference
functionality is exactly the same
we go with router route and then we can
just
chain our methods and add the callback
functions
now in this case we set up each route
separately so for example if you have
multiple
urls that match yeah you're in good
shape you can just
set up router route pass in the url
and then chain all the methods and
lastly let me just quickly test it one
more time since i made some changes
i send it and there it is i successfully
get back my people so with this in place
with our router in place with the fact
that we have covered all the methods
the get post put and delete
i think we're ready for the next level
where we connect our server